GOOD AFTERNOON --
WE ARE GOING TO CONVENE THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON S. B.
NINE NO ONE DIED AND TODAY'S
CONVERSATION WILL FOCUS ON WHILE
FOR FUELS REDUCTION.
AND LET ME JUST SAY THAT --
AS THE COMMITTEE IS --
MOVING INTO ITS FOURTH MEETING
HOW WE CLEARLY ARE --
WITH A LOT OF THE FOCUS HAS BEEN
ON THE ISSUE OF STRICT LIABILITY --
BUT THERE IS OF VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
DEALING WITH TODAY THAT I THINK.
IS GOING TO BEAR A LOT OF
HEAVINESS AND AND ALSO OUR
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE COMPLETE
MEANT COMPLETED BEST OF THIS.
COMMITTEES WORK AND AND SO WE
KNOW THAT THE ISSUES OF FUEL AND
REDUCING THE FUEL.
AND IN OUR WILDERNESS AREA IS A
CRITICAL.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO NOT
ONLY THOSE WHO ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY AS WITNESSES BUT ALSO.
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMITTEE WHO
HAVE BEEN DEALING OF WITH THIS
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS CERTAINLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD I HAVE
A PUT A GREAT DEAL OF FOCUS
APPROPRIATELY SO ON THIS TOPIC
IN THE COMMITTEE.
WILL BE LOOKING A TO THEIR
COMMENTS A TODAY'S WELL ABOUT TO
START OFF I WILL BEFORE WE
INTRODUCE THE FIRST PANEL --
I TO MY CULTURE TO SEE IF HE HAS
ANY OPENING COMMENTS.
I LIKE TO ASSIST.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH MY CO CHAIRMAN.
YOU'RE NOT LAUGHING SO YOU
PROBABLY WORK AT THE LAST
MEETING. ONE PERSON ARE.
HOW SO LET'S GO FORWARD --
TO DISCUSS THE BACKGROUND ON
FIRE PREVENTION AND PENDING
LEGISLATION OF THAT PANEL WILL
CONSIST OF SCOTT STEVENS
PROFESSOR FIRE SCIENCE UC
BERKELEY.
A CRAIG THOMAS CONSERVATION
DIRECTOR SIERRA FOREST LEGACY.
AND WILLIAM CRAVEN CHIEF
CONSULTANT SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE.
MICHAEL JARED SENIOR CONSULTANT
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES.
IF YOU COULD ALL COME FORWARD.
AND WE YOU CAN LEAD OFF IN THE
ORDER THAT YOU RECALL
.
GOOD MORNING ARTS AFTERNOON
SCOTT STEVENS FROM UC BERKELEY
I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
TO TALK A LITTLE ABOUT AND FIRED
FUELS.
FIRST THING I WAS GONNA SPEAK TO
ASSIST A FEW SUCCESS STORIES NO
ONE HERE BUT FIRED FUELS IN.
WHAT'S GOING ON OUTSIDE RIGHT
NOW YOU ALWAYS WONDER IS THERE
ANY SUCCESSES OUT THERE AND THEY
REALLY ARE SUCCESSES BOTH THE
UNITED STATES AND THE WORLD I
WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT JUST FOR A
MOMENT.
WHEN PLACES FLORIDA THE STATE OF
FLORIDA IS THE LEADER A
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND FUEL HAZARD
MANNER MANAGEMENT IN THE UNITED
STATES?
WE THINK FOR OF ALL PLACES FOR
THE VERY PYRO CENTRIC STATE LOT
OF FIRE THEY BURNED ONE POINT
TWO MILLION ACRES LAST YOU
PRESCRIBE BURNING.
THEY DID PRETTY WELL THEY DID
HAVE ONE ESCAPE THAT ACTUALLY
THE TRAGEDY ONE THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED ABOUT FORTY YEARS.
STILL THEY DO A LOT OF GOOD WORK
IN FLOOR AND IT SHOWS IS THAT
IT'S POSSIBLE TO MAYBE DO MORE
PROACTIVE FUELS MANAGEMENT IN A
PLACE WITH THE HAS INCREDIBLE
BIG.
WHILE IN URBAN INTERFACE WESTERN
AUSTRALIA WESTERN AUSTRALIA
PERTH IS ANOTHER AREA OF THE
WORLD WHERE.
BIG PRESCRIBED FIRE PROGRAM THEY
BRING ONE TO THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES AROUND PERTH
PERTH HAS OVER MILLION PEOPLE.
SO THEY HAVE THIS INCREDIBLE
FIFTY YEAR PROGRAM OF ACTUALLY
DOING PROACTIVE BURNING AND
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO ECOSYSTEMS
ANOTHER PLACE THAT ANOTHER
SUCCESS STORY.
ENTER THE FORCE YOU KNOW WE SAW
THE HIGH MORTALITY ADVANCE OF
THAT SOUTHERN SIERRA LAST FEW
YEARS AND HUNDRED MILLION TREES
PLUS DYING AND THEN THERE ARE
THE PLACES WE ACTUALLY SEE THAT
FORCED A MUCH MORE RESILIENT
WHEN THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A LOWER
DENSITIES MORE HAD ORIGINATING
MORE VARIABILITY. ONE SUCH PLACE
THIS YEAR'S AND PAGE MARK HERE
NORTHERN WESTERN MEXICO AND
WORKING ON THEIR TWENTY YEARS.
THAT PLACE HAS THE SAME DROUGHT
TO GET BURNED BY WILDFIRES WE GO
DOWN THERE EVERY TIME I GO DOWN
THERE I AM INSPIRED.
BECAUSE OF JUST THE INCREDIBLE
RESILIENCE THAT FORCED. THREE
YEAR DROUGHT FALL BY A WILDFIRE
80% THE TREES SURVIVE.
SO IF TO PLACE IT ACTUALLY EVERY
TIME I GO THERE WAS THERE ABOUT
TWO MONTHS AGO FOR PUBLIC THE
TWENTIETH TIME EVERY TIME I GO
THERE AND WORK.
I JUST REALIZED WHAT CALIFORNIA
FORCE COULD BE.
WITH A LOOK AT MORE ACTIVITY IN
TERMS OF MANAGEMENT FEELS
TREATMENT.
ELECTRIC BASS AND HAS A PLACE IN
THE SEMI NATIONAL PARK HAS BEEN
MANAGED BY LIGHTNING FIRE FOR
FORTY FIVE YEARS SO THIS IS AN
AREA REMOTE COUNTRY WHERE YOU
CAN PUT FIRE ON THE GROUND BY
LIGHTNING ALLOW IT TO BURN.
MOST TIME FIRES GOING ON THEIR
OWN.
THEY'VE HIT EACH OTHER AND THEY
SIMPLY GO OUT AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING UP THERE FOR MANY YEARS
AND WE SEE THE HEADERS AND
EIGHTEEN ALSO THE LOWER
DENSITIES HIGH DENSITY AREAS.
AND THERE'S ACTUALLY SEEM TO BE
A CO BENEFIT WERE SEEN MORE
WATER COMING FROM THE WATERSHEDS
VILLA CREEK.
SO WE SEEM TO HAVE A WATER COULD
BENEFIT. ONE OTHER THING I MIGHT
TO SAY IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE DONE
SOME WORK HERE IN BLODGETT
FORCED BLODGETT FORCES THE UC
BERKELEY RESEARCH FORCE WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT FEEL TREATMENTS
BOTH THINNING.
PRESCRIBED BURNING THINNING AND
PRESCRIBE BRING TOGETHER.
WE WORKED UP THERE ALMOST TWENTY
YEARS ON THIS AND WE'VE REALLY
COME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT THE
FUEL TREATMENTS DESIGNED FOR
RESTORATION THE TARGET LADDER
FUELS SMALLER TREES.
ECOLOGICALLY ARE DOING ANY HARM
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT REALLY HOW
YOU MIGHT DO AN IMPLEMENTATION
FORCE IN CALIFORNIA BLODGETT
SHOWS US THAT WE CAN DO A LOT OF
GOOD WORK AND REALLY HAVE NO
ECOLOGICAL.
PROBLEMS IN TERMS OF THOSE FORCE.
SO WHAT ABOUT A COUPLE QUICK
THINGS ABOUT CALIFORNIA WHAT
THINGS MIGHT WE WANT TO THINK
ABOUT IF WE GO FORWARD.
CALIFORNIA HAS ITS VEGETATION
TREATMENT PROGRAM ENVIRONMENT
IMPACT REPORT THIS IS BEEN
SOMETHING GOING ON FOR ABOUT
FIVE YEARS OR LONGER THIS IS A
PROGRAMMATIC.
DOCUMENT THAT WILL ACTUALLY
ALLOW.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO PLAN
PROGRAMS IMPLEMENT PRESCRIBED
BURNING MORE EFFICIENTLY.
IT'S BEEN STUCK IN THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS --
WE ACTUALLY GET A PEER REVIEW
FOR THAT FOR THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
SCIENCE CONSORTIUM ABOUT. THREE
FOUR YEARS AGO OUTSIDE PANEL
HELD PUBLIC MEETINGS THE
DOCUMENTS SEEM TO BE PRETTY GOOD
SHAPE BUT IT IS SOMEHOW STUCK IN
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AT THAT
CAME OUT I THINK WE COULD
ACTUALLY SEE SOMETHING POSITIVE.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE I
THINK ABOUT THINGS COULD HAPPEN.
I THINK MANY OF US MIGHT TALK
ABOUT THE PACE AND SCALE
TREATMENTS ON THE ADVOCATE FOR
TRYING TO DO MORE TRYING TO DO
BETTER IN TERMS IT ECOLOGICALLY
DOING FUEL TREATMENT BECAUSE WE
AREN'T DOING ENOUGH.
ESPECIALLY IN FORCE WE TALK
ABOUT TROUBLING TO DEFER
CONVERSATION UNFORTUNATELY WE
TALK ABOUT FORCE WE CAN DO A LOT
BETTER BACK OF THE ENVELOPE
CALCULATION WE NEED TO DO FIVE
TO TEN TIMES MORE PER YEAR. TO
REALLY GET A HANDLE ON THIS AND
WE COULD DO IT ECOLOGICALLY.
NOTHING I WOULDN'T MENTION IS IF
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT TRYING TO
BREACH THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
KNOW WE HAVE URBAN WHILE AN
INTERFACE WE HAVE FORCE
RESILIENCY PROBLEMS.
UNIVERSAL CALIFORNIA HAS AN
EXTENSION SERVICE FOR WE HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY DO OUTREACH
WE DO THIS AND THINGS LIKE RAIN
SCIENCE WE GET IN AGRICULTURE WE
GET A LOT OF DIFFERENT FIELDS.
WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
DUDE AND FIRE.
SITE ONE THING I THINK WOULD BE
INTERESTING BECAUSE MAYBE HAVE A
FOCUSED OUTREACH PROGRAM THAT
ACTUALLY [inaudible]
IN COUNTIES PEOPLE OF MASTER'S
DEGREES THAT WOULD WORK
COLLECTIVELY WITH CITY COUNCIL'S
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS PUBLICS AND
BRING THE IDEAS OF WHAT YOU
MIGHT BE ABLE TO LOCALLY AND TRY
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
LIKE US ALL THE PROBABLY WOULD
REDUCE THE PROBLEM.
I'VE SEEN THIS HAPPEN IN SO MANY
OTHER PARTS OF KIND OF NATURIST
HORSES WE KNOW ENOUGH TO DATE
THAT WE COULD ACTUALLY HELP
PEOPLE PREPARE FOR FIRE AND DO
BETTER.
SO I THINK THIS IDEA PUTTING
PEOPLE IN NATURAL RESOURCE
FIELDS INTO COUNTIES WHERE
PEOPLE LIVE WOULD BE A REALLY
INTERESTING WAY TO GO AND GIVE
US A CALIFORNIA'S HAD SOME
SUCCESS WITH SOME OTHER PROGRAMS
LIKE THAT.
MISTER STEVENS AND I HATE TO
INTERRUPT YOUR AYE I SHOULD HAVE
SAID AT THE VERY BEGINNING WE'RE
GOING TO ALLEN FIVE MINUTES TO
EACH THE PRISONERS.
AND SO HAVING NOT GIVING YOU
THAT A PRE WARNING IF YOU
CONCLUDE IN THE NEXT AND I AM
LIKE THAT WAS ACTUALLY MY LAST
LITTLE COMMENT SO THE ONLY THING
I'D ACTUALLY WANT TO CLOSE WITH
THIS HOPE.
YOU NO BECAUSE I CAN'T AGAIN I
FEEL SOMETIMES WITH ON CLIMATE
CHANGE WE HAVE THIS I GET THE
NEW NORMAL.
IS THIS THE NEW NORMAL THAT'S AN
INTERESTING TOPIC THE IDEA OF
NEW NORMAL KIND OF FEELS LIKE TO
ME WERE KIND OF GIVEN UP.
I THINK THAT THE NEW NORMAL
ACTUALLY CANCEL HAVE INCREDIBLE
INPUT FROM MANAGEMENT AND
CREATIVITY THAT WE COULD
ACTUALLY DO BETTER IN THE FUTURE
SO I'M VERY HOPEFUL WHEN IT
COMES A FIRE IN THE STATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CRAIG THOMAS WAS
AIRFORCE LEGACY AND I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR INVITING ME
TODAY --
I'LL SPEAK TO THREE THINGS
QUICKLY FIRE PREVENTION FIRE
PLANNING [inaudible]
FOREST HEALTH.
FIRE PREVENTION IS ABOUT
PREVENTING UNCHARACTERISTIC FIRE.
WHILE EXPANDING THE BENEFICIAL
USES A FIRE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE POINT IS THE FIRST POINT IS
THAT CALIFORNIA POLICY MAKERS
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT CALIFORNIA SCIENTISTS AND
LAND MANAGERS ALREADY KNOW FIRE
HAS PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
SHAPING AND BUILDING RESILIENCE
IN THE DIVERSE LANDSCAPES OF OUR
STATE FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
YEARS?
WE NEED TO WORK ON LIMITING
UNCHARACTERISTIC DAMAGING FIRES
WHILE SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDING
THE ROLE OF BENEFICIAL FIRE FROM
MULTIPLE RESOURCE BENEFITS.
THOSE BENEFITS INCLUDE
[inaudible]
ECOLOGICAL RESILIENCE.
CARBON STABILITY REDUCED
EMISSIONS AND IMPACTS ON PUBLIC
HEALTH AND FINALLY COMMUNITY
PROTECTION.
WE ALL KNOW THIS.
AND THIS YEAR'S LEGISLATIVE
SEASON PARTICULARLY --
I'LL CALL IT SENATOR JACKSON'S
COMPREHENSIVE FIRE BILL WE'VE
REALLY MOVE THE BALL IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION WE NEED TO
KEEP THIS UP. FOR EVER IN THE
STATE UNTIL WE GET THIS
LANDSCAPE RESTORED.
IN TERMS OF AND I'VE LISTED A
BUNCH OF IN THE HAND OUT A LIST
OF THE BUNCH OF REFERENCES THAT
YOU MIGHT WANNA LOOK AT THERE'S
TREMENDOUS WORK GOING ON RIGHT
NOW AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT ONE
OF THEM --
AND THAT IS THE FIRE IN WILL YOU
PARTNERSHIP WHICH IS THIRTY
THREE PARTNERS NOW IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING CAL FIRE AND SEE YOU
IN ABOUT A CONSERVANCY FOR
SERVICE.
AND OF UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AN ASTOUNDING THING IS WE'RE
FROM TO AND A SIGN OF PROGRESS
THAT WE HAVE THREE AIR DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE JOINED.
THE FIRE I AM ARE YOU
PARTNERSHIP TO PROMOTE EXPANDING
FIRE USE FOR ECOLOGICAL AND
OTHER BENEFITS.
IN TERMS OF FIRE PLANNING.
I THINK THE FIRST PRINCIPAL
NEEDS TO BE THAT THERE IS NO NO
FIRE OPTION IN CALIFORNIA. TO
UNDERSTAND THAT AND THEN WE
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THE USE OF
THE STATE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH OPR WILDFIRE PLANNING
GUIDELINES TO LINK IS LISTED
THERE.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO BE ON
THE TABLE IN ALL THESE
ADOPTED
OF ALL COUNTY GENERAL PLANS.
WITH PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO
FIRE HISTORY FIRE REGIME
TOPOGRAPHY SLOPE BUILDING
MATERIALS EMERGENCY ACCESS AND
MORE.
RIGID LINES SHOULD BE FOR OPEN
SPACE AND BIKE TRAILS NOT
DENSELY PACKED MILLION DOLLAR
HOMES.
THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENT
IS ANOTHER ISSUE THAT COMES UP A
LOT WHEN WE'RE IN RURAL AREAS
MANY OF YOU COME FROM RURAL
LANDSCAPES.
IT'S MANDATORY IT'S NOT OPTIONAL
BUT WE'RE STILL ACTING LIKE IT'S
OPTIONAL.
IT IS MANDATORY HOME CLEARANCE
WORK NEEDS TO BE SUPPORTED FOR
THOSE WHO CAN'T AFFORD IT TO GET
THE WORK DONE [inaudible]
AND WE ARE IN A PUBLIC SAFETY
CRISIS AND HOPE PROTECTION IS
NOT OPTIONAL WE NEED TO SUPPORT
FOLKS BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
MANDATE REQUIRE THAT IT GETS
DONE.
HOME HARDENING IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL AND THIS PENDING
LEGISLATION IN FRONT OF
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR IT HAS A
LOT TO SAY ABOUT SUPPORTING HOME
HARDENING IN EXPANDING RESOURCES
TO PROTECT HOMES.
ADDITIONAL WATER SUPPLIES
MAINTAIN CLEARANCE RETROFITTED
HOMES COMMUNITY WIDE EFFORTS TO
CREATE LARGER LANDSCAPES.
ARE ALL IMPORTANT THINGS IN
TERMS OF BUILDING FIRE
RESILIENCE IN THE MOVIE IN
PARTICULAR.
DOING THE WORK AND AND UP DON'T
ALWAYS EXPECT AN ENGINE THAT'S
GOING TO COME AND SAVE YOU.
IT OFTEN IS NOT THE CASE WE HAVE
TO TAKE PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY
FOR LIVING IN THESE FIRE SO
CHEATED LANDSCAPES.
I WANT A SECOND WHAT SCOTT SAID
BRIEFLY ABOUT THE EXPANDED ROLE
OF YOU SEE FIRE ADVISORS.
PROVIDING DIRECT SUPPORT TO
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS TO RESTORE
FIRE ON THEIR LANDS OR BY
FORMING PRESCRIBED BURN
ASSOCIATIONS WERE COMMUNITIES
WORK TOGETHER TO EXPAND FIRE
RESTORATION AT THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL.
WERE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CONCEPT I PERSONALLY ATTENDED A
WORKSHOP THAT WASN'T.
CREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL IN BUILDING
AND BRINGING THE COMMUNITY
TOGETHER THAT KNEW.
SOMETHING ABOUT FIRE BUT THEY
HAVE ACTUAL GROUP TORCH IN THEIR
HANDS AND WORKING TO REDUCE
FUELS ON THEIR PROPERTY WAS
AMAZING.
LAST THING IS FOR US HEALTH AND
NOW OFFER THAT FIRE RESILIENCE.
AND FOREST HEALTH OR NOT
SEPARATE ISSUES.
THE ORIGIN OF FOREST HEALTH IN
CALIFORNIA BEYOND NATURAL
BACKGROUND LEVELS OF PROBLEMS.
IS A DIRECT RESULT OF HISTORIC
FIRE EXCLUSION IN THE HIGH
GRADING AND CLEAR CUTTING OF
LARGE FIRE RESILIENT TREES.
ABSENT THE REINTRODUCTION OF
PLAN FIRE AS A MAJOR MANAGEMENT
TOOL AN INCREASE PROTECTIONS AND
INCENTIVES FOR LARGE TO RESTORE
LARGE ECOLOGICALLY APPROPRIATE
TREES WE WILL NEVER REACH.
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF NEVER
REACH RESILIENCE ON A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE.
WERE MECHANICAL TREATMENTS ARE
REQUIRED OVERLY DENSE STANDS
UNCHARACTERISTIC DENSE TREES
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S A BROAD SCIENTIFIC
CONSENSUS THAT TREATING LADDER
FUELS SHOULD STILL BE THE
PRIMARY CONCERN.
THE SURFACE ON LADDER FUELS
SHOULD BE THE PRIMARY CONCERN IN
TARGET FOR LIMITING FIRE
BEHAVIOR SMALLER TREES UP TO
SIXTEEN TO EIGHTEEN INCHES IN
DIAMETER MAKE UP THE MAJORITY OF
THAT COMPONENT.
FINALLY THE THING THE NEGLECTED
STEPCHILD OF ALL OF OUR REAR
RESTORATION EFFORTS IS
MAINTAINING THE BENEFITS THAT WE
PRODUCED ON THE LANDSCAPE I'VE
GOT A THIRTY YEAR HISTORY.
OF WITNESSING WORK BEING DONE
SOME OF IT NOT GREAT SOME OF IT
GREAT SOME OF IT WE HAD A DIRECT
HAND IN.
BUT THE FAILURE TO COME BACK AND
MAINTAIN THAT RESILIENCE IS A
ECOLOGICAL AND SOCIAL TRAGEDY
FOR ALL THE SOCIAL CAPITAL AND
DOLLARS THAT WE'VE INVESTED. TO
FIRE AS A PRIMARY MAINTENANCE
TOOL IN THESE TREATMENTS SHOULD
NOT BE THOUGHT OF AS DOES A OR
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT WE JUST
PUT OFF ON THE SIDE OF THE TABLE
AND FORGET ABOUT ITS FREQUENT
FIRE AND RESTORING SELF LIMITING
EFFECTS OF NATURAL FIRE.
WOULD ALSO LIMIT
UNCHARACTERISTIC OF BY OF TREES
THAT WE SEE ON THIS LANDSCAPE
NOW THAT ARE CAUSING THE BIG
FIRE BEHAVIOR PROBLEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PRESCRIBE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
BILL CRAVEN WITH THE SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE MICHAEL AND I HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE A QUICK
SURVEY. TO THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
OF ALL THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN
DONE.
ON THE GENERAL TOPIC OF
PREVENTION --
IN THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR AND
THE TAKE AWAY HOPE WHEN WE'RE
BOTH FINISHED.
IS THAT A LOT OF MEMBERS AND A
LOT OF STAFF.
AND A LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
BEEN VERY COOPERATIVE IN PUTTING
TOGETHER.
THESE BILLS --
YOU HAVE TWO HANDOUTS FROM US
ONE AND DESCRIBES THE BILLS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT.
THE SECOND --
DESCRIBES ALL OF THEIR PONTS IN
EACH BILL.
THE FIRST HAND OUT ALSO INCLUDES
ALL THE WORK THAT WAS DONE ON
THIS TOPIC IN THE RECENTLY
APPROVED BUDGET.
WHICH IS --
ALSO A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
WORK BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADDRESSING PREVENTION --
WE'RE BASS OR MOSTLY GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE BILLS THAT WE
HAVE HELPED SHAPE --
THIS SESSION BUT BEFORE I DO
THAT I WANT TO MENTION THAT
THERE ARE.
OTHER BILLS --
THAT YOU SHOULD BE AWARE OF
FIRST IS SENATOR MONIES BILL S.
B. CAN SEVENTY NINE THAT
AUTHORIZES ADVANCE PAYMENTS.
THAT FOR VARIOUS FORESTRY GRANTS --
FUNDED BY A CAP AND TRADE RIGID
YOUR FANS.
THAT'S ALL I'M ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING --
MISTER PATTERSON'S BILL AB
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR EXTENDS AN
EXEMPTION --
SO THAT LANDOWNERS CAN REMOVE --
TREES THAT THREATENED STRIKE --
ARM.
SOMEHOW THAT BILLS ALREADY TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK --
THE GUY.
YEAH AND ALSO THERE'S A BILL ON
SENATE INACTIVE BY MISS
CABALLERO A BEFORE --
TWENTY FIVE I WOULDN'T BE A BIT
SURPRISED IF THAT BILL BECOMES
REACTIVATED --
TO CONTAIN.
ADDITIONAL PROVISIONS --
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT MISTER
DALI IS A CO AUTHOR OF THAT BILL --
SO OF THE BILLS THAT --
MICHAEL AND I WORKED ON I JUST
WANNA START WITH --
A MAJOR EFFORT BY SENATOR
JACKSON SP.
TWELVE SIXTY THAT TOUCHES BOTH
ON LOCAL PLANNING AND PRESCRIBED
FIRE -- FOR
FOR LOCAL PLANNING --
IT BASICALLY APPROVED IMPROVE
THE CONSULTATION PROCESS BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY.
AND REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO REFLECT THE OPR GUIDANCE THAT --
CRAIG MENTIONED EARLIER --
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN STILL
AND HER CONSTRUED MEET OR EXCEED
STATE REGULATIONS AND SOME LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE DONE SO --
MICHAEL'S GOING TO TALK ABOUT --
THOSE OTHER BILLS A DEAL
PROVISIONS.
BUT ON THE TOPIC A PRESCRIBED
FIRE SENATOR JACKSON'S BILL.
CONTAINS SEVERAL PIECES THAT I
THINK -- IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR YOU KNOW OF
THE FIRST GIG AUTHORIZES THEM A
AGREEMENTS BY THE DEPARTMENT
HELLFIRE AND LANDOWNERS TO
UNDERTAKE PRESCRIBED FIRE.
IT BUILDS ON THE ALLOCATION IN
THE BUDGET THAT I JUST MENTIONED
KRUEGER DISTRICTS PUBLIC
EDUCATION ON PRESCRIBED FIRES
NEW EQUIPMENT SO THAT.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING THE
BURNING HAVE THE BEST AVAILABLE
WEATHER HUMIDITY.
AND WIND INFORMATION --
AND THERE ARE DEDICATED CREWS
NOW TO CAL FIRE FOR PRESCRIBED
FIRES THAT'S A HUGE STEP --
IT ELEVATES CALIFORNIA'S RULE IN
ADMINISTERING PRESCRIBED FIRES
ACROSS THE STATE REQUIRES A
CURRICULUM AND TRAINING
CURRICULUM PRESCRIBED FIRE.
THE REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT. TO
COOPERATE WITH PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC LANDOWNERS.
STREAMLINED AND IT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW A
PRESCRIBED FIRE PROJECTS BY
ALLOWING TEARING FROM THAT HE
AYE ARE IS THAT --
DOCTOR STEVENS JUST MENTIONED.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT.
PROJECTS TO TEAR FROM THE CI OUR
WINNER GETS FINALIZED --
CAN RELY ON THAT YEAH I ARE FOR
ITS -- FOR
THE MITIGATION.
IDENTIFIED IMPACTS AND IF YOU
IMPACTS HAVE NOT BEEN IDENTIFIED
OR MITIGATED PARA PROVIDE FOR
MITIGATION.
IN THAT HE AYE ARE IN THE
PROJECT WOULD HAVE TO FULFILL --
COVERED IN THE DRAFT.
AND SO WE'RE STILL IN
NEGOTIATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION REGARDING --
SPECIAL PROTECTIONS FOR
CHAPARRAL IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
BUT THIS IS PROBABLY --
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT PRESCRIBED
FIRE BILL OF THE YEAR IN LEAST
IN MY VIEW --
I WANT TO BRIEFLY MENTION TWO
OTHER BILLS.
FIRST -- AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY AND WILL BE
DISCUSSED IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
FINAL PANEL BUT THE IDEA IS.
THAT WE NEED TO USE SMALLER
DIAMETER TREES WE NEED TO TAKE
HIM OUT OF THE FOREST YOU DO USE
THEM CONSTRUCTIVELY.
WE NEED TO JUMPSTART THE
INDUSTRIES AND INCUBATE THE
INDUSTRIES OF THAT CAN USE THESE
TREES FOR CONSTRUCTIVE PURPOSES
IN IN IN THE STATE --
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST MISTER
WOODS BILL AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
ONE ADDS PROVISIONS FOR
REGARDING PRESCRIBED FIRE
CONTAINS PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW
LOANS TO SMALL LANDOWNERS.
UNDER THE
BATES YOU WE
APPRECIATE.
AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION I THINK THAT ALL
WILL AGREE THAT IT'S A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE AND GIVES US A
GOOD VIEW OF THE KIND OF WORK
THAT'S BEING.
UNDER WAY AMONGST OTHER MEMBERS.
WE WILL --
TURNED TO MEMBERS OF YOUR
HOUSING [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
PAST SIMON'S MICHAEL JAROD I
WORK FOR THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE --
AND I'M GONNA GO THROUGH THE THE
REST OF THE BILLS IN THE HAND
OUT -- JUST
AS SOME INTRODUCTORY REMARKS YOU
KNOW I'VE WORKED AT A RESOURCE
COMMITTEE FOR A COUPLE YEARS AND
IS A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
LEGISLATION --
THIS YEAR THAT'S GONE FOR
COMMITTEE ON FIRE PREVENTION
FIRE PLANNING AND FORCED HEALTH
WE'VE ALSO SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN AND RESOURCES THAT --
PORTRAYED THE BUCK BUDGET FOR
THOSE ISSUES --
THE FIRST GIRL I'D LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT IS --
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SIX BY SOME A
MEMBER LOW MOUNT --
THIS BILL CREATES [inaudible]
THE YEAR ROUND FIRE PREVENTION
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WHAT IT DOES IS IT EXPANDS A
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANT PROGRAM.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A YEAR
ROUND ROBUST FIRE PROVISION
PREVENTION EFFORT IN THE AND
THEN THE STATE.
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO AND
WHAT THEIR TIME THE LOCAL
CAPACITY --
TO GIVE GRANTS TO FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS AND YOU SEE
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION TO DO ON
MULTI YEAR EFFORTS TO REALLY
INCREASE THE LOOK THE LOCAL
CAPACITY --
FOR FIRE PREVENTION AND WHEN I
SAY FIRE PREVENTION I MEAN IS A
FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS --
FIRE HARDENING --
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH PLANNING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS --
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES --
ADVANCE PAYMENT AUTHORITY FOR A
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS THAT CAN
HELP --
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO PER TO PROVIDE THE
RE --
FUNDING UP FRONT FOR THE WORK --
IN ADDITION --
THE BILL PRIORITIZES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEEMED TO DO --
SERVE ALL THE BEST PRACTICES FOR
BEING A PROACTIVE ON FIRE
PREVENTION.
AND THE NEXT BILL IS AB TWENTY
NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON --
YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE HEARD A LOT
OF FIRE UP PRESCRIBED FIRE IN US
SENATOR JACKSON'S BILLS A HUGE
STEP FORWARD ON THAT ISSUE.
BITE OUT THIS ATTACK --
GOES AFTER ANOTHER ISSUE WHICH
IS INSURANCE FOR PRIVATE
PRESCRIBERS THEY HAVE TO GET
INSURANCE POLICIES TO DO THEIR
PRIVATE A PRESCRIBED BURN IN
WITH THIS BILL WOULD DO FOR A
FIVE YEAR PERIOD.
IS ALLOW --
CAO FIRE --
TO DEVELOP A POOR SO THAT ALL
THE PREVENT PRIVATE PRIVATE
PRESCRIBE BURNERS GOOD TO GET
TOGETHER AND HOPEFULLY GET A
LOWER RATE FOR THEIR INSURANCE
TO DO MORE PRESCRIBED FIRE.
TIME AND EXPEL ARE GONNA GO OVER
IS AB.
TWENTY NINE ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN --
THIS BILL DEALS WITH A FIRE --
SMART PLANNING --
IT.
IT ALSO ADVOCATES --
FOR AT A TYPE OF UTILITY
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT CALLED
RIGHT TREE RIGHT PLACE THIS IS
THE CONCEPT --
THAT IF WE ARE TO PLANK
COMPATIBLE VEGETATION BELOW
UTILITY LINES THAT WOULD NOT AT
ITS MATURITY GROW UP INTO THE
LINES TO GET AVOID SOME --
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT COSTS --
IT ALSO.
CLOSES SOME LOOPHOLES ON MAKING
SURE THAT COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
VERY FIRE HIGHER HIGHER FIGHT HI
FI.
YEAH THIS IS A TOP WE IF THE TOP
BACK IN ABOUT FIVE BUT
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE HIGH FIRE
DANGER.
THAT THEY GET THE POOR PROPER
ORDINANCES PASSED NOW THE PROPER
RULES IN PLACE AND IN ADDITION --
IN MAKE SURE THAT THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY HAS ALL THE DOCUMENTS
THAT IT NEEDS IN ORDER TO AND
FOR STATE LAW WE HAVE A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD --
FIRE PLANNING LAWS ON THE BOOKS
BUT NOT THE FULL BOARD FOR SHE
DOESN'T ALWAYS HAVE INFORMATION
NEEDS. TO ENFORCE THOSE LAWS ON
THE BILL ALSO HAS THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL --
UPDATE BUILDING STANDARDS BASED
ON THE I'VE LEARNED --
AND PROVIDE A LIST OF LOW COST
RETROFITS --
SO THE LIST OF LOW COST
RETROFITS WILL BE HELPFUL IN
THAT -- ONCE
THAT LIST IS DEVELOPED --
HELLFIRE CAN --
HOW REACH TO COMMUNITIES ABOUT
WHAT THOSE LOW COST RECTOR RIGHT
FITS ARE AND THAT GRANTS CAN BE
PROVIDED TO HELP COMMUNITIES --
IMPLEMENT THEM [inaudible]
AND IN ADDITION --
THE THE BILL --
IMPROVES EVACUATION EFFORTS
THERE'S A LOT OF COMMUNITIES OUT
THERE THAT DON'T HAVE --
SAFE WAYS TO GET OUT OUT OF
THEIR COMMUNITY WHEN THERE'S A
FIRE ON AND THERE'S REGULATIONS
RIGHT NOW FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION
BUT THERE'S ALREADY EXISTING
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY.
BE IN TROUBLE IF THERE'S A FIRE
NOT BE ABLE TO EVACUATE SO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IDENTIFY THOSE
COMMUNITIES --
AND PROVIDE SOLUTIONS FOR THEM
ON HOW TO MAKE SURE THEY CAN
ESCAPE IF THERE'S A FIRE --
IN ADDITION --
THE BILL PROVIDES --
ACCESS FOR UTILITIES TO DO THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WORK THAT
THEY NEED TO DO --
AND IT TAKES A SIMILAR
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENTS
THAT THAT ACCESS NEEDS TO BE
GIVEN OR A FINE CAN BE ISSUED --
THOUGHTS GOING TO TALK ABOUT IS
THE AS A NEW BILL IT WAS JUST
RECENTLY AMENDED --
A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON --
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
CREATES A LIST OF ALL THE
COMMUNITIES THAT --
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN.
TO I REDUCE FIRE RISK AND ALLOWS --
THAT LIST TO BE PUBLICIZED --
SO THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN CREATE
AT THE COMPETITION AND HOPEFULLY
HAVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DOING
MORE BEST PRACTICES AND AND IT
FITS TOGETHER WITH THE WOMAN
BILL ON THAT ONCE THOSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MADE THAT LIST OF
THE PRIORITIZE FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS.
ON THE BILL ALSO APPROPRIATES
OUT FUNDING FOR YOU SEE SCIENCE
ADVISERS WHICH WERE RECOMMENDED
EARLIER IN THE PANEL.
AND IT EXTENDS REGULATIONS
BEYOND THAT'S ARE A TO LOCAL
AREAS THAT ARE AT VERY BY HIGHER.
HAS RISK --
FINALLY IT UPDATES REGULATIONS --
AT THE BORDER FOR ST UNPROVED
FIRE SAFETY AND HEALTH SO AS ARE
THE REMAINDER OF THE BILL'S YOUR
HAND OUT RUN.
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WILL TURN TO MEMBERS.
CERTAIN THANK YOU YES I
APPRECIATE THE I THINK THIS
LEADS TO ME IS THE IMPORTANT.
DISCUSSION WE SHOULD BE HAVING
RIGHT NOW ON THE ISSUE OF FIRES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
PREVENTION AND SAFETY AND TO OUR
OF ACTION THAT'S PART OF WHAT
MOTIVATED THE SP TWELVE SIXTY I
WOULD THINK PROBABLY.
EACH OF YOU HAS BEEN WORKING --
ON THAT BILL IS MY STAFF.
QUITE CLOSELY AND I AM VERY
PLEASED WITH WHERE IT'S GOING --
I JUST WONDER --
ASSUMING THAT YOU.
ARE OFF YOU WITH US --
TWELVE SIX IS THERE ANYTHING.
THAT YOU BELIEVE WE MIGHT BE
DOING IN ADDITION TO WHAT'S IN
THERE OR SHOULD WE JUST TAKE THE
BILL AS IT IS NOW IN --
YOU SAID IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
MODELED GOING FORWARD ANOTHER
WHICH DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
SUGGESTIONS WE MIGHT.
INCLUDED AS WE WRAP UP THE THE
CONTENT TO THAT BILL.
YOU WON'T GET FIRED.
FOR WE'RE BLESSED FROM A REMINDS
ME THAT --
FIRST ALL OF THESE BILLS --
WE'RE TELLING YOU WHAT'S IN THE
BILLS RIGHT NOW --
WE CAN'T PREDICT --
IF IF THE ADMINISTRATION'S GONNA
RECOMMEND CHANGES WORTH
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES ARE
GOING TO RECOMMEND CHANGES.
SO I THINK THAT APPLIES TO WHAT
I'VE SAID ABOUT ALL THESE --
I THINK --
I'M I'M WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF --
THERE ARE.
I THINK THERE ARE SOME REALLY
SMALL TWEAKS THAT WE'RE WE'RE
CONSIDERING.
NOTHING SIGNIFICANT --
AND THE ONE MAJOR QUESTION I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON AND WITH
CAL FIRE ON ARE THE SPECIAL
CONSIDERATIONS --
FOR COASTAL POINT COMMUNITIES --
WHICH IS. TWO WERE IN THE
PROCESS OF RESOLVING THAT.
SO -- I
THINK.
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED THAT
BILLS CLOSE [inaudible]
TO CLUSTER DOT.
I WONDER IF OUR EXPERT FROM OF
BERKELEY --
PROFESSOR STEVENS HAS ANY
THOUGHTS.
I'VE SEEN THE BILL AND PARTS
OVER THAT PERIOD LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
INNOVATE I HAVE TO REALLY I
DIDN'T SAY THIS IN MY COMMENTS I
HAVE TO GIVE THE STATE'S A REAL
CREDIT.
YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS BUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS NOW
AND I'VE NEVER REALLY SEEN THE
STATE CUT TO GET INTO THIS AREA
FIRE FUELS RESTORATION IS MUCH.
THE DELTA SEEMS LIKE IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN THE BIG ISSUE WHEN I LOOK
AT IT FROM AFAR SO I REALLY
THINK THAT YOUR YOUR BILL IS
REALLY FORWARD LOOKING I THINK
IT TAXI VERY FOR WITH THE
LEGISLATION THAT YOU FOSTERED IN
THE OTHER BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED.
AS HE DID YEAH I I INITIALLY
COUPLE YEARS BACK.
THERE WAS SOME REAL TENSION
BETWEEN AIR REGULATIONS AND THE
NEED TO PUT MORE FIRE ON THE
LANDSCAPE.
WE IT'S NEVER AN EASY ISSUE.
BUT THAT WAS ONE THING I WAS
WONDERING WHAT IF WE SHOULD TRY
TO DO SOMETHING IN A BILL OR CAN
WE WORK THROUGH OUR EXCELLENT
STAFF AND THE RELATIONSHIPS WE
HAVE TO SEE IF WE CAN HAVE
FARTHER SITE I THINK.
WATCHING THE PROGRESS CLOSELY
AND NEVER LETTING GO OF THIS
ISSUE KNOW THAT WE'D KEEP IT ON
THE FRONT BURNER PARDON THE PUN.
FOR AS LONG AS IT TAKES TO GET
US THROUGH THE NEED TO GOING TO
COULD BE A GENERATION.
BUT WE NEED TO STAY ON IT THAT
THE AIR COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA
THIS YOU MAY NOT.
HAVE HEARD THIS BUT IN OREGON
AND WASHINGTON THEY'RE NOT GET
ALONG SO GREAT WITH THE FIRE
PEOPLE WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO
RESTORE FIRE ON THE LANDSCAPE.
WE WITH THE AIRPORT HERE IN THE
AIR DISTRICTS COLLABORATIVE WE'D
JOINING THIS PRO FIRE PRO
PRESCRIBED BURNING PARTNERSHIP.
IT'S MINUTES FOUNDING WE JUST
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING ECOLOGICALLY SIGNIFICANT.
FIRE AND WORK ON THE LAND OVER
TIME THAT'S THE TEST THINK YOU
AND I DIDN'T WANT YOU TO ATTACK
ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES BILLS SO
THAT'S WHY I'M GOING TO UNIFY
COULD TAKE THE HEAT ON IT SO TO
SPEAK.
BUT CERTAINLY --
PERHAPS THE MONITORING IS
SOMETHING ON ALL OF OUR BILLS
YOU KNOW WE ALL HAVE.
EXPECTATIONS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THERE --
THE FIELD I HAVE ONE OTHER
QUESTION --
WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT HARDENING
OUR HOMES.
HARDENING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE --
I WONDER IF --
I'VE BEEN LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF BRINGING IN THE
PACE PROGRAM.
AND ADDING --
ADD TO IT --
THE ABILITY OF HOMEOWNERS.
TO BE ABLE TO OBTAIN THOSE KINDS
OF LOANS WITH THE CHICKEN
AMORTIZED OVER THE LIFE FOR
THEIR HOMES. TO WENT TO
ENCOURAGE THIS KIND OF HARDENING
WHETHER IT'S I GUESS SAID DOUBLE
PANE GLASS FOR EXAMPLE IS VERY
HELPFUL IN.
REDUCING THE HEAT THAT THAT
FIRES CREATED AND BLOWING OUT
WINDOWS AND LIGHTING UP TO DRAW
THE DRAPES AND DESTROYING HOMES.
AND NOT A NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS --
ANY THOUGHTS ON WHY ON WHETHER
ADDING --
THIS SAID TO THE PACE PROGRAM
THE HARDENING OF OUR HOMES WOULD
BE HELPFUL --
ARAB.
PUT I CAN OFFERED SOME THOUGHTS
AND I A VERY SMART THING TO DO --
THE THE STATE'S SYSTEM OF GRANTS.
FOR FOREST MANAGEMENT AND
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT AND JUST A
COUPLE OF MINUTES --
AREN'T REALLY DESIGNED TO HELP
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS
[inaudible]
AND INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS NEED.
SOME SORT OF MECHANISM. TO
UNDERTAKE THESE STRUCTURAL
RETROFITS TO THEIR HOUSES --
THE PACE PROGRAM AS A BASICALLY
A PRIVATE SECTOR PROGRAM THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO SELF FINANCE
[inaudible]
AND THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL HAS A
LIST OF RETROFITS THAT ARE
APPROVED BUT FOR THIS VERY
PURPOSE.
AND I THINK THAT THE PIECE
PROGRAM OR A SIMILAR EFFORT IS
NOT GOING TO BE NEEDED. TO
CREATE A WHO A MEANINGFUL WAY
FOR THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
HOMEOWNERS ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT NEED SOME FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THEM TO VOLUNTARILY
MAKE THESE RETROFITS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISTER DALI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR.
I WON OF JUST THE I THINK THE
SENATORS ON THE RIGHT TRACK WE
TALK TALKING ABOUT FIRE BUT
THERE ARE A COUPLE THINGS THAT
DOWN.
I LIKE TO ADDRESS ON THE FIRE
ISSUES THAT. ONE OF THE THERE'S
BEEN WE'VE HAD GOALS THE FOREST
SERVICE HAS GOALS OF HALF A
MILLION ACRES YEAR THAT THEY
WANT.
TO TRY [inaudible]
TO BURN.
AND THE BIGGEST.
HURDLE IS WHEN YOU ACTUALLY GO
TO IMPLEMENT IT ON THE GROUND
AND THERE'S A THERE'S FOR SMALL
NUMBER ONE THERE'S A LIABILITY
IF THE FIRE GETS AWAY FROM YOU.
WHO PAYS SO THE INDUSTRIAL LAND
OWNERS THAT I REPRESENT MY
DISTRICT?
WHO WOULD LOVE TO USE THIS AS A
TOOL ARE AFRAID TO USE IT
BECAUSE IF THE FIRE GETS AWAY
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY THE
COST OF SUPPRESSION AND SO
THEY'RE RELUCTANT TO BE A? TO
PUT FIRE BACK ON THE GROUND
NUMBER.
ONE NUMBER TWO IS THAT WE HAVE
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE REGULATED BY
THE AIRPORT WHICH THE WINDOWS OF
TIMES THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY HAVE
WHAT WE CALL.
BURN DAY SWITZER DAYS THAT YOU
ALLOW YOU TO BE ABLE TO BURN
BECAUSE OF AIR QUALITY --
ARE REALLY NARROW BECAUSE WE VSP
PERFECT BASICALLY FOR YOU TO BE
ABLE.
TO MEET AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
AND APPLY THE FIRE TO THE GROUND.
AND SO THOSE ARE TWO HURDLES
THAT WILL BE FACED IN ANY PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT SAYS WE'RE
GOING TO INTRODUCE FIRE --
BACK IN OUR ECOSYSTEM AND THEN I
HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT SO.
BEEF AND BEFORE WE INTRODUCE
FIRE ARE WE TALKING ABOUT.
MANAGING THE FUEL LOAD BEFORE WE
PUT FIRE BACK INTO IT OR WE JUST
TALK ABOUT PUTTING FIRE INTO IT
BEFORE WE'VE SAID AND OR DONE ME
SOME SORT OF THE MANAGEMENT BE
SO WE DON'T HAVE SUCH THE
INTENSITY OF FIRE.
I GREW UP I CAN MAKE SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT ALL THESE --
YOUR IDEA OF KIND ABOUT THE
LIABILITY IN THE CHALLENGES OF
PLAYING FIRE ON THE GROUND IT'S
VERY VERY REAL.
IN ON THIS IS AGAIN WHERE I
THINK WE CAN LOOK TO OUR
COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS IN THE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
BECAUSE IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA
THEY'VE ENACTED SOME LEGISLATION
THAT ALLOWS IF YOU HAVE A
PRESCRIBED FIRE PLAN HAS BEEN
WRITTEN.
HE GETS PEER REVIEWED BY THE
RIGHT PEOPLE FEEDBACK IS APPLIED.
AND THEN IT'S ACTUALLY ACCEPTED.
THEN IF THE PRESCRIBED BURNING
TEAM GOES OUT AND ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTS THE FIRE AS PLANNED.
WITH EVERYTHING IS.
TIGHT AS POSSIBLE AND THEN THEY
HAVE A PROBLEM WHICH INEVITABLY
YOU WILL.
I GUARANTEE IT I'VE HAD PROBLEMS
AND I'VE BEEN PRESCRIBED FIRES
I'VE BEEN PROBABLY HUNDRED MY
CAREER.
AND I HAD PROBLEMS SO THE
LEGISLATION IN FLORIDA THAN SAYS
THEM THERE ACTUALLY IS.
LIABILITY REFORM FOR THE PEOPLE
DOING THE WORK.
SO THERE'S NOT ON THEIR BACK IS
ACTUALLY THE STATE ACTUALLY FUND
THE LIABILITY PROCESS THAT IF
THE THING HAS BEEN.
PROBABLY PLAN IMPLEMENTED YOU
HAVEN'T DONE SOMETHING FOOLISH
CYCLE WHETHER SAYS THIS THE
WEATHER'S BAD I DO IT ANYWAY.
THEN YOU DON'T GET COVERAGE BUT
IF YOU DO IT PROPERLY IN STATE
OF FLORIDA'S BUDGET BEEN DOING
THIS FOR FIFTY YEARS.
AND IT REALLY HAS WORKED THE
QUESTION ABOUT YOU NO BURNING IN
THINNING AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE INTERESTING ONE AND ALSO
I THINK FOR ME.
YOU KNOW IT DEPENDS ON THE SIDE
OF COURSE WHICH JUST YOU COULD
DO SOME MECHANICAL WORK FIRST
YOU CAN DO SOMETHING TO GET
FIRED BACK THERE OTHER PLACES
CORSET YOU COULD MAYBE PUT FIRE
AND AT FIRST AND ACT TOGETHER.
YOU WORK AS LITTLE RISK YOUR
YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE AS EASILY
OUTCOME YOU'RE NOT GONNA BUILD A
PRESCRIBED EXACTLY AS TIGHTLY
WHAT THE OUTCOME MIGHT BE
INTERESTING WERE TALLY.
A BLODGETT FORCE WHICH I
MENTIONED WE'VE DONE PRESCRIBED
FIRES IN THE SAME GROUND OFFER
THREE TIMES IN TWENTY YEARS.
AND WE'VE ALSO DONE MECHANICAL
THINNING BUT NO FIRE.
AND YOU CAN GO IN THERE AND
YOU'RE OUR DIFFERENCES YOU KNOW
THE THE FIRESIDE IS JUST A MORE
RANDOM --
MORTALITY PATCHES AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE SO I'VE ALWAYS FELT
THAT.
A PROBLEM IN THE SCALE IS SO
LARGE IN THE STATE I THINK YOU
TAKE ALL OF THE TREATMENTS THAT
ARE POSSIBLE.
AND YOU APPLY THEM AND YOU LET
THE MANAGERS ON THE CHOICE SO I
THINK ALL THOSE ARE VIABLE AND I
FOR ME THE MECHANICAL SIDE.
IN MY VIEW SOMETIMES PUBLIC
DOESN'T GET DISCUSSED ENOUGH YOU
KNOW AND I IF WE GO TO BLODGETT
WE CAN LOOK AT PLACES THAT I'VE
BEEN THIN TWICE.
AND WE CAN LOOK AT SOME OF THE
OUTCOMES OF THAT AND YES YOU CAN
DO SOME WORK IS NOT A COMPLETE
CIRCUIT FOR FIRE BUT IT CAN
ACTUALLY WORK AS WELL.
SO MY VIEW IS THESE THINGS HAVE
BEEN TRIED AND TESTED AND IT
REALLY DEPENDS AND I HAD TO TAKE
ONE OF THE METHODS OFF THE TABLE.
A PRIORI AND THEN SAY WE'RE ALL
GOING TO USE THIS ARE ONLY GOING
TO USE THAT I FEEL THAT STEP BY
STEP [inaudible]
BACKWARDS --
SO I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS A COUPLE
THINGS ONE THE HALF MILLION ACRE
IDEA COMES FROM A MALCOLM NORTH
PAPER FROM. NINE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE THAT LOOKS AT THE
DIFFERENT VEGETATION TYPES AND
THEIR ASSOCIATED FIRE REGIME SO
THAT HE DIDN'T PULL IT OUT OF
THIN AIR WHAT'S.
THAT IS THE FUEL AND FIRE DEBT
WE LIVE WITH EVERY YEAR IN THIS
HERE IN OUR OWN BROWN IN THIS
HEARING ABOUT.
EVERY YEAR.
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THOSE
ACRES ARE NOT.
ABSOLUTELY UNREACHABLE BY
MECHANICAL EQUIPMENT.
SO THEN WE ARE ALSO FACED WITH
WHAT THE HECK DO WE DO IT.
AND YOU KNOW A LOT OF THOSE
ACRES ARE IN HIGHER ELEVATIONS
WHERE WE CAN ESTABLISH EITHER A
NATURAL IGNITION USE IT FOR
BENEFIT WHEN ALL THE CONDITIONS
ARE RIGHT.
ALL THE CONDITIONS ARE RIGHT.
OR WE CAN USE FIRE THEIR PRO
ACTIVELY AND ACCEPT THE LOW IN
NYC SEVERITY RESULT WHICH WAS
THE NATURAL SYSTEM [inaudible]
FOR CENTURIES SO THERE'S THERE'S
CERTAINLY ISSUES WITH THAT LEVEL
OF ACREAGE ARE WE STAFFED UP TO
DO IT DO WE GET THE AIR DAYS TO
DO IT.
WE GET A LOT OF AIR DAYS IN
CALIFORNIA WE OFTEN DON'T WE GET
THEM SOMETIMES WHEN WE'RE YET
TRAINING LEARNING HOW TO PUT THE
FIRE OUT WHEN WE COULD BE OUT
BURNING.
HOW WE GET THERE ARE DAYS WHEN
THE FUELS ARE WAY TOO WET TO
EVER LIVE WITH A BLOWTORCH?
SO THAT THAT IS PART OF OUR FIRE
AND WHEN YOU PARTNERSHIP IN
WORKING TOGETHER TO HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THESE DIFFERENT BARRIERS.
AND THE NEAT THING IN CALIFORNIA
IS THAT WE ARE.
VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE IS A VERY
ASTUTE AIR QUALITY COMMUNITY.
THAT IS SAYING WE HAVE TO DO
MORE THERE'S ONLY TWO CHOICES
EMISSIONS THAT ARE REALLY
HARMFUL TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND EMISSIONS WHERE WE HAVE SOME
SAY IN THE DISPERSION OF THOSE
THAT SMOKE FACT NOT LIKE WHAT
WE'RE SEEING LATELY.
BUT WHEN WE HAVE THAT PLANNED
OPPORTUNITY WE CAN DO A LOT
BETTER WITH FIRE SO THOSE ARE
THE THINGS WE WORK ON DAY AND
NIGHT IN THIS PARTNERSHIP
[inaudible]
OKAY.
FOLLOW OKAY UM MISTER WOODS.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THEIR PRESENTATIONS I THINK GO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT --
IS MISSING FROM.
THIS BILL PACKAGE SURE THESE
PACKED NOT.
BUT THIS GROUPING OF BILLS.
IS A REAL LONG TERM COMMITMENT
TO FUNDING QUITE FRANKLY WE
HEARD FROM THE PROFESSOR HERE
ABOUT.
THIS THERE'S A LOT OUT THERE IS
GOING TO TAKE TIME AND YOU KNOW
I DON'T WANNA GO BACK TOO FAR IN
TIME BUT MY MY RITUAL BILL
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE ACTUALLY
CALLED --
FOR SIGNIFICANT EXPENDITURES ON
AN ONGOING BASIS ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED PLUS MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
A NOT FOR ST THAT DIDN'T MAKE IT
VERY FAR WE GOT DOWN WE'RE DOWN
TO ONE TIME FUNDING SO I DON'T
SEE HOW WE ACCOMPLISH WHAT WE
NEED TO IN CALIFORNIA.
WITHOUT A LONG TERM SUSTAINED OF
INVESTMENT IN THESE ACTIVITIES
[inaudible]
AND SO.
AS I'M LOOKING AT AT STAFF THERE
THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING THAT.
I AYE PERSON WILL BE LOOKING. TO
TO TO ADDRESS BECAUSE I DON'T
SEE HOW WE DO IT WITH JUST THE
GOVERNOR'S TO UNDER FIFTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS PLUS SOME OF
THESE OTHER THINGS.
WE NEED SOMETHING ON A LONG TERM
BASIS.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT --
OBVIOUSLY I AGREE --
DO WE HAVE TO GET.
SUPPORT FOR THAT --
WHETHER WHETHER IT'S ENOUGH
POLICY BUILT IN THE BUDGET --
WHICH HAS BEEN ELUSIVE.
BUT WE HAVE TOGETHER
[inaudible]
AND I THINK THE OTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT COROLLARY POINT HERE
IS.
IS THE GRANTS THAT ARE GOING OUT --
TO LANDOWNERS AND NGOS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND EVERYBODY ELSE --
REQUIRE.
A LONG TERM COMMITMENT TO THE
LAND.
AND THAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT NOT
JUST LONG TERM FUNDING.
BUT LONG TERM MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES I MEAN THESE THESE
GRANTS SHOULD NOT JUST BE ONE
AND DONE.
IS THIS THINGS I MEAN THERE
NEEDS TO BE A LONG TERM
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY TO MANAGE
THOSE LANDS FOR CLIMATE AND FIRE
AND WHAT.
KINDS OF SPECIES WE WANT TO SEE
ON THE LANDSCAPE --
THOSE SHOULD ALL BE CONDITIONS
OF THESE GRANTS [inaudible]
SENATE CANNELLA.
OKAY.
BOTH OF THANK YOU I APPRECIATE.
ALL OF YOU AND YOUR OUTSIDE.
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS MORE THAN
LIKELY TAKE YOU UP ON YOUR OFFER
TO CIRCLE BACK TO CALL CIRCLE
BACK.
OUT NOW TURN THE NEXT PANEL OVER
TO SENATOR DODD.
OKAY WE HAVE NOW FUNDING FOR THE
FIRE PREVENTION HEALTHY FOUR
SEGMENT --
THE PANEL HERE WE'VE GOT JIM
BRAND HIM BY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY CAMP HIM WHAT
DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE PROTECTION.
ALSO JOHN LAYERED SECRETARY
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
AND ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE FIVE
MINUTES --
EACH.
AS I RECALL BEING JOHN
LEGISLATURE WE COULDN'T SNEEZE
IN FIVE MINUTES --
MISTER CHAIR I'M GONNA TAKE THE
LIBERTY OF GOING FIRST IN TRYING
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW AND THEN
LEAD INTO THE REST --
BECAUSE THIS SECTION OF YOUR
GENDER IS TITLED FUNDING FOR
FIRE PREVENTION AND HEALTHY
FORESTS AND I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THE OVERVIEW AND TURN IT OVER TO
DIRECTOR PAM WHAT.
FOR THE FIRE GRANTS AND THEN TO
JIM BRANHAM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY.
WHO'LL PROVIDE SPECIFIC EXAMPLES
OF THEIR FUELS REDUCTION PROGRAM.
HOW WE'VE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS FROM THE FIRST DAYS OF OUR
TIME HERE?
AND WHEN WE WALKED IN THE DOOR
THERE WERE OVER A HUNDRED YEARS
OF CHOICES TO EXCLUDE FIRE FROM
THE LANDSCAPE AND ALLOW WILD
FIRE FUEL TO ACCUMULATE.
OF FIRE IN THE STATE IS NON
NEGOTIABLE IT'S PART OF OUR
ECOSYSTEM AND EITHER WE MANAGE
OUR FORCE FOR LOW INTENSITY FIRE.
OR WE EXPERIENCE LARGER AND
LARGER FIRES.
WILDFIRE THREAT IS A COMBINATION
OF THREE FACTORS.
FUEL TEMPERATURE AND WIND AND
IGNITION.
AS OUR CLIMATE WARMS TO FUEL
CONDITIONS ON THE GROUND AND
INCREASING WARM SPELLS GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR FIRE.
AND AS OUR STATE'S POPULATION
GROWS THE IGNITION OPPORTUNITIES
GROW.
ON AVERAGE 95% OF FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CAUSED BY SOME
FORM OF HUMAN ACTIVITY.
WE SEE EVIDENCE OF THESE
CHANGING FACTORS IN THE LENGTH
OF THE FIRE SEIZE.
OVER THE PAST GENERATION OUR
FIRE SEASON HAS GROWN AT THE
FRONT END BY ROUGHLY THIRTY DAYS
AND AT THE BACK AND HAS EXTENDED
BY ROUGHLY THIRTY DATES.
WE RECOMMENDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED LAST YEAR A CHANGE IN
OUR FIRE BUDGETING SYSTEM THAT
RECOGNIZES THIS CHANGE.
IT'S IT RECOGNIZES A BASE
BUDGETING THAT WAS BASED ON WHAT
IS NOW OUR FIRE SEASON NOT ON
WHAT USED TO BE OUR FIRE SEASON.
AND AT THE PRESS CONFERENCE THE
GOVERNOR HAD ON OUR CURRENT FIRE
SITUATION THE WEEK BEFORE LAST.
DIRECTOR PAM WHAT STATED THAT
HIS DEPARTMENT USED TO
EXPERIENCE ONE BIG FIRE OF
NINETY THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR.
WE HAVE HAD FIVE SUCH FIRES THUS
FAR THIS YEAR INCLUDING THE
BIGGEST FIRE IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY.
AND WE'RE BUT HALFWAY THROUGH
THE FIRE SEASON.
THESE FIRES OF LED TO
DEVASTATING IMPACTS TO LIFE
PROPERTY IN ECOSYSTEMS.
ARE AND IT DOES ALSO HAVE LARGER
IMPACTS TO THOSE OF US THAT
MIGHT NOT LIVE EXACTLY IN THE
FIRE ZONE.
WHETHER IT'S SMOKE IN THE AIR WE
BREATHE OR ECONOMIC IMPACTS SUCH
AS WIPING OUT WEEKS OF PETE
TOURISM.
AND YOU SOMEBODY PARK THIS YEAR
AND IN THE NAPA VALLEY IN BIG
SUR COAST IN RECENT YEARS.
IN MAY THE GOVERNOR TOOK MAJOR
STEPS TO INCREASE OUR RESPONSE
TO FIRE PREVENTION.
BY ISSUING AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
WITH FIRE PREVENTION ACTIONS.
APPROVING A FORCE CARBON PLAN IS
A ROADMAP.
INCREASING BUDGET ALLOCATIONS
FOR FIRE GRANTS AND FIRE
PREVENTION AND APPOINTING A
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE POINT PERSON
TO LEAD ON THESE ISSUES.
OF THE LEGISLATURE FOLLOWED SUIT
BY APPROVING OF MOST OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN JAIL ALL TALK
ABOUT HIM IN A MINUTE.
BUT I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE WERE SOME ACTIONS TAKEN
AND PRECEDING YEARS --
* IT IN THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
ADMINISTRATION THE GOVERNOR
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS
NEGOTIATED.
A A. B. FOURTEEN NINETY TWO TO
FINALLY GET SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
FOR TIMBER REGULATION SO THAT
THAT WOULD MOVE.
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS WE
FACED WRECK.
STATE THAT LED TO WORK ACROSS.
FATE THE STATE FEDERAL AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PUT FORTH A PLAN
OF ACTION.
WE WORKED WITH YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE SUCCESSFULLY FUND
THOSE PRIORITIES OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS.
AND WHEN WE STARTED THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD IT DE IN THE
STATE OUT OF TWENTY SIX BILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT.
THAT MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT AND
THEN WHEN THE STATE RECOVERED
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHEN IN
TO BUDGET SEQUESTRATION.
OF THAT THEN HAMPERED FEDERAL
EFFORTS IN THE FORESTS.
AND CONGRESS FINALLY --
DEALT WITH THE ISSUE THAT
FEDERAL FIREFIGHTING COSTS EAT
UP MANY FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT
COULD HAVE GONE TO FORCE HEALTH.
BUT THAT SOLUTION DOES NOT BEGIN
UNTIL SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY NINETEEN AS A RESULT THE
STATE ENTERED INTO GOOD NEIGHBOR
AGREEMENTS THAT ALLOW FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES TO WORK
ACROSS JURISDICTIONAL LINES. TO
DEAL WITH VARIOUS FORCED AND
FIRE SITUATIONS.
WE'RE ALSO LEADING THE NATION.
IN FIRE AND TEMPERATURE
FORECASTING SCIENCE A FOURTH
CLIMATE ASSESSMENT WILL BE WHICH
WILL BE RELEASED LATER THIS
MONTH WILL SHOW THAT WERE
PRODUCING NEW SCIENCE AND
LEADING GLOBAL WAY IN THAT FIELD.
THE TWO THINGS I WANT TO JUST
TALK ABOUT IT BRIEFLY AS I CAN
IN THE REMAINING TIME.
IS THE FORCE CARBON PLAN WHICH
IS THE PRODUCT OF STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCY WORK ON FORESTRY.
BY AGENCIES WHO DON'T ALWAYS SEE
EYE TO EYE.
ACTUALLY CAME TOGETHER AROUND
CONSENSUS RECOMMENDATIONS THE
PLAN COVERS ALL FORCE DID
REGIONS IN THE STATE.
EMPHASIZES THE NEED TO TAKE
RETURN ON WATERSHED BASED ACTION
[inaudible]
AND INCLUDE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE FUELS REDUCTION.
A TO PREVENT HIGH INTENSITY FIRE
CENTERING STRATEGIES AROUND
REGION'S --
PROTECTING FORCED LANDING
GUARANTEEING LOWER INTENSITY
FORESTRY PRACTICES TO EASEMENTS
ACQUISITIONS IN LAND USE
PLANNING.
BUILDING NEW AND MODERN
ECONOMIES AROUND WHAT PRODUCTS
SO THAT WE CAN.
USE REMOVE SMALL TREES AND OTHER
FUELS.
OF RATHER THAN BURNING THEM.
THE RECENTLY ENACTED BUDGET HAS
ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO PUT TO REST.
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION FOR
FOREST HEALTH GRANT SIXTY THREE
MILLION FOR FUELS REDUCTION.
THIRTY MILLION FOR FORCED
TREATMENT IN THE SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY.
OF TWENTY NINE A MILLION AND
PERMANENT FUNDING FOR SIX
PRESCRIBED BURNING AND FUELS
REDUCTION CRUZ. TWENTY TWO
MILLION TO LOCAL AGENCIES AND
NON PROFITS LEADING WORK AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
PROTECTING US FORCES STATE PARKS.
TWO POINT TWO MILLION FOR WHAT
PRODUCT MARKET INNOVATION AND
ACCELERATION.
A BUILDING ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF OUR S. B.
EIGHT FIFTY NINE WHAT PRODUCTS
WORKING GROUP.
FROM THIS FUNDING GRANT SIR --
GOING OUT LOCALLY THAT THE
DIRECTOR WILL TALK ABOUT.
THE OTHER THING IS THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER WAS ISSUED.
AND IT DOUBLES FROM TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES A
TREATED PER YEAR WITH REGARD TO
FIRE. TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES AND IN YOUR PREVIOUS PANEL
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES WAS
MENTIONED.
THAT'S IN FEDERAL FORCE AND WE
HOPE THEY CAN HOLD TO THAT WE
CAN HOLD TO THIS THAT'S ONE
MILLION TOGETHER --
THAT WOULD BE TREATED.
OF THE EXECUTIVE ORDER ALSO AND
CALLS FOR IMPROVING REGULATORY
PROCESS REDUCING LIABILITY FOR
PRESCRIBED FIRE.
INCREASE WHAT PRODUCT MARKETING.
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN
RURAL AREAS WHERE THE WORK IS
DONE.
AND OUT OF THIS WAS CREATED A
FOREST MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE LED
BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ARE
AGENCIES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE PROTECTION.
OF THAT TASK FORCE WILL HAVE --
EXTENSIVE --
TASKS WITH REGARD TO THIS IT MET
JUST YESTERDAY AND IT IS WORKING
TO IMPLEMENT AND GET EVERYBODY
AROUND THE TABLE TO MOVE AHEAD
ON THIS AS FAST AS POSSIBLE.
SO AMOUNT TURN IT OVER TO CHEAT.
THANK YOU SECRETARY LEARNING
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
AGAIN CAN TEN LOT AT DIRECTOR OF
CAL FIRE.
SO YES AS I SAID BEFORE YOU
TODAY OBVIOUSLY WE ARE IN AGAIN
ONE OF THE MOST DEVASTATING AND
DESTRUCTIVE FIRE SEASONS AND IT
SEEMS LIKE WE SAY THAT --
EVERY YEAR AND EVERY YEAR WE
COME BACK AND AN INCREASE --
THE DESTRUCTIVE AND SIGNIFICANT
NATURE OF FIRE SEASON --
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF STATE AND
PRIVATE LAND HAS BURNED IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE JULY PURSUE ME
JANUARY FIRST --
WE HAVE OVER FOUR THOUSAND FIRES
HAVE BURNED SINCE JANUARY FIRST --
WE HAVE EXPENDED OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE STATE'S
EMERGENCY FUND COMBATING THESE
FIRES.
AGAIN THE CHALLENGE CONTINUES
AGAIN JUST LAST NIGHT ON THE
MENDOCINO COMPLEX THE RANCH FIRE
AND AS SECRETARY LAIRD SAID
WHICH IS NOW THE LARGEST FIRE IN
THE STATE'S HISTORY.
A FIREFIGHTER FROM THE STATE OF
UTAH --
PERISHED COMBATING THAT BLAZE SO
THE RISKS ARE REAL THE
CHALLENGES ARE REAL.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE THAT THE FIRE
SUPPRESSION EFFORT ITS KEY
OBVIOUSLY THE RESPONSE BUT
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE. TO THIS
ARE SO MUCH MORE TO CAL FIRES
ROLE AND OUR ROOM WAS THE STATE
AND FIRE PREVENTION AND WHAT WE
DO --
HELLFIRE IS RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
AND FIRE PREVENTION PROGRAMS
COMBINE FOR A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH INCLUDING FORCED AND
VEGETATION TREATMENTS WILDLAND
FIRE PRE ENGINEERING LAND USE
PLANNING EDUCATION.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT CIVIL COST
RECOVERY ALL OF THESE.
ARE AIMED AT REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF FIRE STARTS YOU HEARD
SECRETARY LAIRD SAY 95% OF FIRES
IN THE STATE ARE HUMAN CAUSED SO.
FIRE PREVENTION FOCUSES ON
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF STARTS TO
BEGIN WITH.
CREATING MORE FIRE RESISTANT AND
DEFENDABLE.
COMMUNITIES AND REDUCING THE
OVERALL INTENSITY OF WILDFIRE
THROUGH THE VARIOUS FUEL AND
VEGETATION TREATMENTS THAT ARE
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT TODAY.
WE WORK ON FOR STANDING
PRESCRIBED FIRE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTIONS --
VARIOUS LAW ENFORCEMENT CIVIL
COST RECOVERY ARE WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR INVESTIGATING
THE CAUSE OF EVERY FIRE.
AND THEN PURSUING WHERE THAT
NEIGHBOR THERE MAYBE NEGLIGENCE
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT ALL OF
THESE ACTIVITIES AGAIN ARE ABOUT
REDUCING.
THE NUMBER OF FIRE STARTS AND
THE INTENSITY.
OUR FOCUS IS THROUGH EDUCATION
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PREVENT THE
FIRES FROM STARTING OUT IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
HELLFIRE IS CONDUCTED OVER ONE
MILLION DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
INSPECTIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITIES.
A SECRETARY LAIRD SAID OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES ON
AVERAGE ANNUALLY ARE TREATED
THROUGH A VARIETY OF PROCESSES.
SCRIBE FIRE FOR STANDING FUEL
BREAKS I UTILITY CLEARANCES ALL
OF THAT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DOUBLING
THAT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
INITIATIVES.
HELLFIRE IS A PART OF THE
PRESCRIBED FIRE IN THE YOU THAT
YOU HEARD --
TALKED ABOUT HERE EARLIER WE
ALSO HAVE --
ANIMAL YOU DEMO YOU --
SINCE LAST AUGUST WITH THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
WORK ARE ON A NUMBER OF ASPECTS
BUT IN PARTICULAR SUPPORTING THE
U. THE COMMISSION'S WORK WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS.
AS PART OF SENATE BILL TEN
TWENTY EIGHT PROVIDING THE
SUPPORT FOR THE MAPPING AND
ENGAGING IN THAT EFFORT.
WE ARE LOOKING TOWARDS A A MULTI
AGENCY UPDATE OF THE POWER LINE
FIRE PREVENTION FIELD GUIDE
THESE THE VERY.
GUIDANCE THAT'S PROVIDED THAT
HELPS INTERPRET THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE EXPECTATIONS ARE FOR
UTILITIES CLEARANCE AROUND THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT GRANTS
AND FIRE PREVENTION AND FORCED
HEALTH GRANTS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN HELLFIRE IS APPROVED
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN GRANTS.
TOTALING NEARLY TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FIRE PREVENTION FORCED HEALTH.
TREE MORTALITY. TO STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN
PARTICULAR AREAS THAT ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES AND AREAS
IMPACTED BY TREE MORTALITY I
BELIEVE THE A STAFF HAS HANDED
OUT -- SOME
HANDOUTS THAT TO PROVIDE A
LISTING OF ALL THE GRANTS THAT
HAVE BEEN APPROVED.
BUT THE THE GRANTS REALLY FALL
INTO CATEGORIES FOREST HEALTH
AND FIRE PREVENTION.
FOREST HEALTH LOOK AT THE
BROADER.
ASPECTS WE EMPHASIZE LANDSCAPE
LOW MULTIPLE BENEFITS SUCH AS
CARBON SEQUESTRATION FIRE
RESILIENCE WATER QUALITY PEST
RESILIENCE WILDLIFE HABITAT.
ALSO BROUGHT BROADER COMMUNITY
BENEFITS FROM THESE BROADER
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGED PROJECTS AND
ALSO.
PERMITS WE WANT PROJECTS THAT
AREN'T ONE TIME WE WANT PROJECTS
THAT ARE ONGOING AND PERMANENT
FIXTURES WITHIN THESE WATERSHEDS.
FIRE PREVENTION GRANTS FOCUSED
MORE SPECIFICALLY ON PROTECTION
OF HABITABLE STRUCTURES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY FOCUS ON IN OF THE GREATER
NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES AND
PROTECTION OF PEOPLE --
AND CERTAINLY NEED BROADER
COMMUNITY SUPPORT --
SEVERAL EXAMPLES AND YOU'RE
GONNA HERE'S BOB IS A VERY
SPECIFICALLY FROM JIM BROWN I'M
ON A VERY A GOOD PROJECT --
BUT THERE'S OTHER PROJECTS OUT
THERE TO SOME FOR EXAMPLE THE
CRAGGY VEGETATION PROJECT.
IN SISKIYOU COUNTY.
WORKING THROUGH THE GOOD
NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY WHICH ALLOWS
US TO WORK WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS ACROSS BOUNDARIES
TREATING OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND
ACRES THROUGH FUELS REDUCTION.
INVENTING.
THE MY SIERRA WOODS PROJECT
SPONSORED BY THE AMERICAN FOREST
FOUNDATION IT'S LOOKING AT NINE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR YOUR
COUNTIES WITH OF THE REACHING
OUT -- TO
NON INDUSTRIAL PRIVATE FOREST
LANDOWNERS TO ENGAGE THEM WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CAPACITY TO WORK ON THEIR LANDS
ANTICIPATE OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
AND TWENTY PROJECTS.
TREATING FORTY TWO THOUSAND
ACRES USING WOOD PRODUCTS
MARKETS TO OFFSET COSTS HOOTING
BIOMASS LUMBER AND OTHER VARIOUS
FOR ITS PRODUCTS.
THESE PROJECTS WORK.
JUST WITHIN THE LAST TWO WEEKS
THE CRANSTON FIRE IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY VERY SIGNIFICANT FUEL
BREAK PROJECT BELOW THE
COMMUNITY OF IDYLLWILD USING A
VARIETY OF FUNDING SOURCES
INCLUDING STATE FUNDS.
THAT FUEL BREAK WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN HELPING STEER THAT FIRE AWAY
FROM THE MOUNTAIN COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING IDYLLWILD.
AGAIN IT GAVE FIREFIGHTERS A
FIGHTING CHANCE STEER THAT FIRE
REDUCED FUEL LOADING DOES THE
KIND OF PROJECTS WE ARE WORKING
ON STATEWIDE AND WE NEED TO
INCREASE.
OUR INVESTMENT IN THESE PROJECTS
STATE WIDE.
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO AGAIN INCREASING PACE AND
SCALE INCREASING THE USE OF THE
GOOD NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY WE
CURRENTLY HAVE.
FIVE GOOD NEIGHBORS SORTIE
PROJECTS --
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS AROUND
THE STATE AGAIN CROSS BOUNDARY
WORK BOTH OF RESOURCES IN
FUNDING.
THAT WE NEED TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF THOSE AGREEMENTS.
WE ARE LOOKING AT REDUCING
BARRIERS TO ENTER --
FOR STANDS FOR FOR STEALTH AND
FUELS REDUCTION THAT INCLUDES.
ARE INCREASING OUR ABILITY FOR
FOREST INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
CAPACITY OF MILLS AND BIOMASS
FACILITIES ALL OF THAT TO HELP
PROCESS THE MATERIAL COMING OUT
OF THE WOODS.
WE NEED CAL FIRE NEWS TO
CONTINUE TO WRAP UP OUR OWN
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
AND AS YOU HEARD WE THROUGH SOME
OF THE LEGISLATION.
AND HAVE A REAL EMPHASIS ON
PARTNERING WITH OTHER PRESCRIBED
BURNERS SO THAT WE CAN LEVERAGE
ALL OF OUR EXPERTISE TO INCREASE
THE PACE AND SCALE.
THAT ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE.
HELLFIRE HAS RECENTLY RE ASSUME
THE RESPONSIBILITY AS THE STATE
WHITE COORDINATOR FOR THE
NATIONAL FIRE WEIS COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM.
SINCE TAKING OVER THE PROGRAM
CAL FIRE HAS INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF NEW FIRE WEIS
COMMUNITY STATEWIDE.
ADJUST THIS YEAR A WE'VE
DESIGNATED A RECORD NUMBER OF US
ADDING SIXTEEN AT NEW
COMMUNITIES FOR A TOTAL OF ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR FIRE
WEISS COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
AGAIN THIS IS.
CRITICALLY PART OF THE OUTREACH
WERE DOING.
SO IN CONCLUSION REALLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THAT HE SHARED WITH YOU
IN A LETTER.
UP IN IN JULY AND IT'S REALLY
WORKING AGAIN WITH --
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
STAKEHOLDERS.
TO STRENGTHENED ENHANCE
CONSTRUCTION OF OUR INTERESTS AB
AND PROTECTION OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE WILD LANDS
WORKING ON THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS [inaudible]
ALL THIS IS YOUR MARK TOWARDS
REDUCING.
A NUMBER STARTS IN THE WILD LAND.
REJECTING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
WHEN FIRES DO OCCUR YOU
[inaudible]
CHIEF.
THANK YOU AFTERNOON JIM BRANDS
HERE THAT A CONSERVANCY --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF GROUND
COVERED IN THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
I TRY NOT TO BE REDUNDANT HERE --
MONEY START UP THERE THIS YEAR
NEVADA CONSERVANCY IS ONE OF THE
STATE'S.
TEN CONSERVANCY'S --
WE REPRESENT ABOUT A QUARTER OF
THE STATE OBVIOUSLY SERIES IF HE
TO CALIFORNIA IN MANY WAYS AS
ITS PRIMARY WATERSHED RESTORE
HALF THE STATE'S POOREST CARBON.
RECREATION AND SO ON SO AS WE
THINK ABOUT CARRYING OUT OUR
MISSION IN THAT REGION WERE
ALWAYS.
I'M COGNIZANT OF OF HOW WE HELP
ACHIEVE STATEWIDE OBJECTIVES AND
THAT'S A RULE THAT A REGIONAL
CONSERVANCY CAN PLAY --
AS WE ARE WE'VE BEEN AROUND
THIRTEEN YEARS AND AS WE GET
BETTER PROGRAM ON THE GROUND IT
BECAME INCREASINGLY CLEAR TO US
THAT THAT REALLY ARE PROGRAM
CENTERED ON THE IDEA CREATING
HEALTHY WATERSHEDS.
HEALTHY FOREST HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES THEY WERE
INTERLINKED --
AND WE WERE WORKING OUR WAY
THROUGH THAT AND ALONG CAME
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND THE RIM FIRE.
AND THE RIMFIRE WAS WAS TRULY A
GAME CHANGER I THINK FOR MANY OF
US LARGEST FIRE THE RECORDED
HISTORY OF THE SIERRA NEVADA --
IT BURNED AT SEVERITY IS THAT
THERE'S NO HISTORICAL RECORD FOR
PATCHES OF HIGH SEVERIT FIRE
THAT WE'VE EVER SEEN.
AND IT WAS I THINK A WAKE UP
CALL TO SAY THIS ISN'T NORMAL
THIS IS NATURAL WHAT'S GOING ON
UNFORTUNATELY EVERY YEAR SINCE
THEN WE CAN POINT TO SOMEWHERE
IN THE STATE.
WE'VE HAD A SIMILAR EXPERIENCE
AND AND IT'S ALWAYS YOU IS YOU
DID YOU THINK ABOUT THAT ANY
BEGIN TO ASK YOURSELF WHAT CAN
WE DO ABOUT IT THE ONE THING IF
YOU KEEP COMING BACK.
TO HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT A LOT
WHICH OF THE FUEL AND WHETHER
THE FUEL AT THAT STE CALIFORNIAN
ONE FORMER ANOTHER AT 60% OF THE
STATE IS COVERED BY --
WOODY MATERIAL WHETHER THEIR
TREES ARE BRUSH WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE AT SOME POINT EVERY
YEAR I THINK THAT YOU CAN BACK
ME UP ON THIS THEY BECOME
FLAMMABLE.
AND AND THE FUEL LOADS ARE A
COMMON DENOMINATOR SO REALLY
FOCUSING ON THAT'S SOMETHING WE
CAN ADDRESS.
YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH CLIMATE ISSUES THE LONG
TERM WEATHER TOPOGRAPHY THOSE
AND IGNITIONS WE DON'T HAVE AS
MUCH CONTROL OVER.
SO WE BEGAN TO WORK WITH BUT A
NUMBER OF OUR PARTNERS --
YOU'RE AT HOW DO WE HOW DO WE DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENTLY IT'S NOT
WORKING WE FORM THE SIERRA
NEVADA WATERSHED IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM --
OUR PRIMARY PART AT THE TIME WAS
U. S. FOR SERVICE BUT WE
CERTAINLY HAVE REACHED OUT TO
OUR THEIR STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCY PARTNERS.
WE HAVE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY INDUSTRY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CAN EVERYBODY IN
BETWEEN.
WE STARTED KIND OF SIMPLE
PREMISE WHAT COULD WE AGREE UPON.
AND WE'VE GOT QUICKLY DID
AGREEMENT THAT NOBODY WAS TOO
HAPPY WITH THE PATH WE RUN SO WE
BEGAN EXPLORING HOW WE BUILD
UPON AGREEMENTS.
AND COME UP WITH A PROGRAM
ACROSS THE REGION THAT'S GOOD OR
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
WE ALSO CAME PRETTY QUICKLY TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT --
TREAT TREATMENTS WORK.
AND THERE'S REALLY NOT A BUDGET
TOOLS IN THAT TO A BOXER'S
PRESCRIBE TO MANAGE FIRED YOU
FOR TALK ABOUT AND THERE'S
MECHANICAL TREATMENTS WHETHER
THEY BE THINNING OR SUSTAINABLE
HARVEST --
THAT'S OUR THAT'S OUR OUR GATE
AND SO FIGURING OUT HOW TO PUT
THAT OUT ANY PACE AND SCALE
THAT'S GONNA MAKE A DIFFERENCE
BECAME --
OUR CHALLENGE UNDER THE
WATERSHED APPROVED PROGRAM BUT
THE OTHER THING WE WERE NOTICING
AS WE MET WITH FIRE OFFICIALS
AND SCIENTISTS AND SO ON IS --
EVERY TIME WE THOUGHT WE'D.
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO US.
REALITY KEPT LEAPFROGGING.
WE KEPT GETTING WORSE AND WAITED
MANY BRIEFINGS AFTER THE RIM
FIRE KING FIRE AND SO ON WITH.
THE FIRE PEOPLE CENTER MODELS
COULDN'T PREDICT THIS BEHAVIOR
AND I THINK THAT I GET IS ONLY
GETTING WORSE FOR US SO.
SO WE REALLY LOOKED AT HOW DO
YOU WOULD YOU WOULD YOU DO ABOUT
THIS AND WHAT WE'VE LEARNED.
FROM THAT EFFORT IS THERE REALLY
ARE THREE THERE'S THREE PRETTY
SIMPLE --
THINGS WE NEED TO ADDRESS ONE IS
INVESTMENT A LOT'S BEEN TALKED
ABOUT THAT HAVING A STABLE LONG
TERM SOURCE OF FUNDING ALLOWS
YOU TO BUILD PROGRAMS.
OVER TIME TO GET TO THE PACE AND
SCALE SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE ALL STRUGGLE WITH HIS --
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT KIND OF
STABILITY.
HOWEVER WE GOT A LOT OF MONEY IN
THE SYSTEM NOW IS THE SECRETARY
MENTIONED A LOT OF FUNDING THAT
IS SHOWING UP ON THE SCENE.
THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS NOW WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE DO
STRATEGIC HACKLEY SMART ABOUT
SPENDING THAT AND HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY MOVE LANDSCAPES TO A TO
A STATE OF RESILIENCE.
AND AND I WOULD SAY FOR FROM A
LEGISLATIVE PERSPECTIVE.
THINKING THROUGH HOW YOU
ALLOCATE THOSE FUNDS
INAPPROPRIATE THEM AND YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY THINK IT'S IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS.
NOT MAKING THE TO TO
PRESCRIPTIVE NOT TARGETING ONE
LANDSCAPE OVER ANOTHER WE TRY TO
LOOK AT THIS YEAR NEVADA MAPPING
WE TRIED BUT THE THAT COLORBLIND
GLASSES ON RIGHT.
I DON'T CARE IF IT'S GREEN OR
YELLOW OR WHITE OR WHATEVER THE
OWNERSHIP AS IN THERE IS HOW DO
WE ADDRESS AT A LANDSCAPE SCALE
SO AGAIN LET'S.
HOPE WE CAN BE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
HOW WE GET PUT THOSE FUNDS OUT
THERE SO WE CAN DESTROY TEACHER
COULD AWAY THAT.
ACTUALLY MOVE LANDSCAPES TO
POINT A RESILIENCE --
THE OTHER THE SECOND THEY WE
FOCUSED ON WAS POLICY AND
PROCESS INTO --
AND THERE'S A LOT OF NEW WERE
THE AIR QUALITY DISCUSSION AND
AND AND USING A FIRE AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE MAKING A LOT OF
PROGRESS AND STILL HAVE SOME
WAYS TO GO.
BUT I THINK WE'RE SEEING A LOT
OF DISCUSSIONS WITH.
WITH AIR REGULATORS WHO ARE
REALIZING.
WHAT WE'RE DOING OUT THERE ISN'T
WORKING SO WELL SO?
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT WAYS TO DO
THAT WE HAVE A PROJECT IN THE
CENTRAL SIERRA.
THE TONGS INTERESTS HERE
INITIATIVE WHERE WE WERE REALLY
TESTING NEW WAYS OF DOING
BUSINESS AND AND CARRY OUT THE
PROCESS ONE OF THE PROJECTS THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY.
THE NGOS ACTUALLY HIRED IN HIS
OVERSEEING THE WORK OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSULTANTS.
WHO PRODUCED THE OF OUR MIDDLE
DOCUMENTS AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE LOCAL AGENCY
IN THIS CASE WILL APPROVE IT'S A?
DIFFERENT WAY TO GO ABOUT IT BUT
IT'S CREATING SOME CAPACITY THAT
OTHERWISE WOULDN'T BE THERE SO.
REALLY.
LOOKING AT PROCESSES ONE I WOULD
SUGGEST TO YOU MAY BE OFFERING
IT AS A QUESTION SINCE I AM BUT
I WANT TO GET OUT IN FRONT OF MY
SECRETARY HERE --
BUT AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
MAKES THE DECISION TO INVEST ON
PROJECTS ON FEDERAL LAND THAT
HEAVY CLEAR BENEFIT TO THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA.
PROJECTS THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS DOES
IT REALLY MAKE SENSE AS A
FUNDING AGENCY FOR US TO HAVE TO
START OVER IN GO THROUGH THE
SECRET PROCESS ON TOP OF THAT.
TO DO IT TWICE.
MANY OF US THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE SHOULD REALLY BE
ASKING OURSELVES AT THEIR SUMMIT
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE CAN
BE THERE.
THE FINAL THING WE PHONE HAVE
FOCUSED ON IT IS THE ONE WE WENT
BACKWARDS ON QUITE FRANKLY.
IS THE INFRASTRUCTURE THE CHIEF
PIMLOTT MATCHING AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR US IS NOT
JUST MILLS AND BIOMASS
FACILITIES AND BIOENERGY
FACILITIES BUT THE PEOPLE THAT
CAN DO THE WORK IN THE FIELD.
THE MACHINERY THE EQUIPMENT.
TRUCK DRIVERS IT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE ALL OF THAT TO GET TO THE
PACE AND SCALE THAT WE JUST
HEARD DESCRIBED AND SO.
HOW DO WE REALLY HONESTLY TAKE
ON THE ISSUE OF CREATING THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE --
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE ONE
POINT IN BECAUSE I KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF DEBATE ABOUT.
THINGS LIKE BIOMASS ENERGY --
THE THE LEAST ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY THING FOR US TO BE
DOING IS REMOVING THE FUEL FROM
THE FROM THE FOREST PUTTING INTO
PILES AND BURNING IT FOR WORSHIP.
ALLOWED TO BRING IN WELFARE
FIRES PUTTING IT IN FACILITIES
THAT CAN MAKE ENERGY OF IT.
WHILE THEY HAVE SOME EMISSIONS
ARE STRONG MAGICALLY IMPROVEMENT
OVER WHAT HAPPENS OUT THERE IS
THE ALTERNATIVE AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE KIND OF FACED I THINK THE
SECRETARY SAY IT'S IT'S
INEVITABLE.
GONNA BURN ONE WAY THE OTHER AND
AND WE THINK WE'VE GOT A PRETTY
GOOD APPROACH TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT SO FIGURING OUT HOW WE CAN
ACTUALLY INCENTIVIZE.
KEEPING WHAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
I'M IN TERMS OF INFRASTRUCTURE
BUT CERTAINLY BUILDING UPON IT
CREATING IN.
A WORK FORCE TO DO THE WORK OF
CREATING PLACE OUTLETS THE OTHER
THING I WOULD SAY IS A LOT OF
THAT MATERIAL THAT NEEDS TO REAP
BE REMOVED AND FIRES.
ASCRIBE FIRE WILL DO A LOT OF
GOOD FOR US A LOT OF PLACES BUT
MISTER DALEY'S POINT WE HAVE TO
DO.
MANAGEMENT IN MANY PLACES BEFORE
THAT'S A LOT OF THE TRUE THIS IS
OF NO VALUE IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
PLACE TO TAKE IT NOBODY'S GOING
TO PAY.
FOR SO IT MAKES ALL THOSE
PROJECTS READY SO CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES TO TO TAKE THE
MATERIAL CREATE MEANS WE CAN GET
MORE WORK DONE IN THOSE THREE
THINGS ALL ADD UP TO ACTUALLY
GETTING.
TO THE PACE AND SCALE OF
RESTORATION --
I THINK AS I SAY WE GOT GREAT
PARTNERS THAT ARE DOING GREAT
WORK IN OUR REGION --
CAL FIRE HAS BEEN VERY GENEROUS
IN IN AWARDING SOME OF THEIR
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS --
IN A PLACE THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER THE TALLEST INTEREST
SIERRA AREA WHICH WILL REALLY
FOCUSED ON TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW YOU DO YOU NEED.
BUSINESS DIFFERENTLY --
AND I GO BACK TO COLLEGE I THINK
IT WAS. TO STEVEN'S IT TALK
ABOUT THE NEW NORMAL RIGHT AND
WE LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING DOWN
WE LOOK AT SOME OF THE CLIMATE
CHANGE PROJECTIONS AND WHAT
COULD BE HAPPENING IN A FEW
DECADES AND WE MAY ACTUALLY
YEARNED.
FOR THE DAYS OF TODAY BECAUSE IT
CAN GET A LOT WORSE AND IF WE
DON'T CHANGE OUR PATH.
IF WE DON'T IT'S HEADED SO WITH
THAT.
HOME CONCLUDED HAPPY DANCE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAHLE OVERSAW ONE
THINK ALL THREE OF YOU AND
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE NOT TO KNOWN
YOU GUYS ALL TOO WELL THROUGH
THIS PROCESS OF I'M TRYING TO
COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS OF VERY
DIFFICULT.
AND CHALLENGING TIMES THAT WE
FACE -- SO
AS AS YOU MENTIONED AND JAM WITH
THAT IS IN WATERSHEDS THEIR
IMPAIRED AFTER THE FIRE IN THE
RECONSTRUCTION HAS TO GO ON
THERE.
AND THE IT I THINK WAS A VAMPIRE
THAT WE REALIZE THAT IT ACTUALLY
STERILIZE THE GROUND IN THEIR
THEIR THERE WILL BE NO LIFE
THERE FOR SOMETIME IN THE FUTURE.
SO AND I HOPE SO THE GUESS THE
QUESTION IS. TO BOTH YOU AND TO
TPN LAW.
IS THAT THE NUMBER ONE FACTOR WE
HAVE IF WE REDUCE THE FUEL
PERIOD.
THE FIRES ARE IS AS INTENSE SO
THAT THAT'S THE GOAL OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO REDUCE THAT FEEL NOW
THAT.
THE THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS
OF ALL THE REASONS THAT ARE.
THAT'S HARD TO DO BECAUSE
THERE'S NO VALUE IN.
MOST THAT FUEL.
SO WE'VE DONE --
MYSELF AND MANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
RAN LEGISLATION THIS FORCED
PEOPLE OF TO BASE THE BY ENERGY
THIS PRODUCED FROM BIOMASS. TO
HAVE A PLACE TO OUTLET THAT
THESE DRIVES THE COST DOWN A
LITTLE BIT AND AND EXPENSE
ACOSTA RESULT THE WATERSHEDS OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE CARBON SEQUESTRATION OF THE
FORCE THAT THEY GET THE BENEFIT
FROM FROM.
THAT BIOMASS FACILITY SO YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT SOME OF THE
REGULATORY.
STREAMLINING THERE IS TALK ABOUT
AND I THINK MAYBE THAT THERE IS
THERE SOME OPPORTUNITIES OTHER
THAN JUST THE DUPLICATION OF
NEPAD SEEK WERE.
THAT YOU SEE --
THIS LEGISLATURE COULD TAKE A
LOOK AT TO MAYBE A STREAMLINED
THE PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY DO LOWER THE COST WE
CAN TREAT MORE ACRES.
IN THE END [inaudible]
ALRIGHT SIX A JUST A THEY GO FOR
IT SOME GOOD COVERAGE --
IS RETIRING ON THE FIRST.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY FROM
WHAT OUT --
I THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
SYSTEM FROM TOP TO AND ASK
OURSELVES WHERE ARE THE
PROCESSES WERE USING ACTUALLY
SERVING.
THE PURPOSE THEY WERE DESIGNED
TO SERVE WHICH WAS.
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT WELL
INTENTIONED RIGHT AND I THINK
MANY OF THEM ARE ARE SERVING A
PURPOSE BUT WE HAVE TO ACT BUT
WE WE HAVE OUR SYSTEMS THAT.
ANALYZE THE PROPOSED ACTION.
I TRIED IT --
IDENTIFY IMPACTS MINIMIZE
IMPACTS ALL APPROPRIATE --
BUT WHAT YOU WHAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW IS IT'S THE INACTION.
IT'S HAVING THE GREATEST
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS SO.
HOW DO WE DO IT IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS THE ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
HONEST CONVERSATION?
ABOUT --
SHOULD WE BE TALKING ABOUT
BROADER OPPORTUNITIES TO
STREAMLINE PROCESSES FOR THINGS
LIKE PRESCRIBED FIRE.
IT FOR PROJECTS THAT ARE TRULY
RESTORATIVE IN NATURE SHOULD
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE SAME
PROCESS OF OF OTHER PROJECTS
THAT.
YOU KNOW COULD HAVE FAR GREATER
IMPACT THAN I THINK YOU KNOW
THAT ON I'M TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
WORK ON THE GROUND WE HAVE
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITIES. TO
IMPROVE THE PROCESS --
MAKE IT SIMPLER MAKE IT LESS
COSTLY BUT ENSURE THAT IN THE
END WE'RE GOING TO PROTECT.
PROTECT THE RESOURCE --
BECAUSE AGAIN YOU KNOW THE THE
INACTION IS OFTEN THAT THE
GREATER.
PURPOSE FIGHT GREATER RISK THAN
WHATEVER ACTIONS MIGHT BE
PROPOSING AYE I THINK THE THE
OTHER THING I WOULD SAY ON THE
ON THE BIOMASS IN.
ISSUE IN PARTICULAR IS --
THE PUBLIC BENEFITS ARE SO CLEAR.
RIGHT I MEAN WE'RE SPENDING I
DON'T YOU KNOW.
CHIEF BUDGET ON FIRE SUPPRESSION
THE COST OF EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS WHEN READING THIS AIR
THERE ARE A LOT OF CUT COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH WHAT'S GOING OUT
THERE AND THEN FOR SOME WHILE
LANCE NOW.
THERE'S A PUBLIC BENEFIT AND WE
OUGHT TO BE WILLING TO INVEST
FUNDS TO TO GET IT FACILITIES UP
AND RUNNING TO GET THE WORK
FORCE TRAIN AND PUT.
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND I I THINK
IT'S A LEGITIMATE PUBLIC
INVESTMENT AND IN WHICH YOU KNOW
WHAT WE SHOULD BE AFRAID TO TO
DO THAT I THINK.
CREATING SOME OF THOSE
INCENTIVES WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE
US YOU KNOW A LOT OF SAID THE
WORKING TO TRY TO GET SOME
SMALLER SCALE.
FACILITIES UP AND RUNNING --
WITHOUT MUCH SUCCESS AND YOU'VE
DELIGHTED TO WORK TO KEEP THE
EXISTING FACILITY SO I THINK
THERE'S I THINK INVESTMENT COULD
PLAY KEY ROLE ON ON THE ACTUAL
THE IT CONSTRUCTION PIECE.
SENATE JACKSON THANK YOU --
TO APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION --
I'M I'M KIND INTERESTED IF
SOMEONE COULD TALK ABOUT RECENT --
NON SIERRA FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECTS YOU KNOW THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S.
MUCH HAS A MUCH DIFFERENT
VEGETATION SYSTEM AND WE DEAL
MORE IN CHAPARRAL RATHER THAN IN
THE BIG --
TIMBER AND TREAT.
CONCEPT WE HAVE GRASSLANDS SO
MIXED OAK AND PINE IN --
THE CHAPARRAL IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS VERY DIFFERENT
FROM.
WHAT EXISTS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND?
MOST OF THOSE FIRES IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA REALLY
ARE.
UM.
DIRECTLY.
AND SERIOUSLY IMPACTING OF HOMES
GIVEN THE LOCATION OF COURSE.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT'S BEEN
THE SAME THING EVEN THOUGH THAT
HASN'T HISTORICALLY BEEN THE
ISSUE BUT THE CHAPARRAL ISSUES
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME AND ARE
WE DOING FUEL TREATMENT IN THESE
AREAS AS AGGRESSIVELY.
AS WE DOING THEM ELSEWHERE.
IT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION CENTER
IN OF AND OF COURSE I DID YEAH
I'VE OBVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE THE
PROJECT --
INCENTIVES INTO MOUNTAINS OF
RIVERSIDE WHICH IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF WORKING IN BOTH THE
CHAPARRAL.
AND THE MIXED CONIFER FOREST
OTHER COUNTIES HAVE BEEN VERY
FORWARD.
THINKING AND IN THEIR PROJECTS
AND TRIP COUNTY --
FIRE DEPARTMENT FOR EXAMPLE
PERFECT AREAS THAT WERE --
WITHIN THE THOMAS FIRE FOOTPRINT
WERE AREAS THAT WERE EITHER
UNDER TREATMENT OR HAD BEEN
PROPOSED --
FOR TREATMENT AND THE CHALLENGES
ARE FINDING THE RIGHT WE CAN'T
TREAT.
ALL SIXTY MILLION ACRES OF THE
LANDSCAPE WHETHER IT'S BROKE
WOODLAND CHAPARRAL OR MEXICANA.
FOR SO WE HAVE TO FIND THOSE KEY
AREAS TO TO MAXIMIZE OUR
INVESTMENT AND PROTECTING
COMMUNITIES WHERE THOSE RIDGE
LINES AND AREAS SURROUNDING --
COMMUNITY WHERE WE CAN REDUCE
FUEL LOADING PUTTING CRITICAL
FUEL BREAKS THAT WE CAN USE FOR
DEFENSIVE.
I PERIMETERS AROUND COMMUNITIES
I AREAS ALONG AT THE SANTA
BARBARA FRONT COUNTRY AND I KNOW
THERE IS THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
CHALLENGES AND FRUSTRATIONS --
WITHIN SO EVEN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO
GET --
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCE TO DO
SOME OF THESE PROJECTS THAT WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE.
TO BE AT THE TABLE WORKING WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS --
TO IDENTIFY WHERE THESE CRITICAL
NEEDS ARE AND GET THOSE --
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO BUY IN.
AGAIN IT'S NOT TREATING.
YEAH.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF ACRES
IT'S TREATING VERY KEY AREAS
WITH THESE URBAN INTERFACE
PROJECTS THAT ARE CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING COMMUNITIES AND AND
THAT'S TRULY IN PARTICULAR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE KINDS OF
PROJECTS WE'VE REALLY GOT TO
FOCUS ON AND ARE WE DOING THAT
OR WE JUST IN THE IT.
IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
CONSIDERING.
THAT KIND OF CLEARING WERE DOING
IT BUT WE CAN DO MUCH MORE.
WHAT IS GOING TO TAKE TO GET US
TO DO MUCH?
WE NEED TO GET MORE PROJECTS
APPROVED WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT GETTING UP
AS THAT JIM GRAHAM SAID IN.
STREAMLINING OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW PROCESSES WE NEED TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT EXIST AND WE NEED TO GET
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE AND
AGREE -- TO
THE THE CRITICAL NATURE OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE --
LIFE SAFETY COMMUNITY PROTECTION
CRITICAL.
AND WITH THAT IN MIND --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE SEQUEL WE HAVE
NEAT BUN AND THEY ARE.
VERY DIFFERENT --
OR PARTICULARLY DIFFERENT TO THE
EXTENT THAT UP --
SEQUEL REQUIRES MITIGATION IN NY
BUT DOESN'T AND I THINK THAT IS
A CONCERN TO SOME AYE.
I DO KNOW PR IS PUBLISHED A
HANDBOOK ON HOW TO DO SEEK WHEN
THE BUS SIMULTANEOUSLY ON IT IS
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK
IS A POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT THIS
IS SOMEWHERE WHERE.
WE SHOULD BE GOING BECAUSE YOU
MENTION IF WE WANT TO EXPEDITE I
DON'T WANT TO EXPEDITE SO THAT
WE WE LEAVE OUT SOME OF THE
IMPORTANT WORK OF MITIGATION
THAT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE.
INDICATED S OF GREAT IMPORTANCE.
TO YES THANK YOU CENTER YEAH I
MEAN I THINK WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT A A TYPE OF PROJECT THAT
THAT WERE COMFORTABLE IS GONNA
HAVE.
RESTORATION VALUES RIGHT I MEAN
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE NEAT BUT
NOT.
WITHOUT TAKING ACTIONS THAT WE
FEEL LIKE WE NEED SOME
SIGNIFICANT MITIGATION EVERY
CARD SO.
SO.
IN THE MEAN IN THAT IN THE
IMMEDIATE I'M SITUATION WE FACE
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS --
THAT THAT THE CROSSWALK BETWEEN
SEQUINED EVEN THAT OP ARE HAS
PROVIDED --
IT DOESN'T WORK VERY WELL
BECAUSE YOU NEED TO BE INVOLVED
REALLY THE BEGINNING THE PROCESS
OF WHAT WE'RE BEGINNING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE FOR
SERVICE.
AND ARE THE FEATHER PART IS
ABOUT IS LET'S DO LARGER
LANDSCAPE ENVIRONMENTAL PLANNING
AND LET'S DO IT IS JOINT
DEEPENED SEQUEL.
AND THE MORE THAT WE CAN DO THEN
THE PROBLEM GOES AWAY BUT
THERE'S A BACKLOG RIGHT NOW OF
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WORK TO DO
IN THE SHORT TERM THAT.
WE'VE WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DEAL WITH THAT IN A MORE
EFFICIENT WAY BUT I THINK THAT
IS A LONG TERM SOLUTION OUT
AGAIN.
EXTRA COSTS FOR SMALL AGENCIES
LIKE OURS WE DON'T IS HONESTLY
FUNDED YOU KIND OF LARGELY
LANDSCAPE SEQUEL BUT THE MORE
THAT WE CAN DO THEN THAT FURTHER
THE BETTER OFF WE'LL BE DOWN THE
ROAD [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHIEF KILL FIRE HAS BEEN
MENTIONED THROUGHOUT THE
PROCEEDINGS.
AS ONE OF THE IT IMPORTANT --
AGENCIES TO HELP US THROUGH THIS
PROCESS. TWO TO OVERLOOK THE
PLANS -- TO
IT JUST IN EVERY ASPECT OF THIS.
IS CALIFORNIA PREPARED TO DO
THAT TO WHAT IS IT CAL FIRE
NEEDS. TO IMPLEMENT ALL THE
THINGS THAT THAT WE ARE
[inaudible]
ASKING CALIFORNIA OR TAKE ON IT
PROBABLY ALL USE A GOOD NIGHT'S
SLEEP RIGHT HUTTON CAO HER FOR
EVERYBODY'S WORKING VERY HARD --
THERE'S A LOT TO DO BY ALL OF US
AND CAL FIRE IT IS LATE
INDICATED HAS HAD PROGRAMS FOR
YEARS ENGAGED IN FIRE PREVENTION
AND FUELS TREATMENT BUT TO
CONTINUE TO INCREASE TO THE PACE
AND SCALE THAT WE NEED TO GET
ALL THIS DONE.
WE NEED TO RISE ALL OF THE THE
BOATS WITH THE TIDE IF YOU WILL
WE NEED TO LOOK AT A 100%
SUPPORTING --
ONGOING FUNDING SOURCE FOR CAP
AND TRADE OR FOR FOREST HEALTH
AND FIRE PREVENTION INVESTMENTS
IF WE'RE TRULY GOING TO GET
LANDOWNERS.
OUGHT TO BUY ENDEAVOR GOING TO
GET --
INDUSTRY TO REINVEST AND AND
HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE --
WE NEED TO HAVE A LONG TERM
COMMITMENT AND THE ONLY WAY
WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT IS NOT
ALL THROUGH PUBLIC FUNDING THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE THAT.
MONEY THAT WILL PRIME THE PUMP.
AND THEN BRING IN PRIVATE
INVESTORS.
MATCH WHAT OTHERS ARE DOING UP
THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO TAKE
STAFF IT'S YOU YOU HEARD ABOUT
THAT.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF ADDITIONAL
PRESCRIBED FIRINGS FUELS CREWS.
ONGOING SUPPORT FOR THAT KIND OF
INVESTMENT TO KEEP --
THAT GROWING THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR
KEOGH WHILE SHE WAS IN OUR IN
THE SENATE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
PASSING SENATE BILL TWELVE FORTY
WHICH ALLOWS CAL FIRE IN THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY TO REVIEW.
THAT --
PUBLIC SAFETY I ELEMENTS OF THE
GENERAL PLANTS GETS US RIGHT AT
THE TABLE.
WITH ENGAGING IN THE LAND USE
PLANNING PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WE NEED IT CONTINUE
TO INCREASE OUR ENGAGEMENT AND
WORKING WITH.
LOCAL OFFICIALS TO ENSURE THAT
GENERAL PLANS HAVE THAT THAT THE
ELEMENTS IN THEM FOR FIRE SAFE
COMMUNITIES GOING FORWARD.
AND LET ME HARDLY DE LET ME ADD
ONE THING AND THAT IS THAT.
YEAH I AM LOOKING AT SPREAD OF
WHO'S SITTING HERE AND I JUST
KNOW FROM SERVING WITH --
SENATOR JACKSON'S THAT THERE MAY
ONLY BE. ONE OR TWO PEOPLE HERE
THAT WERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
WHEN WE HAD THE LAST MAJOR
RECESSION.
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENED --
THE BUDGET RESPONSE WAS TO GO
BACK TO THE BASICS AND WITHIN
CAO FAR IT WAS BASICALLY.
DO WHATEVER FOUGHT FIRES AT TO
NOT DO MUCH MORE BECAUSE IT WAS
TRYING TO BE DEFENSIVE AGAINST A
MONUMENTAL CUTS THAT HAPPENED.
AND SO WHEN THE CHIEF AS FOR
SALE SUSTAINABILITY.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW YOU
MIGHT HAVE SOURCES THAT ARE OFF
THE GENERAL FUND.
THAT ARE MORE A MU AND GO TO
WHAT HAPPENS IN THOSE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURNS WOULD GUARANTEED
BECAUSE THE FIRE CYCLES DON'T
MATCH THE ECONOMIC CYCLES.
AND AND WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS
DISTINCTLY DIFFERENT AND SO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT --
WHETHER IT'S CAP AND TRADE OR
OTHER THINGS THAT THAT IS TO
SUSTAINABLE SOURCE THAT THE
CHIEF WAS TALKING ABOUT WILL
REALLY HELP GOING.
FOR ALSO IF I MAY.
IN YOUR STATEMENT YOU PROVIDED A
NUMBER OF SUGGESTIONS.
AND THIS WOULD THOSE AT THE SAME
FOR THE REST OF YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO AND I DON'T KNOW
IF ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO GET COPIES OF YOUR
WRITTEN STATEMENTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
CO CHAIR HOLDING.
IF YOU ARE CHIEF.
I WANTED TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
HOW THE CP YOU SEE AND THE FACT
THAT THEY HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE CHARGE IF
YOU WELL --
TO TO LOOK OUT AND PUT TO REVIEW
THE MITIGATION PLANS OF INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES [inaudible]
AND WANTED TO GET A SENSE OF DO
YOU CHECK THE WORK OF THE P. YOU
SEE AS RELATES TO THE VEGETATION
PLANTS AS AN EXAMPLE.
OF UNDER THOSE MITIGATION PLANS
AND WHAT ROLE DO YOU PLAY AN
OVERSIGHT. FOR WORKING TOGETHER.
GOOD QUESTION IN THROUGH THEIR
MEMORANDUM UNDERSTANDING
HELLFIRE PROVIDES THE TECHNICAL
SUPPORT --
TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AS THEY'RE DEVELOPING
THE WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLANS
WERE PROVIDING THE TECHNICAL.
ADVICE ON THE ELEMENTS TO
INCLUDE IN THE PLAN AND CUT
ACROSS CHECKING THAT. FOR THEM
TO ACTUAL IMPLEMENTATIONS OF THE
PLANNED FALL WITHIN THE
RESPONSIBILITY.
OF THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION HELLFIRE IS VERY
CAREFUL BECAUSE WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY --
TO AS THE CAUSE AND ORIGIN
INVESTIGATOR FOR ALL FIRES
REGARDLESS OF WHO STARTS CLUES
OF OF UTILITIES AND SO WE WANT
TO HAVE WE HAVE TO SEPARATE OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE IN
ENFORCING --
THAT THE PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE
AS IT COMES TO FIRE STARTS
OBVERSES REVIEWING AND APPROVING
MITIGATION PLANS THAT ARE THE
RESPONSIBILITY.
OF THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND SO VERY CLEAR
DELINEATION.
BETWEEN THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES
BUT A VERY CLEAR --
RELATIONSHIP IN PROVIDING THE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE THAT POWER
HELLFIRE HAS BOTH IN OUR
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
PROFESSIONALS.
AND FIRE PREVENTION FIRE
PROTECTION FOR TO ENSURE THAT
THE MITIGATION PLANS HAVE ALL OF
THE ELEMENTS THAT ARE CRITICAL.
TO PROTECTING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF THE UTILITIES AS WELL AS
REDUCING THE RISK FROM FIRE
STARTS.
IT AND DO YOU HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY DO YOU INSPECT
THE LINES.
CAL FIRE HAS A RESPONSIBILITY
UNDER THE PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE --
FOR YOU'RE ENFORCING ALL --
FIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING --
WHEN UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE?
I WOULD EQUATE IT TO KNOW
DIFFERENT THAN A STOP SIGN --
WE DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
HAVE A PERSON YOU KNOW ON ON
EVERY STREET CORNER TO ENSURE
EVERYBODY'S COMPLYING.
IT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
DRIVER TO STOP AT THE STOP SIGN.
IT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
EVERYONE INCLUDING UTILITIES TO
ABIDE BY THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE.
OBVIOUSLY OUR RESPONSIBILITIES
IF WE DETERMINE SOMEONE TO BE IN
VIOLATION WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO INVESTIGATE
AND PROVIDE APPROPRIATE TO A
COURSE OF ACTION.
AT S RELATES TO THE VICTORY
CLEARANCE THE DISTANCE BETWEEN
THE TREES AND THE LINES IS THAT
PART OF WHAT YOU LOOK AT IT.
IS PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE IS VERY
CLEAR IN TERMS OF THE
REQUIREMENTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AYE FOR
DISTANCE --
I'M CLEARANCES AROUND VARIOUS
HARDWARE AND POWERLINES POWER
POLES YOU KNOW WE HADOF THERE'S
A LOT THAT YOU OBVIOUSLY ARE
CALLED ON TO DO AND AND I GUESS
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I WOULD
HAVE AND OBVIOUSLY WOULD HAVE A
BUDGET.
APPLICATION BUT DO YOU HAVE THE
THE PERSONNEL DO YOU HAVE THE
THE WHEREWITHAL TO DO ALL THAT.
IS BEING CALLED TO DO BECAUSE
WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM.
OF THE P. YOU SEE THAT THEY'RE
SORT OF BUILT TO MOVE SLOW.
AND OTHER SOME ACTIONS OUT THERE
THAT I THINK IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHERE CAL FIRE
MAY HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY IN
INSISTING AND MOVING FORWARD.
ON SOME OF THESE DIRECTORS AND
HELPING TO MOVE OUT FOR FASTER.
IF BY HAVING MORE.
PERSONNEL THAT WOULD ALLOW YOU
TO DO SO.
HELLFIRE DOES NOT HAVE THE
PERSONNEL TO INSPECT EVERY POWER
LINE EVERY PIECE OF INSULATOR
EVERY HARDWARE --
WE IDENTIFY THOSE AS WE CAN AS
WE COME ACROSS THEM AND
CERTAINLY IF THERE'S A FIRE OR A
VIOLATION WE WILL CERTAINLY
INDICATED THERE.
WERE CAL FIRE DOES NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO INSPECT THE THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF POWER POLES AND
MILES AND MILES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AYE I THINK WE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT.
NOT ASKING YOU TO BE IN THAT
POSITION CLEARLY BUT IN TERMS OF
HAVING A LITTLE BIT MORE
RESOURCES TO HELP IN TERMS OF
HELPING TO FACILITATE THE
PROCESS IF YOU HAD AN ASSESSMENT
OF THAT AND I'M NOT TODAY AT
SOME POINT --
WHAT?
INCREASING BY A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF PERSONNEL THAT HELPS.
FACILITATE SOME OF THE WORK.
WHERE THERE'S OVERLAP WITH IF
YOU SEE IT MIGHT BE HEALTH?
WE'VE BE HAPPY TO IDENTIFY WHAT
THAT.
WOULD LOOK LIKE AND AND WHAT
THAT OVERLAP WOULD BE.
FOLLOWING UP ON MR HOLDINGS A
QUESTION.
THERE YOUR YOUR OFFICE SAYS
ISSUED I THINK ELEVEN CITATIONS
FOR LOCAL DISTRICT ATTORNEYS --
TO FILE ACTION AGAINST INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES IN THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FIRES.
I GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU WOULD
BE.
DOES THAT CAUSE YOU TO CHANGE.
THE OVERSIGHT THE YOU THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT --
IS IN THOSE IN THOSE AREAS.
SO CAL FIRE AGAIN HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO INVESTIGATE
THE CAUSE AND ORIGIN OF ALL
FIRES.
AND IN THE CASE OF THE NORTH BAY
FIRES AS YOU INDICATED SENATOR
WE IDENTIFIED --
ELEVEN FIRES --
WHERE WE FOUND NOT ONLY THEIR
JOB?
THE UTILITY TO BE THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY FOR THE FIRE
START BUT ALSO THAT THERE WAS A
VIOLATION --
OF AN ELEMENT OR TWO OF THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE AND OR
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE THAT PUTS
THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY.
WHAT WE DO THERE THEN THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE ALL ELEVEN OF THOSE --
INVESTIGATIONS NO CITATIONS HAVE
BEEN ISSUE WE INVESTIGATION
REPORT IDENTIFIED VIOLATIONS.
THOSE IN THAT ARE TURNED OVER TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY THEY'RE MAKING
THEIR DECISION ABOUT WHERE TO GO
FORWARD HELLFIRE IS NOT.
DOING ANYTHING WITH THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS UNTIL WE HAVE.
THAT RIGHT AYE I'M SO I DON'T
THINK MY QUESTION WAS VERY CLEAR
GAINES WHAT I'M SAYING IS THE
FACT THAT THAT HAPPENED THE FACT
THAT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
GROUND WITH THE SAFETY --
OF OUR GREAT AGAIN JUST THE ONE
AREA.
YOU HAVE ACCORDING TO WHAT YOU
SAID PUBLIC.
RESOURCES KOTOR SAFETY CODE
WHATEVER CODE IT IS.
SAID THE YOU HAVE OVERSIGHT IN
THAT AREA SOUL ON THE OTHER SIDE
NOT THE INVESTIGATIVE SIDE DOES
THAT CAUSE YOU ANY.
YOUR REASON FOR WANTING TO
CHANGE SIZE AND THE SCOPE --
OF YOUR OVERSIGHT.
ON YOU KNOW THOSE AREAS.
THAT THAT HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO BE
VERY VERY DIFFICULT AND PROBLEMS
WITH AND SOME OF THESE AREAS WE
LEARN FROM EVERY FIRE IN EVERY --
INVESTIGATION DOES HELP US
IDENTIFY WHAT.
WHERE RECEIVED FREQUENT CAUSES
OF WE SEE A HIGHER NUMBER OF
CAUSES FROM ANY PARTICULAR
SOURCE? FOR EXAMPLE THEY THE
UPDATING OF THE GUIDELINES FOR
POWER LINES BY THAT'S ONE AREA
WHERE WE REALLY WERE REP DATING
THAT DOCUMENT --
IT ALLOWS US TO GO BACK AND YEAH
OTHER ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO DO IS THESE WILDFIRE.
MITIGATION PLANS ARE BEING
DEVELOPED THAT ALLOWS US TO
BRING THAT WHAT WE'RE LEARNING
FROM THESE FIRES AND BRING THAT
ACROSS TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
AND HELP BUILD THOSE INTO THE
FRAMEWORK OF THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
THANK YOU JESUS THAT ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
ETCETERA CANNELLA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND SO
YOU MAY HAVE ANSWERED THIS
QUESTION IF YOU DID I'M SORRY
BUT OBVIOUSLY WERE UNPRECEDENTED
TERRITORIES FORCED UP THE SCOPE
AND MAGNITUDE FIRES.
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT WHAT YOUR
BUDGET IS TO DEAL WITH THIS AND
IN WHAT THE SHORTFALL IS AND
WHAT YOU WOULD NEED TO TACKLE
THESE MOVING FORWARD
[inaudible]
IT.
SPECIFIC TO FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES
FIRE PREVENTION.
WELL WE CONTINUE TO WORK AND
AGAIN THAT'S WHAT WAS REFLECTED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND
WHAT WAS APPROVED --
IN IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WITH A
HOMES NINETY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN IN IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FORCE
CARBON PLAN.
SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT THAT ABOUT
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS WAS
TO FIND SIX FIRE PREVENTION
SUBSCRIBE FIRE FUELS.
MANAGEMENT FEELS TREATMENT CREW --
CREWS WERE LOOKING AT AGAIN THE
INVESTMENT OF A HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS INTO THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR ADDITIONAL
HIGH CAP AND TRADE FUNDING FOR
FIRE PREVENTION --
AND FORCED HEALTH PROJECTS ARE
THOSE ARE ALL THINGS VEERED
RIGHT TOWARDS GETTING AFTER AND
CONTINUING TO INCREASE THE PACE
AND SCALE OF GETTING A FIRE
PREVENTION WORK DONE ON THE
GROUND.
SO YEAR COVER FOR YOUR FULLY
FUNDED TO DEAL WITH ALL THE FOR
THE VEGETATION AS WERE FIRE
PREVENTION THAT YOU NEED DO WITH
THE MONEY YOU JUST DISCUSS.
WILL AUTOMATE TO REACH OUR GOALS
OF VOTING OVER FIVE HUNDRED AT
LEAST FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES YOU'RE ANNUALLY AND TO
CONTINUE TO COMBAT THIS
INCREASING CHALLENGE OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO NEED. TO
TO MEET OR EXCEED OUR FUNDING
EVERY YEAR TO CONTINUE.
TO MEET THIS INCREASING
CHALLENGED SO YEAH SO MISTER
MAYES ASK JUST IN MY HERE SO
WHAT'S WHAT'S THE TOTAL NUMBER
YOU LISTEN A FEW DIFFERENT FUNDS
THAT.
YOU'RE GETTING WHAT'S THE TOTAL
PER YEAR THAT YOU NEED.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT CERTAINLY
SIT DOWN WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
WORK ON THOSE OUR DISCUSSION
DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION NOW
I DON'T HAVE IT READILY
AVAILABLE.
IS IT BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S NECESSARY OR HOW HOW CAN
IF WITH PART OF OUR SOLUTION IS
A FUNDING COMPONENT WE DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER HOW HOW DO WE
DEAL WITH THAT.
I THINK IT MAY BE TO STEP IN AND
ANSWER I THINK THAT IT'S THERE'S
ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION THAT'S GOING TO ALL THE
ACTIVITIES AND I THINK.
HE IS THE THE CHIEF IS JUST.
OF A KINDA CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
THAT BREAKS OUT TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION SO THERE'S THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY TOTAL MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S GOING FOR THE
WHOLE RANGE.
OF OF FORCE PROGRAMS AND E. IN
OURS A QUESTION OF WHETHER YOU
JUST TERM ALL OF PREVENTION WE
CAN GET WE CAN WORK WITH THOSE
NUMBERS AND GET THAT.
AND DE THAT DEFERRED THEIR
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTIONS YOU CAN
ALWAYS DO MORE.
OF WE HAVE JUST DOUBLED WHAT WE
ARE PROJECTING TO DO AND I'M
GOING TO TRY.
TO THROUGH ALL THE DIFFERENT
METHODS THAT THE ALLOCATIONS BUT
MADE MEET THAT GOAL.
WELL AGAIN IT JUST SEEMS LIKE AS
PART OF THE SOLUTION WE SHOULD
HAVE PROPER FUNDING.
WE SURE AND THE HECK DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE PROPER FUNDING AS WE
RELY ON THE PROFESSIONALS TO
TELL US.
IN A CONCERNS ME THAT IS NOT
READILY AVAILABLE SO I HOPE THAT
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN GET.
SO THE WE LOOK AT A TALK A LONG
TERM SOLUTION WE CAN PUT THAT
FUNDED IN THEIR I STILL MORE
QUESTIONS BUT MISTER MAYES WAS
JUMPING ON THAT POINT.
YEAH THIS IS A PUT THIS REALLY
IS AN IMPORTANT QUESTION BECAUSE
IF WE WE KNOW THAT --
WE HAVE TOO MUCH FUEL.
AND WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
PROPERLY MANAGE WE KNOW THAT NOW
WE KNOW THAT DURING THE LEAN
TIMES THAT THERE WASN'T ENOUGH
YOU CAN WE HAD TO CUT BACK. TO
BEING VERY IMPORTANT TO US TO
UNDER.
THAT ALLOCATION SHOULD BE --
NOT JUST THIS YEAR BUT GOING
FORWARD SO BE GREAT TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A PLAN I'M AND END UP
AND I THINK WHAT WE MEAN BY THAT
IS WHAT'S THE PLAN TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM HOW MUCH DO YOU NEED TO
BE ABLE. TO TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM
OVER.
AND OVER THE NEXT COUPLE KNOW
THE ONE THING THAT'S GOING ON
AND I SORT OF CUT MY COMMENT
SHORT BECAUSE OF THE LIMIT.
IS THE THE FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK
FORCE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
ESTABLISHED IS REALLY EVERYBODY
THAT NEEDS TO BE AT THE TABLE
AND DIESEL IKANA QUESTIONS IT'S
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO ADDRESS.
OVER TIME.
WE'VE TAKEN A SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF
MONEY WERE DOUBLING WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND WE'RE DOING IT IN MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS AND INCREASE
WASTE AND WE'RE DONE BEFORE SO
WE'LL GET TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES.
THE QUESTION IS IS WHETHER THERE
ARE OTHER THINGS TO DO THAT
WE'RE NOT DOING HOW MUCH MORE
THEY COST.
AND I THINK WE'RE HAVING FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STATE GOVERNMENT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PRIVATE LAND
OWNERS NGOS EVERYBODY'S AROUND
THE TABLE TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION AND THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
OKAY SO OF COUPLE QUESTIONS SO
THAT CHIEF YOU MENTIONED THAT.
THAT YOU HAVE PROBLEMS WITHIN
VITAL CLEARANCE CAN YOU DISCUSS
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT YOU'RE
HAVING THE BILL WHO ARE THE
PROBLEMS WITH.
WELL IN THE CASE OF FOR EXAMPLE
IN IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTERS
CONCERNS ABOUT FIRE FREQUENCY
WITHIN THE CHAPARRAL AND WORKING
WITH THAT THOSE COMMUNITIES TO
TO COME TO WHAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE FIRE FREQUENCY
BECAUSE THERE ARE THOSE THAT.
THERE'S CONCERNS IT TOO MUCH
FIRE OVER --
SHORT INTERVALS CAN'T CHANGE
THAT.
YOU KNOW THEY GET EXOTICS OTHER
SPECIES THAT WERE SITTING DOWN
TO THE TABLE IN FRONT THE TERM
HOW DO WE YOU COME TO SOME
CONSENSUS ON WHAT THE RIGHT
AMOUNT IS ABOUT THE SAME TIME.
RECOGNIZING WE IF WE DON'T
PROVIDE VERY FUEL MODIFICATIONS
TO SOME OF THESE COMMUNITIES
THEY'RE GOING TO BURN.
AND SO IT'S IT'S I THINK IT'S
GOING BACK TO SOME OF THE OTHER
QUESTIONS JUST EVEN WITHIN THE
STATE FAMILY AND WE ARE LOOKING
AT EFFICIENCIES BETWEEN
ORGANIZATIONS IN OUR PERMITTING.
AND A REVIEW PROCESS AND SUCH
CIRCUMVENTING PROCESSES BUT IT'S
LOOKING AT EFFICIENCIES AND HOW
WE CAN DO THINGS TOGETHER AND
WORK TOWARDS SHORTENED TIME
FRAMES OF APPROVALS.
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE TO GET TO
THE APPROVALS IT REALLY DEPENDS
AT FOR EXAMPLE WE'RE WORKING
VERY HARD TO GET THE VEGETATION
TREATMENT PROGRAM ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT APPROVED --
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
PROGRAMMATIC DOCUMENT TO GET.
DID WE LOOK AT VERY SIMILAR
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE TO
HAVE VERY SIMILAR KINDS OF
TREATMENTS AND VERY SIMILAR
IMPACTS.
ON THE GROUND AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING FOR NUMBER OF YEARS NOW
TO HAVE THIS PROGRAMMATIC
DOCUMENT APPROVED IN ITS.
BEING REVIEWED WE'VE HAD OUT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND DOES THE
KINDS OF TOOLS ARE VERY HELPFUL
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT IN GETTING THIS COMES
OUT WHEN YOU'RE.
GOING TO HAVE A LARGER
PROGRAMMATIC DOCUMENT IT DOES TO
SCIENCE AND FAX ACROSS THE
BORDER CROSSED ISSUE AND WHEN
YOU HAVE A SPECIFIC APPLICATION
THERE MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
SPUR. TO THAT PARCEL OF LAND OR
LANDSCAPE.
BUT YOU HAVE THIS BASE OF
SCIENCE THAT'S BEEN DOCUMENTED
APPROVED AND SIGNED OFF ON THAT
YOU CAN USE AS PART OF THAT SO
IT JUST MOVES YOU CLOSER TO THE
OUTCOMES SURE HOW WAS IT TAKE.
TO TO PREPARE THE DOCUMENT
PROCESS IT THROUGH USED JUST
TWELVE MONTHS EIGHTEEN MONTHS
SIX MONTHS [inaudible]
I YEARS.
HERE S. BEST A PROGRAM AT WE
ASSUME YOU CAN'T DO SPECIALIZED
ENVIRONMENT DOCUMENTS ANTI DO
THEM THOUGH THE LARGE ONE CUT IN
INTEREST AS SECRETARY ALERTS AS
A LOT OF WORK THAT GOES INTO
BUILDING THE PROGRAMMATIC DOCKET
LOTS OF SCIENCE LOTS OF FEW
BUILDING THE FOUNDATION AND THEN
WHAT.
YOU HAVE THAT DOCUMENT HE'S VERY
SPECIFIC PROJECTS COMMAND THAT
FALL UNDER THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO WHICH YOU CAN DO TO SPECIFIC
PROJECTS NOT OF THE LARGER
DOCUMENTS ON THE PROGRAMMATIC
THING IS THE THING THAT YEARS.
CIFRA PROJECTS OR MUCH BRIDGE
ORDER WIDERSTAND BUT CAN YOU DO
THE SPECIFIC PROJECTS INTO A
LARGER DOCUMENT.
YOU COULD YOU MIGHT HAVE TO DO A
LITTLE MORE SCIENCE OR LOAD MORE
THINGS OR OTHERWISE CONTAINED IN
THE LARGER DOCUMENT.
SO HE DOESN'T HOLD IT OFF IT
JUST MIGHT MAKE IT A LITTLE
LONGER OKAY SO FEW DID A
SPECIFIC DOCUMENT.
I LOOK I KNOW WERE BE CAREFUL
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT PROCESS I
GET THAT.
BUT AGAIN IF WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
A DECISION TO TRY TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
WE HAVE TO KNOW THE FACT BUT I
THINK THE REVERSE IS TRUE
BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE.
IS THAT TRYING TO USE THE LARGER
DOCUMENT TO FACILITATE PROJECTS
AND MAKING THEM QUICKER SO THAT
YOU GET OUT OF THE WAY WITH A
LOT OF THE SCIENCE YOU HAVE
CERTIFIED YOU HAVE DONE.
IT CAN BE USED AND PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE TO REINVENT EVERYTHING WHEN
THEY DO THE INDIVIDUAL YEAH BY I
GUESS BECAUSE I GUESS PROCESS SO.
SO COULD IT COULD TAKE YEARS TO
GO THROUGH THAT THE LARGER
DOCUMENT.
IS THAT BECAUSE IT'S HELD UP IN
COURT DO YOU THROUGH THE PROCESS
IS THAT WHITE EXCELLENT KNOW
IDEALLY YOU WANT TO BUILD A
DOCUMENT THAT IT'S NOT THE AUDIT
GIVEN DOES THAT HAPPEN THOUGH.
CERTAINLY IT DOES AND SO ARE AYE
WE WANT TO SURE WE HAVE A
DOCUMENT THAT IS SOUND AND SOLID
AND HAS THE GREATEST CONSENSUS
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED
GOING BECAUSE WE HAVE A PROCESS
FOR LARGE SCALE NBA NFL STADIUMS
AND A LOT FASTER.
THAN WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT TRYING
TO DO IT FOR SOME OF THESE
PROCESSES WELL RIGHT.
WHAT WERE ABOUT AGNOSTIC ON THAT
ISSUE?
SENATOR STONE I THINK YOU MISSED
YOUR FIRST I WANT TO SAY --
TO CHIEF COME LOS THANK YOU --
TO YOU IN YOUR TROOPS FOR YOUR
YOUR ATTENTION --
TO ALL THE FIRES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT IN PARTICULAR THE
THE CRANSTON FIRE IN THE HOLY
FIRE AND I KNOW MANY OF YOUR
TROOPS ARE FRIENDS OF MINE THAT
HAVE BEEN WORKING MANY MANY
HOURS TO TRY TO PRESERVE
PROPERTY IN LIFE AND I I WANT TO
KNOW.
HOW MUCH WE ALL APPRECIATE ALL
ALL OF THOSE EFFORTS?
I'M NOT GETTING TO THE MATTER OF
HANDS CAN YOU TELL ME --
LAST YEAR --
HOW MANY ACRES OF PRESCRIBER
EARNED IT CAL FIRE?
ENTERTAIN INCOMPLETE.
CALVET COMPLETED JUST OVER
NINETEEN THOUSAND ACRES A
BROADCAST PRESCRIPTION BURN OUT
DURING THIS LAST FISCAL YEAR
CONCLUDING I JUNE THIRTIETH.
THAT'S UP.
OF FROM ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
ACRES A FEW YEARS PRIOR.
OKAY AND IT BUT YOU HAVE A GOAL
OF MITIGATING IF YOU WELFARE
PRESCRIBE BURNS AND IMPRESSION
MANAGEMENT.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES A
YEAR SO.
WERE A LONG WAYS OFF IT SEEMS
LIKE TO ME THEN.
AGAIN MAYBE THAT'S OR A RESOURCE
ISSUE WHICH WE CERTAINLY --
ONE KNOW ABOUT --
ALSO.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THINNING OF
FORCE WE'VE WE'VE NEGLECTED
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY FOR SO LONG
AND WE TALK ABOUT PRESCRIBED
BURNS YOU GOT TO BE EXTRA
CAREFUL NOW BECAUSE YOU HAVE
SUCH DENSE VEGETATION
[inaudible]
AND LOCAL COMPANIES SIR --
CAUTIOUS ABOUT PRESCRIBED BURNS
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO DANCE NOW TO
GET OUT OF CONTROL HAVING
TROUBLE GETTING INSURANCE --
WHAT WISDOM CAN YOU OFFER SOME
OF THE SMALLER COMPANIES ABOUT
HOW THEY CAN DO THIS PRESCRIBED
BURNS AND HE'S VERY DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS THAT?
YOU HAVE UNDERTAKEN I ASSUME
THAT UNDER THE NINETEEN THOUSAND
ACRES INTO HAVE --
PRESCRIBED IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR
I ASSUME THAT NONE OF THEM GOT
OUT OF CONTROL AND CREATED.
A SIGNIFICANT LOSSES.
THERE IS ALWAYS RISK WITH
PRESCRIBED BURNING I THINK IF
YOU LOOK ACROSS THE NATION
THERE'S ALWAYS THERE'S THERE'S
AN INHERENT RISK IN PUTTING FIRE
ON THE GROUND.
BUT WE ALL DO COLLECT THE THOSE
MITIGATING THAT RISK TO THE
LOWEST POSSIBLE POINT IN THAT'S
HEARD OF THAT DESCRIPTION
EARLIER IT'S BURNING WHEN WE
HAVE A PRESCRIPTION THAT'S WHEN
THE WEATHER.
THE FUEL CONDITIONS ARE ALL THAT
ARE IN ALIGNMENT SO THAT IT
MEETS THE PRESCRIPTION INTENSITY
YOU WANT WHILE YOU SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE YOUR RISK OF A SKATE.
AND AS WE WORK THROUGH THESE
DISCUSSIONS THAT DO THE ABILITY
TO INCREASE IS GETTING EVERYONE
MORE COMFORTABLE THAT WE AGAIN
YOU FOR DISCUSSIONS ABOUT A
CENTRALIZED APPROVAL AND
TRAINING PROCESS. FOR ALL THE
BURNERS IN CALIFORNIA IF WE'RE
GOING TO GET BEYOND CAL FIRES
TWENTY THOUSAND ACRES AND AND
OTHERS WE NEED TO EXTEND AND
LEVERAGE OUR ABILITY.
TO WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS TO
BRING MORE BUT WE HAVE TO
OBVIOUSLY HAVE OUR PARTNERS MORE
COMFORTABLE.
WITH THE SHARED RISK AND IT
CAN'T ALWAYS BE THE STATE
ASSUMING A 100% OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY.
YOU KNOW FROM --
FROM A POTENTIALLY NO ESCAPED
BURN ABOUT THE SAME TIME WE
CAN'T PUT ALL THAT ON THE BACKS
OF OF THAT BURNER IF WE'RE EVER
GOING TO HOPE TO INCREASE THE
SPACE AND SCALE SO IT.
IT'S A TOUGH QUESTION IT'S A
HARD QUESTION AND IT'S TAKEN US
A LONG TIME TO GET HERE BUT
THERE ARE SOME.
VERY EXCELLENT DISCUSSIONS GOING
ON RIGHT NOW IN THIS PRESCRIBED
BURN COMMUNITY AS WE TALK ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL FOR LIABILITY
INSURANCE WE TALK ABOUT POOLED
INSURANCE THAT.
THE PRESCRIBER COMMUNITY ACROSS
THE LEVERAGING IDEAS WHICH
SHARED POOL OF OF INSURANCE AND
VERY PROMISING POTENTIAL
APPROACH BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
ALL OF THAT --
AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE TRUST ON
THE OF THAT PART OF OUR
RESIDENTS IN THE STATE THAT THEY
TRUST US AND THEY TRUST ARE
BERMAN PARTNERS TO GET
[inaudible]
DOWN WE HEARD FROM TESTIMONY
THAT ROUGHLY 6% OF THE
GEOGRAPHICAL MASS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS COVERED IN
TREES OR PRICES NEED SOME TYPE
OF CLEARING.
OUT OF THAT I THINK ABOUT 60% OF
ITS FEDERAL.
HOW TELL ME ABOUT --
YOUR RELATIONSHIP OF THE U. S.
FOR SERVICE AND HOW YOU ARE
SYMBIOTIC IN YOUR IN YOUR
RELATIONSHIP OR IS IT --
STREAM TO ME WHAT TO DO.
CLEARING AND AND STATE AREAS
WHICH IS YOUR RESPONSIBILITY ARE
YOUR FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS AT
KEEPING UP WITH YOUR PROGRESS
AND VICE VERSA.
SO WE WE ALL HAVE DIFFERENT
RESPONSIBILITIES STATE FEDERAL
LOCAL WE ALL COME IN TO THAT
WITH DIFFERENT MISSIONS BUT I
WILL TELL YOU THAT IN CALIFORNIA
IN PARTICULAR --
WE ARE WE HAVE A IS EXTREMELY
CLOSE WORKING RELATIONSHIP OF
THAT OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS IN
PARTICULAR FOR SERVICE ARE PART
OF THE FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK
FORCE.
UP THEIR PART OF THE WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM THAT JIM
TALKED ABOUT --
THERE A CRITICAL PARTNER IN
WATERSHED PROJECTS BECAUSE IT IN
IN CALIFORNIA --
ISSUES WATERSHEDS FIRES INSECT
AND DISEASE KNOW NO BOUNDARIES
AND SO USING TOOLS SUCH AS THE
GOOD NEIGHBOR AUTHORITY WHICH
THE FOR SERVICES BEEN VERY OPEN
AND WORKING WITH US IN
DEVELOPING.
UP THESE ARE ALL TO OF MEMBERS
WERE SHARING RESOURCES AND
WORKING ACROSS FORCE BOUNDARIES --
YES SOMETIMES WE MAY BE AT ODDS
BETWEEN THE STATE'S ROLE IN
MISSION ON PRIVATE LAND AND
FEDERAL.
MISSION AND RESPONSIBILITY AND
PUBLIC POLICY BUT IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY COLLECTIVELY TO
BE AT THE TABLE.
AND WORK THROUGH THOSE AND NOT
LET THAT BE THE IMPEDIMENT AT
THE BOUNDARY. TO GET THIS WORK
DONE AND I THINK ALL THE EFFORTS
THAT WERE TALKED ABOUT TODAY ARE
REALLY LEADING THE WAY IN
BREAKING ALL THOSE BARRIERS DOWN
TO GETTING THE WORK DONE.
AND WOULD YOU SAY THAT THE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE FEDS IN
THE STATE IS --
EXEMPLARY AT THE PRESENT TIME OR
DO YOU THINK THAT THEIR
RELATIONSHIP SOMETHING NEEDS
SOME MORE HELP.
WITH RESPECT TO FIRE MITIGATION
CLEARING GETTING RID OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION DEAD
OR DYING TREES.
ARE WE GETTING THE KIND OF
COOPERATION AND THIS EMERGENCY
SITUATION TO REDUCE THE SENATE
CHIEF AND I SPENT YESTERDAY WITH
THE SECRETARY OF INTERIOR THIS
WELL LISTA.
AS MUCH ON REGIONAL FOR ST.
AND WE ARE ON THE SAME PAGE ON A
LOT OF THIS BUT I WOULD REFER
YOU BACK TO MY EARLIER COMMENTS
THAT.
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THEIR
BUDGET FIX GO IN FOR A YEAR AND
SO IF THEY HAVE TO SPEND AN
EXCESSIVE AMOUNT OF MONEY ON
FIRE FIGHTING DEATH MUCH LESS
MONEY FOR RESTORATION OF
TREATMENT.
AND I HAVE AND THAT IS NOT A
FUNCTION OF HOW GOOD WERE
GETTING ALONG IT'S A FUNCTION OF
THEIR STRUCTURE SO WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT.
FIXED BECAUSE I THINK THAT SPEAK
TO YOUR QUESTION FIGURE TWO MORE
QUESTIONS AND NOT BE DONE.
I WANT TO GET BACK --
TO THE PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSION --
IT WAS INTERESTING TO HEAR THE
THE PRESIDENT SAY THAT THEY LIKE
TO TAKE THINGS SLOW.
THAT THE PC --
I THINK MANY OF US ON THE
COMMITTEE WERE A BIT ALARMED BY
THAT COMMENT THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS HAPPEN.
QUITE A BIT FASTER BUT HE
MENTIONED THAT HE BASICALLY HAVE
THREE DEEP THIRTY BEING COUNTERS
OF THE ONES THAT ARE OVERSEEING
ALL THE ELECTRICAL LINES OF
THOUSANDS OF LINES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE SAW NUMBER FIRES WERE
STARTED.
THE FAULT OF SOME UTILITIES AND
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS A CONCERN FOR SOME OF US MANY
OF US --
WHERE DO YOU SEE MR PRIME LA
DACHAU FIRE IT IN THIS NEW
NORMAL IS RECALLING AND NOW DO
YOU SEE THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
MORE OF A FIRE OVERSIGHT?
IN THE INSPECTION PROCESS
PARTNERING WITH THE P. YOU SEE
TO ALLEVIATE [inaudible]
THE SHORT.
AMOUNT OF MANPOWER A FEW WILL
THAT THEY HAVE TO ENSURE THAT.
WE GET THE PROPER VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IN AROUND DANGEROUS
POWERLINES.
I THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THAT HE PRESENTED TO
YOU IN HIS LETTER IN JULY REALLY
LAYS OUT THE KINDS OF THINGS WE
THINK NEED TO BE DONE.
BY WORKING WITH THE UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND AND THE UTILITIES
THEMSELVES TO CONTINUE.
TO IMPROVE AND WERE AT THE THAT
THE FILE FIRE MITIGATION PLANS
AND REDUCE THAT RISK.
I'VE OH MORE OVERSIGHT CAL FIRE
AGAIN THE STATE DOESN'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO STEP IN AND PROVIDE
YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS
MORE PEOPLE.
RIGHT CLEARLY AGAIN AS I TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER THE DELINEATION OF
RESPONSIBILITIES BETWEEN THE
REGULATORY RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
COMMISSION.
AND CAL FIRES RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENFORCE THE FORCE AND FIRE LAWS
YES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SAME
POWER LINE SAME INFRASTRUCTURE
BUT TWO DIFFERENT PROCESSES. ONE
IN STATUTE IN BEEN ONE IN IN THE
REGULATORY PROCESS OUT WE NEED
AND WILL CONTINUE TO LEVERAGE
OUR AMMO YOU WITH THE COMMISSION
TO PROVIDE THAT TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE.
AND SUPPORT BUT CERTAINLY AS THE
FORWARD TO DISCUSS.
IMPROVING THESE MITIGATION PLANS
TO ENHANCE OF THE ABILITY TO GET
MORE -- A
THIRD PARTY OVERSIGHT AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL --
ELEMENTS WITHIN THOSE PLANS TO
REDUCE RISK [inaudible]
APPRECIATE THAT --
AND THEN LASTLY --
I HEARD YOU TALK ABOUT THIS
PROGRAMMATIC OUT HE AYE ARE --
THAT.
SUCH THAT WE CAN NOT EXPEDITE --
REVIEWS OF AREAS WE NEED TO BE
CLEARED BUT I THINK IT'S IT'S A
LEASE ALARMING FOR ME THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE YEARS BEFORE WE HAVE
THAT PROGRAMMATIC <c.green> I ARE IN</c>
SUCH PLACES YEAH MANY GOING TO
DEAL WITH THE LITIGATION THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AFTERWARDS --
WHEN I GO OUT AND TOWN HALLS
GOING TO COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW
ON FIRE RAGED AREAS OF OF MY
DISTRICT PEOPLE ARE SAYING WOULD
YOU DO AND? TO REDUCE THIS RISK
ON US WE HAVE THE FIRE COME YOU
KNOW RIGHT UP TO THE BACKYARD OF
A HOME IN LEGAL STORAGE YOU KNOW
IT GOT VERY VERY CLOSE.
SOME OF THE RESIDENCES IN AND
AND MANY OF MY FIRE COMMUNITIES --
MOSTLY OUT IN THE IDYLLWILD AREA
THAT YOU MENTION ARE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS BEEN THE BENEFICIARY OF
OF GRANTS HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB
CLEARING YOU DID A GREAT JOB OF
CLEARING THAT.
SAVE A LOT OF WIRES FROM THE THE
CRANSTON FIRE FROM --
MAKING ITS WAY --
INTO INTO HOMES [inaudible]
AND I I KNOW WE WANT TO BE VERY
CAREFUL HOW WE DISCUSS
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES HERE ON THE
DAIS AND OUT I WANT TO PIGGYBACK
ON MY MY MY COLLEAGUE A SENATOR
CAN I WAS.
COMMENTS THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE TALK ABOUT --
REASONS WHY WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO GET IN THERE TO EXPEDITIOUSLY
REMOVED [inaudible]
RUSSIAN AND TREES AND WE TALK
ABOUT WELL WE HAVE SOME.
ENVIRONMENTAL BARRIERS THAT WE
HAVE TO MOVE THROUGH --
IS NOTHING PROVOKES MORE ANGER
IN MY DISTRICT THAT WHEN I GIVE
AN EXCUSE LIKE THAT.
AND SO HOW CAN WE BE SENSITIVE
TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
BUT UNDERSTAND THE RISKS OF THE
DELAYS THAT THESE REGULATIONS
IMPOSED ON US. TO EFFECTIVELY GO
IN AND CLEAR BRUSHING CLEAR
TREES IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF
PROTECTING.
OUR RESIDENTS THAT ARE SCARED TO
DEATH.
THERE HOMES ARE GOING TO BE
BURNED DOWN AND AFTER A FIGHT
WITH THEIR INSURANCE COMPANY
BECAUSE IT MAY BE UNDER INSURED
I CAN'T GET BACK INTO THE HOUSE
AGAIN GET A BILL FAST --
HOW CAN WE EMBARK ON SOME TYPE
OF THE STREAMLINING PROGRAM THAT
IS SENSITIVE TO THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT GETS THE BRUSHING GETS THE
TREES?
ATTY HERE POST HASTE.
WELL JUST TO CLARIFY IT.
SO WE HOPE TO STOP IT TAKES
SEVERAL YEARS MORE FOR THE I. R.
IT'S BEEN IN PROCESS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS BUT WE ARE WHO
WE WERE LITERALLY BRINGING IT TO
FRUITION AND SO.
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT DOCUMENT WILL
BE IN PLAY HERE.
SHORTLY IN THE INTERIM WE HAVE
OTHER PROCESSES BY WHICH WE GET
PROJECTS APPROVED WEEK ME LOOK
AT THEM ON THE INDIVIDUAL BASIS
WE WORK THROUGH THE SECRET
PROCESS --
AND AND GET THEM DONE OBVIOUSLY
TO IMPLEMENT OVER FOUR HUNDRED
GRANTS ALREADY IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WERE GETTING A LOT
OF GOOD WORK DONE.
ARE ON THE GROUND IN THERE'S
THERE'S MANY COMMUNITIS THAT
ARE FINDING THROUGH FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS ARE.
IN THE WORK IS GETTING DONE WE
JUST NEED TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
EFFICIENCIES IN THESE AREAS
WHERE ABOUT MAYBE WERE NOT IN
AGREEMENT AND FIND A WAY A PATH
THROUGH.
THE WE WERE GETTING THE
DOCUMENTS DOWN IN AGAIN ARE WILL
BE ONE OF A NUMBER OF TOOLS THAT
ALLOW US TO GET STAND MORE FISH.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR SERVICE
AND I HOPE YOU'LL BLOOD --
TAKE THEIR RECOMMENDATION ABOUT
WORKING CLOSER WITH THE PC IS
OVERSEEING SOME OF THESE ISSUES
ARE VERY CONCERNED.
FOR I WOULD TO LAST COMMENTERS
QUICKLY THEY TOLD ME --
MISTER WOOD INDUSTRY DOLLARS
FIRST.
MISTER CHAIR SAMPRAS WELL THANK
YOU CHIEF IT'S GONNA --
I DIDN'T THINK I'D EVER GET TO
KNOW ALL YOUR UNIT CHIEF SINCE
I'M HERE INCIDENT COMMANDERS --
SO CLOSELY BUT I KEEP RUNNING
INTO THEM BECAUSE OF THESE FIRES
SO I APPRECIATE EVERYTHING
YOU'RE DOING AND EVERYTHING A
DART ARE DOING TO PROTECT
PROPERTY AND AND PEOPLE --
COUPLE YOU KNOW MIGHT TAKE AWAY
FROM LISTENING TO YOU IS THAT.
FOR SOME THESE ACTIVITIES TO
REALLY HAPPEN WE NEED A LONG
TERM SUSTAINED SOURCES THAT A
FAIR CHARACTERIZATION.
YES OKAY ALRIGHT.
JUST SAY THAT AGAIN BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN THAT'S
WHAT SOME OF US BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR QUITE AWHILE.
AND I RECOGNIZE ALSO THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE SOMETHING THAT THAT
WOULD WE GET INTO A BUDGET
SITUATION BOARD TO HAVE AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN THAT ISN'T
GOING.
TO HAMPER YOUR ABILITY TO DO
YOUR JOB FOR FIRE SUPPRESSION
AND PREVENTION SO SO THANK YOU --
THANK YOU MS Y. MAKE SURE WE'RE
CLEAR ON THAT APPRECIATE THAT.
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENCE
RACIAL PROGRAMS AND PREVENTION
PROGRAMS OUT THERE.
AND THEY'RE OVERSEEN BY WHAT YOU.
ACROSS MANY DIFFERENT APARTMENTS.
IS THERE ANYONE OVERSEEING THESE
IN A COMPREHENSIVE WAY.
SO AND I AND THE RECENT LET ME
LET ME LET ME PHRASE THIS IN A
WAY THAT. FOR EXAMPLE --
BROADBAND IS SOMETHING THAT I'VE
WORKED ON SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE
YEARS AND ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WITH PEOPLE WHO WANT TO MOVE FOR
A BROADBAND PROJECTS IS.
THAT A LOT OF THE DIFFERENT
GRANT PROGRAMS HAVE TO GO
THROUGH GO THROUGH MULTIPLE
AGENCIES AND BY THE TIME YOU GET
ONE LINED UP.
WERE TO LINE UP THE FIRST ONE
MAY HAVE EXPIRED.
SO SO YOU KNOW.
WHO DOES ANYONE HAVE THE BIG
PICTURE YOU COULD SHOOT SOMEBODY
SO WE TALK ABOUT STAKEHOLDER
HAVING OBSTACLES AT THE TABLE?
TO ACTUALLY GO THROUGH SOME OF
THESE SO I CAN ACTUALLY MOVE
FORT OR SECOND BE THE FACT THAT
FORCE TASK FORCE IT GONNA BE AND
PARK THAT BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAPPENED INTO.
IT IN THE FORM THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY UNMODERATED
YESTERDAY IN REDDING WAS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TALKED ABOUT
EVERY AGENCY AND HOW THEY DON'T
WORK TOGETHER.
WE ARE LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE MOST
OF THEM IN THE RESOURCES AGENCY
AND NOW THE TASKFORCE TAKING
THEM ALL SO WE AT THE STATE
LEVEL HAVE BEEN BETTER ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO BREAK DOWN THE
SILOS. TO TO TRY TO HAVE THE
IMPETUS TO GET THINGS IF I COULD
MAYBE SAID TO THE MISTER WOOD
AND UNDER THE WATER SYNDROME
PROGRAM THAT'S EXACTLY WE'RE
DOING WITH OUR STATE AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS.
WERE MEETING UP THE MEETING THE
CHIEFS CONFERENCE ROOM TO TO SIT
DOWN WITH FOLKS AND SAY YOU GOT
THIS PART OF MONEY WE GOT THAT.
WHAT'S IT LOOK LIKE WHEN YOU PUT
THESE PROGRAMS ON ON ON THE
LANDSCAPE AND HOW WE DO IT IN A
MORE SEVERE YOU PLAY SO --
IT TAPPING IT SOMEONE ORGANIC IN
THAT CASE BUT IT'S DEFINITELY.
WITH THE FUNDS THAT ARE NOW
BECOMING AVAILABLE IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE DO THAT I THINK WE'RE
YOU KNOW WE'RE DOING THAT.
HAPPY TO EXPORT THE MODEL
ELSEWHERE.
SO THE THE X. AS YOU MENTIONED
IN THE EARLIER COMMENTS
EXPANSION OF THE FIRE SEASON
THIRTY DAYS EARLIER THIRTY DAYS
LATER NOW.
THAT IS THAT OBVIOUS IS HAVING
AN EFFECT ON YOUR ABILITY TO THE
PREVENTION OR OR IS IT NOT.
NO CLEARLY AS YOU KNOW WE WERE
FORTUNATE AGAIN SOMEBODY
AUGMENTATIONS OF BEEN YEAR ROUND
STAFFING ON FIFTY TWO FIRE
ENGINES AND THAT HAS BEEN ABLE
TO GIVE US A SOME EXTRA PUNCH
DURING THAT THAT.
TRADITIONALLY NON FIRE SEASON
MONTHS --
AND WE WE LEVERAGE THAT AGAIN
THIS YEAR BUT THE WINDOW TO GET
THE WORK DONE THIS YEAR WAS VERY
VERY SHORT.
WE WENT RIGHT FROM THROUGH
DECEMBER WE WERE ABLE TO DO MUCH
WORK AT ALL IN THE FALL THAT'S
KIND OF OUR FALL BURNING WINDOW.
AND THEN WE HAD RAIN AND WE WERE
IN A WINDOW TO BERNARD DO WORK
WE DID WHAT WE COULD.
AND THEN WE'RE RIGHT BACK INTO
FIRE ACTIVITY AND SO IT'S A IT
IT.
THE IT IS IMPACTING FIRE SEASON
IS IMPACTING ALL OF THIS IT'S
IMPACTING CAPACITY AND IT'S
IMPACTING THE WINDOWS.
WHICH WE CAN SAFELY GET THE WORK
DONE.
SO WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
EIGHT EIGHT DEDICATED PREVENTION.
COMPONENT THAT WORKS ON THESE
THINGS YEAR ROUND AND AND YOU'RE
AND YOU'RE FINE AS SEPARATE
DEPARTMENT THAT THIS FIRE
PREVENTION THE SIX FIRE A
PRESCRIBED FIRE FUELS CRUZ IS
EXACTLY WHAT THAT'S GEARED
TOWARDS ITS THESE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
FOCUSED ON THIS TWELVE MONTHS
OUT OF THE YEAR.
I TAKE ADVANTAGE OR THINGS THEY
CAN EVEN DO DURING THE SUMMER
MONTHS THAT --
ARE LOW RISK THAT CAN KEEP WORK
GOING ON ALL YEAR.
THANK YOU SHARON SO.
AND VEGETATION TO THIS FOR CAN.
CHIEF HAD LOTS USE ME.
A SO YOU YOU MANAGE ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT EDUCATION I THINK THE
SENATOR BROUGHT UP A GREAT POINT
THAT YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
FORESTRY WE TALK ABOUT.
BUT THERE IS THERE'S OAK
WOODLANDS THERE'S A CHAPARRAL
THERE'S FORCES WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF VEGETATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ALL LIVE.
IT'S ALL GROWING.
PHOTOSYNTHESIS AND AND MOISTURE
AND ALL THOSE THINGS MAKE IT
GROW.
AND THERE'S BEEN A BIG HUGE
DEBATE NATIONALLY FOR ABOUT THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS AND HERE IN
THE STATE ABOUT WE SHOULD JUST
WALK AWAY FROM IT AND LET IT DO
ITS NATURAL THING.
AND THERE'S BEEN MANY LAWSUITS.
MANY DIFFERENT GROUPS --
AT EACH OTHER'S THROAT OVER HOW
WE SHOULD MANAGE BUT WE KINDA AT
LEAST IN MY MIND.
THE CONCLUSION IS IF WE JUST DO
NOTHING AT THIS POINT RIGHT NOW
WE DO NOT THINK.
AND WE JUST LET IT GO BACK TO
ITS NATURAL STATE.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF OF NGUYEN
BUT OR WILL LET'S WIN IT WILL
BURN IT WILL EVENTUALLY BURN
CORRECT CORRECT.
SO.
WHAT WE TALK ABOUT THE PROCESSES
THAT?
WE MOVE THROUGH.
AND AS SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN
[inaudible]
HIGHLY FRUSTRATED [inaudible]
AT I'VE READ TWELVE BILLS IN THE
SIX YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE
ADDRESSING.
ALL THAT MOVING PIECES THAT YOU
HAVE TO GET THROUGH TO GET TO
SOMEPLACE TO DO.
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
AS WITH A HEAVY HEART.
WE TALKED BICU WE LOST ANOTHER
ONE TODAY HOW WE'RE GONNA LOSE
LIVES RELEASE PROPERTY.
BUT WE WILL WORRY ABOUT A BUG
[inaudible]
OR A RED LEGGED FROG.
OR ARE YOU NAME IT.
AND ANY TIES AND IF YOU GO OUT
LOOK ON THE GROUND I HAVE PHOTOS
OF THEM.
DESTROYED THE HABITAT GONE
THEY'RE DEAD.
WERE BREATHING CARBON WE'RE
TRYING TO SEQUESTER.
AT THE PACE AND SCALE THAT WE
NEED TO MOVE TO GET OUR FOR
VEGETATION WHETHER IT'S IN.
GREAT SENATORS DISTRICT OR ITS
AND THE VALLEY OR FITS IN.
THE FOOT HILLS AND FOREST.
WHAT IS THE SOLUTION WHAT IS THE
SOLUTION TO GETTING US TO A
PROGRAM?
TYPE THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT
FIVE YEARS.
THROUGH THE COURT SYSTEM.
DELIVER SOMETHING AS LEGISLATORS
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
THAT TAKES CARE OF THE FUEL
LOADING PROBLEMS OUT THERE.
WELL THE SIMPLE ANSWER IS THAT
THE IT'S NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE
PROTECTION OF SENSITIVE SPECIES
AND HABITAT AND INCREASING OUR
PACE AND SCALE OF FUELS
TREATMENT AND FORCE MANAGEMENT.
BUT IT CAN IT CAN ALL BE DONE --
IT'S A MATTER OF BRINGING
EVERYBODY TOGETHER PROJECTS THAT
JIM BRANHAM TALKED ABOUT HERE IN
THE CENTRAL SIERRA TAHOE
INITIATIVE THEY'RE ALL AT THE
TABLE AND WE'RE TALKING.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF ACRES
READY AND PARTNERS WE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING JUST THIS
YEAR FROM JUST THE STATE WITH
MATCHED FUNDING FROM OTHER
PARTNERS THOSE OF THE PROJECTS
WE NEED TO DO RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT THE STAKEHOLDERS A
TABLE.
WE JUST WE NEED TO GET.
THE CHAINSAWS WE GET FOLKS ON
THE GROUND AND START TO WORK AND
IN MANY CASES ENVIRONMENTAL.
REVIEW WAS READY TO GO WE NEED
TO FIND THOSE PROJECTS.
HIGHEST PRIORITIES AND AND AND
START THE WORK RIGHT NOW AND
BUILD THAT MOMENTUM SO WE CAN
TRULY GET TO THESE GOALS.
EVERY SINGLE BILL THAT I
PROPOSED WAS.
OPPOSED BY NOW NAY IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS BECAUSE IT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME IF
YOU KNOW IT'S GOING TO BURN WE
TALK ABOUT.
IN THE FORCED THE SIZE OF A TREE
YOU CAN HARVEST.
AND SOME OF THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
HAVE SOME VALUE IN THEM.
IF YOU HAVE A FORCED OF OLD
GROWTH TREES.
NICE TO SAY THEY'RE ALL FIFTY
INCHES IN DIAMETER AND THE
CANOPIES.
THEY'RE SO CLOSE TO EACH OF THAT
THERE'D THERE'D.
DO YOU THEY WILL CROWN OUT AND
BURN. TO THE GROUND.
AND THEIR OLD GROWTH TREES OR
WHAT WE CAN SEVERAL GROWTH IF
YOU REMOVE SOME OF THOSE.
AND YOU ACTUALLY HAVE AN OPEN
CANOPY WHERE THE FIRE COMES THAT
FLOOR.
AND WE HAVE PHOTOS IN ALL KINDS
OF INFORMATION THE SHOWS THAT
WHEN THAT WHEN YOU DO ACTUALLY
OF THIN THAT OUT.
THAT THOSE TREES ARE STILL ALIVE
WHEN YOU DON'T SEQUESTER CARBON.
HOW CAN WE GET THROUGH A PROCESS
WHEN WE ACTUALLY START TALKING
ABOUT?
THE CANOPY ON THE GROUND OR THE
VEGETATION ON THE GROUND THAT'S
MANAGEABLE FOR FIREFIGHTERS TO
GET INTO SAFELY RESTORE
WATERSHEDS AND GET TO OF A
PERMITTING PROCESS WE DON'T GET.
SUIT AND LOBBIED AND SCORE CARDS
AND ALL THOSE THINGS OUT THERE
THAT ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING GOOD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
EXPERTS SCIENTISTS INCLUDING
DOCTOR DOCTOR STEVENS THAT DR
MALCOLM NORTH DOCTOR JOHN
BATTLES ALL AGREE. FOR THEY HAVE
THE DOCUMENTATION THEY HAVE THE
SCIENCE TO INDICATE WHAT THE
RIGHTS TO THAT FUNDING LEVELS
ARE WHAT THE NUMBER OF TREES PER
ACRE BASED ON THE LOCATION.
THE SCIENCES ALL THERE NOW WE
JUST HAVE TO GO OUT ON THE
GROUND TO PUT IT TO WORK.
AND IF I COULD JUST ADD ONE
THING MISTER ALI --
AS WE'VE BEGUN BRING FOLKS
TOGETHER INCIDENT IN AND TRY TO
WORK THROUGH WHAT THE SCIENCE IS
TELLING US WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
THIS YEAR AT LEAST WE HAVE A LOT
OF ENVIRONMENT GROUPS THAT ARE
ACTIVELY INVOLVED.
IN HELPING US FIGURE IT OUT AND
THEY'RE NOT PURSUING LITIGATION
AS THEIR STRATEGY NOT EVERYONE'S
A BOARD OF THAT PROBABLY NEVER
WILL BE BUT I THINK THAT THE
CHIEF'S POINT.
USE THE SCIENCE ME BY GUIDED BY
THE SCIENCE AND IT'S TELLING US
THAT WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
VERY DIFFERENT THERE'S A LOT OF
OF REALLY GOOD INVOLVEMENT FROM.
THE ENVIRONMENT COMMITTEE ON
THAT AND I THINK.
IF IT'S A TESTAMENT TO THE TO
SIT DOWN AND FIGURE IT OUT
TOGETHER.
NOT BEING SATISFIED WITH
OUTCOMES THAT YOU DESCRIBED WHAT
HAPPENED.
MAYBE WE'LL HAVE A NEW NORMAL IN
THE LEGISLATURE LUCY.
I WANT TO THANK ALL THREE OF YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THIS BRANHAM THAT
MISTER SECRETARY.
HE HAD --
CHIEF UP I THINK.
NOT ON THIS IS MORE THE
PREVENTION THE CLEARING SIDE NOT
THE SUPPRESSION SIDE.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
CALL YOU OUT AT ALL OF THE WOMEN
IN MEN.
IN YOUR OPERATION AND ALL THE
MUTUAL AID --
BECOMES TO HELP --
CAO FIRE ON ALL THESE FIRES
THROUGHOUT THE STATES WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
CO CHAIR.
I WILL NOW CALL FORWARD THE
FINAL PANEL OF THE DAY THIS
WOULD BE DEALING WITH WOOD
PRODUCTS MARKETS.
AND BIOMASS POLICY --
WILL CALL FOR RICH GORDON
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION [inaudible]
JONATHAN KOZOL.
EXECUTIVE RECTOR SIERRA
INSTITUTE FOR COMMUNITY AND
ENVIRONMENT.
EDWARD RANDOLPH DIRECTOR CPUC
ENERGY DIVISION.
AND CATHERINE PHILLIPS SIERRA
CLUB.
CATHERINE IS NOT HERE SO.
TELL ME YOUR NAME.
I HAD WOULD MORENO UP THIS YEAR
COULD CALIFORNIA NINE ALONG WITH --
DE NUMBER.
VERY GOOD.
COULD I JUST POINT OUT THAT ALL
THE PANELS WE HAVEN'T HAD A
SINGLE WOMAN [inaudible]
JUST.
TODAY WE HAVEN'T HAD IF I'VE
MISSED SOMETHING.
HE WAS INVITED BUT THE OPTICS
HERE ARE SOMEWHAT STUNNING AND I
JUST WANTED TO POINT THEM OUT.
OKAY RICH TO UNFOLD AND MAKE YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OF THERE ARE MANY FACTORS
RELATED TO THE CATASTROPHIC
FIRES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERIENCING [inaudible]
HISTORIC DROUGHT.
HOTTER TEMPERATURES LOWER
HUMIDITY.
LAND USE DECISIONS.
AND INCREASING URBAN WILDLIFE
INTERFACE.
A LACK OF INVESTMENT IN
PREVENTION.
BUT PERHAPS THE MOST IMPORTANT
FACTOR IS SIMPLY THIS.
THERE IS TOO MUCH FUEL.
CALIFORNIA HAS A VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROBLEM.
OUR GRASSLANDS ARE OVERGROWN.
WE HAVE TOO MUCH CHAPARRAL.
AND OUR FORESTS ARE OVERLY DENSE.
IF WE DO NOTHING ELSE TO PREVENT
FIRES.
WE MUST REDUCE THE FUEL LOAD.
THAT MEANS WE HAVE TO ASSURE
THAT HOMEOWNERS CREATE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
WE HAVE TO INCREASE GRAZING OF
OUR GRASSLANDS.
WE HAVE TO REDUCE CHAPARRAL.
WE HAVE TO REMOVE DEAD TREES AND
THIN OUR FORESTS.
DEALING WITH OUR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROBLEM LEAVES US
WITH THIS DILEMMA.
WHAT DO WE DO WITH THIS MATERIAL?
REMEMBER WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
HIS WAIST.
A HOMEOWNER WHO CREATES
DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
SEIZE THE CUT MATERIAL AS WASTE.
CHAPARRAL REMOVED FROM A
LANDSCAPE IS WASTE.
WHEN THINNING THE FOREST?
ANY TREE WITH VALUE TURNED INTO
LUMBER.
IT'S THE LIMBS [inaudible]
THE BARK [inaudible]
TOPS.
THE VERY SMALL TREES AND
ANYTHING THAT CANNOT BE TURNED
INTO LUMBER [inaudible]
THAT'S WASTE.
WE CALL THIS WASTE BIOMASS.
AND WHAT DO WE DO WITH BIOMASS.
WHAT LANDFILLS CAN'T TAKE THIS
MATERIAL?
AND ONLY SO MUCH OF IT CAN BE
TURNED INTO DECORATIVE CHIPS OR
ANIMAL BEDDING.
THE REST YOU COULD LEAVE TO ROT
ON THE LAND.
BUT IT IS STILL FUEL.
AND WHILE RIDING IT RELEASES
TOXIC POLLUTANTS.
IF YOU HAVE A TIMBER AG
OPERATION YOU CAN BURN IT OPEN
PILE BURNING.
BUT IT THAT ALSO RELEASES CARBON
AND POLLUTANTS [inaudible]
OR YOU CAN TAKE IT TO A BIOMASS
FACILITIES WERE CAN BE TURNED
INTO ENERGY.
NOW YOU'LL HEAR THAT THIS IS NOT
A CLEAN SOLUTION.
BUT STUDIES HAVE DEMONSTRATED
THAT THE EMISSIONS FROM BIOMASS
FACILITIES.
ARE BETTER FOR AIR QUALITY.
WHEN COMPARED TO OTHER OPTIONS?
INCLUDING PILE BURNING.
IT'S CERTAINLY BETTER THAN
WILDFIRE [inaudible]
AND REMEMBER.
THESE FACILITIES OPERATE WITH
PERMITS YOU SHOULD BY LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS.
IN ORDER TO GUARANTEE THAT LOCAL
AIR QUALITY GOALS ARE ACHIEVED.
AND YOU'RE TECHNOLOGIES MAKING
THESE FACILITIES CLEANER ALL THE
TIME.
YOU'LL ALSO HEAR THAT BIOMASS IS
EXPENSIVE ENERGY.
WHEN COMPARED TWO OTHER
RENEWABLE SOURCES THAT HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM SUBSIDIES?
BIOMASS IS NOT THE CHEAPEST
RENEWABLE.
BUT I BELIEVE AT THIS MOMENT.
ANY DISCUSSION OF COST.
MUST INCLUDE THE ANALYSIS OF THE
SOCIAL COST.
IN LOS LIVES [inaudible]
DESTROYED PROPERTY.
AND DEVASTATED LANDSCAPES AND
COMMUNITIES.
THE SOCIAL COST OF NOT REMOVING
EXCESS FUELS. FOR MORE WILD
LANDS AND FORESTS.
PERHAPS WE NEED TO FIND A WAY
SOME WAY TO SUBSIDIZE BIOMASS IS
PART OF OUR FIRE PREVENTION
STRATEGY.
THANKS TO PREVIOUS LEGISLATIVE
ACTION SEVEN BIOMASS PLANTS
PRODUCING UNDER SEVENTY FIVE
MEGAWATTS.
CONTRACTS TO REDUCE POWER.
AND ANOTHER SIXTEEN PLANTS
ONLINE PRODUCING A TOTAL OF FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY MEGAWATTS OF POWER.
SOME OF THESE CONTRACTS WILL
EXPIRE IN THREE SHORT YEARS.
THERE'S LOW HANGING FRUIT.
THE LEGISLATURE COULD WORK TO
GUARANTEE THE EXTENSION THE A
CONTRACTS FOR ALL OF THESE
FACILITIES.
SO THESE PLANTS REMAIN
OPERATIONAL FOR A LONGER TERM OF
TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS.
THE COST OF THESE CURRENT
FACILITIES IS INCLUDED IN
EXISTING RATES.
SO THIS WOULD NOT TO INCREASE
THE COST FOR ANY RATE PAYER.
SPECIFIC ACTION COULD ALSO BE
TAKEN TO MAKE THESE CONTRACTS
MORE EFFICIENT.
BY ALLOWING FACILITIES TO TAKE
MATERIAL FROM A BROADER RANGE OF
HAZARD ZONES.
THEY'RE ALSO SHUDDERED BIOMASS
FACILITIES.
BUT WE BROUGHT BACK ON LINE IN
NINETY DAYS OR LESS WITH AN
EXPANSION BIOMASS PROCUREMENT.
AND PERHAPS THIS SHOULD ALSO BE
CONSIDERED.
YOU WILL HEAR FROM SOME THAT
THERE ARE OTHER USES FOR THE
BIOMASS MATERIAL.
THINGS LIKE NEW WOOD PRODUCTS OR
CROSS LAMINATED TIMBER.
EVENTUALLY THAT MAY BE TRUE.
BUT WE ARE STILL AT THE DAWN OF
THAT TECHNOLOGY [inaudible]
CHAPARRAL.
AND WILDLAND FUELS.
WE'LL NEVER BE CANDIDATES FOR
NEW WOOD PRODUCTS. FOR THE
IMMEDIATE FUTURE.
WE NEED TO TURN OUR EXCESS FUELS
INTO ENERGY.
I WOULD REMIND YOU.
IT TWO DAYS OF THE WINE COUNTRY
FIRES AND SENATOR DODD'S
DISTRICT.
RELEASED IN AMOUNT OF GREENHOUSE
GASES.
EQUAL TO A FULL YEAR OF VEHICLE
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
IF WE ARE TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS.
IF WE ARE TO PROTECT LIVES AND
PROPERTY.
AND IF WE ARE TO MAINTAIN OUR
AND FIRE MIDDLE VALUES.
WE MUST HAVE A STRONG VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
SIMPLY PUT.
ANY APPROACH TO CALIFORNIA'S
WELFARE PROBLEMS MUST INCLUDE.
A FUELS REDUCTION COMPONENT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
SAVE INEXPERIENCED JUSTIN THE
ORDER THAT YOU RECALL.
COUPLE WELL WITH HIM ON BOB.
GOT GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND SENATORS I'M
EVERGRANDE OFF THAT DIRECTOR OF
THE ENERGY DIVISION AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
ON THE CPU SEES RESPONDED
AGGRESSIVELY TO THE TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN GOVERNOR STRING
MORTALITY EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THE RESPONSE THAT ORDER --
AND IN RESPONSE TO S. B. I THREE
FIFTY NINE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THE CPC IS INSTRUCTED
THE THREE LARGE --
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA I'D TO PROCURE MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
MEGAWATTS OF BIOMASS FOR
FACILITIES THAT ARE COMMITTED TO
BURNING FUEL FROM HIGH HAZARD
ZONES.
ON AS HAS BEEN DETERMINED BY
CALVET.
OFFER POINT OF REFERENCE --
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED AND I THIRTY MEGA WATTS
OF BIOMASS FIT FACILITY
STATEWIDE --
UNDER CONTRACT WHICH NOW
REPRESENTS ABOUT TWO POINT 4% OF
TOTAL ELECTRIC SYSTEM DEMANDED.
THE BIOMASS OF PROCUREMENT --
FOCUSED --
THE BIO BASTROP PROCUREMENT
FOCUS IN FORCE MANAGEMENT
HAPPENS UNDER THREE DIFFERENT
PROGRAM TYPES.
I THOUGHT THE FIRST UNDER CP YOU
SEE DIRECTIONS IMMEDIATELY AFTER
THE GOVERNOR'S SIDE EXECUTIVE
ORDER -- YA
USE NEGOTIATED INDIVIDUAL
CONTRACTS WITH SOME EXISTING MY
BIO PLANTS ARE THEY WERE UNDER
CONTRACT BUT WE'RE NO LONGER
OPERATE NOW PROFITABLY DUE TO
CHANGING PRICING.
TO ON SOME OF THOSE CONTRACTS
THAT WE CAN TALK ABOUT --
LATER HAD SOME UNIQUE FEATURES --
FOCUSED ON I'M HELPING THE
UTILITIES ARE MANAGE YOUR OWN
FUEL ON IN REDUCING THE OVERALL
COST OF GETTING THE FUEL OF THE
FORCED.
ON THE SECOND PROGRAM I WAS
UNDER THE BIO RAM PROGRAM AYE
THE BIO RAM PROGRAM IS A
RENEWABLE AUCTION --
WHERE UTILITY PUTS OUT A I
REQUEST FOR OFFERS AYE AND
FACILITIES CAN BID INTO THAT THE
UTILITY THEN TAKES THE LOWEST
TARGET OF THAT PROGRAM --
WE CONDUCTED ONE PROGRAM AND
MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN OR
THE UTILITIES DEAD ON AND THEN
AFTER S. B. EIGHT FIFTY NINE
PASSED ON ORDERING MORE
PROCUREMENT THERE WAS A SECOND --
PROCUREMENT IN LATE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN ARMORED UNDER THOSE TWO
PROCUREMENTS THERE WERE AYE
TOTAL ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
MEGA WATTS --
BIOMASS APPEARED UNDER ON
THURSDAY PROCUREMENTS AYE THIRD --
IS A PROGRAM WHERE IT'S CALLED
BIO MAT --
THE BIO MAT PROGRAM IS HAS A LOT
MORE COMPLICATED PRICING
STRUCTURE --
THAT IS TARGETED TOWARDS VERY
SMALL FACILITIES IT USED TO BE
THREE MEGAWATTS FACILITIES IT'S
NOW UP THE FIVE MEGAWATT
FACILITIES --
IT'S A MECHANISM WHERE IT STARTS
AT A SET PRICE AND THE PRICE
WILL GO UP OR DOWN DEPENDING
UPON HOW MANY MARKET
PARTICIPANTS THERE ARE.
IN AN EFFORT TO FIND ON THE
PRICE THAT THE MARKET
PARTICIPANTS NEED TO BE
PROFITABLE --
I'M UNDER THAT PROGRAM ON THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON THE OTHER
LEGISLATION REQUIRED TO DO YOU
SEE TO MAKE SOME PROGRAM CHANGES
TO I'M STREAMLINED THAT --
THAT P. YOU SEE I DID IMPLEMENT
THAT THE THE ONE MAIN CHANGE WAS
TO MOVE THE ELIGIBLE SIDES FROM
A THREE MEGAWATTS. TO FIVE
MEGAWATT FACILITY --
THERE ALSO CHANGES DONE TO AYE
THE INTERCONNECTION PROCESS I'D
TO HELP MAKE THE IN THEIR
CONNECTION PROCESS FOR THE
SMALLER FACILITIES.
I HAD --
HOPEFULLY HAPPEN QUICKER BOB
BETTER INTERACT WITH THE PROGRAM
RULES AND AND I CHALLENGES STILL
EXIST IS TO REDUCE THE INTERCOM
INTERCONNECTION COSTS --
ON THESE PROGRAMS I'M HAVE SOME
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
I DO MEET THE GOALS OF REDUCE
REDUCING THE FORCE FIELDS.
ARE THE BIO RAM FACILITIES HAVE
A REQUIREMENT TO USE AT LEAST
60% OF THEIR FUEL FROM HIGH
HAZARD ZONES --
IN -- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IN 80% OF THE
FUEL -- IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND BEYOND
AND THEN FOR POINT OF REFERENCE
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
FACILITIES AVERAGE 55% OF THE
FUEL FROM THE HIGH HAZARD ZONE.
I THESE TARGETS WERE SET IN
STATUTE AND BY THE P. YOU SEE --
TO MAKE SURE THESE FACILITIES
ARE HELPING WITH THE FORCE
MANAGEMENT CHALLENGE THE
PHILLIES THE FACILITIES ARE PAID
A PREMIUM IF THEY CAN MEET THOSE
TARGETS.
OFFER THE FACILITIES UNDER THE
BY A RAMP PROGRAM IF THEY MEET
THOSE TARGETS EITHER PAID ON
AVERAGE A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MEGAWATTS A HUNDRED FIFTEEN
DOLLARS --
IF ON SOME OF THOSE FACILITIES
DEPEND UPON WHICH PROGRAM THEY
PARTICIPATED UNDER THEM IF THEY
CAN'T MAKE THOSE TARGETS THEY
CAN STILL SELL THEIR ENERGY AND
EIGHTY NINE DOLLARS PER MEGAWATT
HOUR.
ON SOME OF THOSE CONTRACTS HAVE
PROVISIONS OF THE CONTRACT WOULD
BE TERMINATED IF THEY CAN'T MAKE
THE PROVISIONS.
BOB FOR COMPARISON SAKE A
SIMILARLY SIZED SOLAR WIND
CONTRACT --
THAT WOULD PARTICIPATE IN
SIMILAR PROGRAM TODAY --
THE UTILITY COULD SIGN A
CONTRACT FOR THEM FOR LESS THAN
FIFTY DOLLARS A MEGAWATT SO
ROUGHLY -- A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN HALF AS
MUCH -- THE
PRICING MECHANISMS FOR THE
SMALLER PROJECTS UNDER THE BIO
MAT PROGRAM AS I'VE EXPLAINED
IT'S DIFFERENT --
IN IT'S AN ADJUSTING MECHANISM
ARE RIGHT NOW THREE PROJECTS
HAVE -- HAVE
EXECUTED CONTRACTS ARE THOSE A
BELIEVER A LITTLE OVER AHUNDRED
AND NINETY DOLLARS PER MEGAWATT
HOUR.
ON IN THE THE PROJECT PRICE
RIGHT NOW IS I JUST SHORT OF TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MEGAWATT HOUR
FOR THOSE PRO.
I'M LAST DECEMBER --
THE P. C. DID CAP PRICES ON THE
OVER ALL BIOMET PROGRAM THAT
PROGRAM WAS CREATED BEFORE --
THE THE EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
BECAUSE IT HAD HIT A A
PREDETERMINED PRICE CAP THAT
REQUIRED ON A STALL OF THE
PROGRAM --
WHILE THE P. C. --
EXAMINE THE PROGRAM TO SEE IF
REFORMS COULD BE MADE --
I TO MAKE IT MORE EFFICIENT
HOWEVER UNDER THAT ORDER WE ALSO
ALLOWED --
FACILITIES THAT DO YOU HAVE A
COMPLETE YOU TAKING FUEL FROM
HIGH HAZARD AREAS --
TO CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PRICE FOR THOSE FACILITIES
COULD CONTINUE TO RATCHET UP --
WHILE THE BIOMASS FACILITIES ARE
MEETING THEIR TARGETS TODAY --
BASED ON STATEMENTS FROM THE
REPRESENTATIVES ON AND SOME
ESTIMATES THAT HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTED BY --
I THINK BOTH ON CAL FIRE IN THE
NATIONAL FOREST SERVICE ON WE
SEE A NUMBER CHALLENGES IN A
MEETING THIS TARGETS IN BEING
ABLE TO GET THE FUEL TO THE
BIOMASS FACILITIES.
ON OVER THE NEXT YEARS AND OVER
THE LONG TERM ON SOME OF THOSE --
CHALLENGING A BIDDING KNOWLEDGES
ARE ON I'D THIS AND BY NO MEANS
A COMPREHENSIVE LIST BUT
COMPETITION FOR LIMITED AMOUNT
OF AVAILABLE HIGH HAZARD WOULD
OUT THERE.
ON EVEN THOUGH THERE'S A LOT OF
ON DIDN'T DYING TREES OUT THERE
THE AMOUNT OF WOOD THAT'S
ACTUALLY ACCESSIBLE CAN BE
TRUCKED IN THESE FACILITIES IS
STILL SOMEWHAT LIMITED.
ON CHALLENGES AND FINDING A
CONSISTENT SUPPLY OF HIGH HAZARD
WOULD --
ONLY BEING ABLE TO REMOVE THE
TREES IN SPRING AND SUMMER --
YOUNG SO IF THERE FUEL AND IT'S
ONLY AND LOG ON TO REMOVE INSERT.
YEAR A THE PLANTS HAVE TO FIND
OTHER FUEL SOURCES OTHER TIMES
OF THE YEAR --
LACK OF ROAD INFRASTRUCTURE TO
GET SAID SOME OF THE IMPACT
AREAS LACK OF SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES SUCH AS TRUCKS TO MOVE
THEM TO THE BIOMASS FACILITIES --
AND THEN IF THE TREE REMOVAL IS
INCREASED --
OVER THE LEVELS IT'S NOW A LACK
OF SUFFICIENT STORAGE SPACE FOR
THE TO STORE THE WOOD WHILE
TRYING OUT BEFORE CAN BE USED
FOR BIOENERGY.
ANOTHER CHALLENGE FACING MISTER
IN THE YOU CAN YOU START TO
BRING YOUR PRESENTATION DR JUST
CLOSING UP RIGHT NOW --
GIVEN THAT THESE CHALLENGES --
GIVEN THESE CHALLENGES --
THERE ARE --
CONCERNS IT'S SIMPLY INCREASING
TARGETS ARE MANDATES FOR BIOMASS
PLANTS WILL NOT ACTUALLY HELP
REMOVE THE FUEL FOR THE FORCE --
CALIFORNIA RATEPAYERS INSTEAD OF
RD PAIN A PREMIUM FOR THE
BIOMASS PROJECTS COMPARED TO
OTHER RENEWABLE RESOURCES AND
THIS PREMIUM MAY ACTUALLY BE
JUSTIFIED GIVEN THE SOCIETAL
COST --
INVOLVED HERE --
BUT IF THEY ARE PLAYING THE
PREMIUM WE DO NEED TO MAKE SURE --
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY MEETING
THOSE GOALS ALL SORTS.
ON IN SO ITIT SEEMS A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH IS NEEDED --
BEYOND JUST DIRECTING UTILITIES --
TO TO PROCURE MORE RESOURCES AND
WITHOUT OFFICE.
THANK YOU --
BECAUSE OF PURCHASE HOLDEN AND
DIED AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY.
MY NAME IS JOHN I THINK YOU SAW
AND I DIRECT TO SEE OUR
INSTITUTE FOR COMMUNITY AND
ENVIRONMENT.
AYE WE'VE BEEN IN OPERATION
SINCE ABOUT NINETEEN NINETY
THREE WERE A NONPROFIT.
ORGANIZATION.
AND WE WORK WITH GROUPS ALL OVER
THE STATE --
SOME OF THE COLLABORATIVE GROUPS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT AND
TRYING TO ADDRESS.
A LARGE LANDSCAPE SOME UPWARDS
OF A MILLION ACRES --
AND THAT'S NOT THE NATURE OF MY
DISCUSSION HERE TODAY BUT IT IS
CRITICAL IN DEALING WITH SOME OF
THESE LARGE LANDSCAPE ISSUES --
WE ALSO HAVE --
PAYROLL THIS SUMMER MANY OF WHOM
ARE -- HIGH
SCHOOL KIDS FROM URBAN AREAS AND
URBAN AIR OUT RURAL AREAS WERE
BRINGING THEM TOGETHER TO DO
RESTORATION WORK IN OUR FORESTS
A LOT OF THAT WORK IS TAKING
PLACE IN.
THE STATE WATERSHED CRITICAL SO
OF THE UPPER FEATHER RIVER --
THEY'RE DOING SOME AMAZING
THINGS UP THERE --
A FEW YEARS AGO TO SERIOUS TO
PROCEED TO TWO POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLAR GRANT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION TO BUILD A
BIOMASS POWER COGENERATION
FACILITY TO PROVIDE HEAT AND
POWER.
PLUMAS COUNTIES NORTHERN PLUMAS
COUNTY HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
BUILDING --
A SECOND BIOMASS BOILERS BEING
DEVELOPED FOR A LOCAL HIGH
SCHOOL ANOTHER BY A MASS BOILERS
BEING CONSIDERED FOR A LOCAL
JAIL.
THEY DON'T USE A LOT BUT THEY
USE MATERIAL IN THEY BURNED IN
ANY IN A CONFINED SPACE AND AS
ALREADY MENTIONED.
IT IS A CLEAN WAY OF UTILIZING
THIS MATERIAL --
ON TOP OF THAT WE BUILT THIS IS
NOT MY SUITCASE THIS IS CROSSED
LAMINATED TIMBER.
ARE ALSO MORE GENERICALLY KNOWN
AS MASS TIMBER WE BUILT THE
FIRST FULL.
ACROSS LIMITED TIMBER STRUCTURE
IN CALIFORNIA AND IT HOUSES ONE
OF THE BIOMASS SPOILERS FOR THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
BUILDING THIS WAS COMPLETED WITH
A RIBBON CUTTING CEREMONY IN
APRIL OF THIS YEAR --
AND THAT JUST CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT CONTRIBUTED OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE LOCAL
ECONOMY.
SMALL BUT SIGNIFICANT.
UP THIS MORNING I SPENT THREE
THREE AND A HALF HOURS IN
JACKSON I'M A SOCIAL SCIENTIST
BY TRAINING.
A LETTER WORKSHOP TALKING ABOUT
COMMUNITY CAPACITY COMMUNITY
HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
AND THE CONVERSATION WAS
FASCINATING BECAUSE THIS IS THE
SAME AREA WHERE. THREE YEARS AGO
THE BUTTE FIRE BURNED.
SCARS REMAIN AND I MEAN NOT JUST
ON THE LANDSCAPE THE SCARS
REMAIN FOR THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY THE ANGUISH THE
ECONOMIC.
AYE DEVASTATION EXIST STILL
TODAY IT WAS PART OF THE
DISCUSSION THIS MORNING --
MY BACKYARD IS A MENTION PLUMAS
COUNTY NORTHERN SIERRA --
THE MOONLIGHT FIRE BURNED THERE
JUST ABOUT ELEVEN YEARS AGO I
THOUGHT THAT FIRE IS A VOLUNTEER
FIREFIGHTER SCARED THE HECK OUT
OF ME OUT THERE AS I WAS DRIVING
A TANKER TRUCK --
PROVIDING WATER FOR SOME OF THE
FRONTLINE ENGINES AND I REMEMBER
THEM FROM BEING ST BERNARD DO
YOU KNOW.
ARIZONA AND ELSEWHERE
[inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY THAT FIRE WAS
CONSIDERED SMALL BY TODAY'S
STANDARDS ON HUNDRED SQUARE
MILES.
BUT WHAT WAS UNIQUE TO THAT FIRE
WAS THAT IT WAS A HIGH SEVERITY
BURNED RELATIVE TO SOME OF THE
AREAS OVER 60% OF THAT LANDSCAPE
HAD A HIGH SEVERITY BURN.
THE IMPLICATIONS AT THE RIM FIRE
BY THE WAY WAS 40% IN CONTRAST.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED SINCE
THEN SO ELEVEN YEARS AGO
[inaudible]
WITH DROUGHT WITH CLIMATE CHANGE --
WE NOW HAVE WE BEEN LOOKING AT A
BROWN LANDSCAPE FOR A LONG TIME.
BUT WHAT WE'VE ALSO LEARNED IS
WHAT WAS OLD FOREST. 40% 44% OLD
FORCES NOW SHRUBLAND.
WE WILL NOT SEE FOR US BACK
THERE NOT IN MY LIFETIME NO
MATTER WHAT WE DO --
I WANT TO SPEAK VERY BRIEFLY.
AND SPECIFICALLY ABOUT AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER AGRIC CURRY WHICH IS --
THE BILL CALLING.
FOR INNOVATIVE FOREST PRODUCTS --
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN CALLS FOR
ADVANCING --
ON MASK MASK TIMBER.
CONSTRUCTION IN SOME LOCATIONS --
IT CALLS FOR SOME OTHER
FACILITIES AND THESE ARE
IMPORTANT IT IS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO UTILIZE.
NOT JUST BIOMASS MORE MATERIAL
BUT YOU'LL NOTICE THAT THERE IS
SMALL MATERIAL THAT'S A PART OF
THIS.
SO IT CAN BE USED IN A PRODUCT
THAT IS QUITE VALUABLE.
WE BY THE WAY IN BUILDING THE
BUILDING FOR THE BOILER SPENT
ALL OF TWO DAYS INSTRUCTING.
AND THAT'S THE VALUE IN TERMS OF
REDUCE LABOR AND THIS BY THE WAY
IS A BIG PIECE OF CARBON.
COMPARE --
TO STEEL --
A TIME.
OF THIS MATERIAL COMPARED TO
STEAL.
STEEL AMIDST TWENTY TIMES TWENTY
ONE TIMES THE CARBON IN ITS
MANUFACTURE CEMENT [inaudible]
EIGHT TIMES THE CARBON SO THAT
DOESN'T EVEN COUNT THE CARBON
DICK REGROWS ON THE LANDSCAPE.
AS THE FOREST AS WHAT WAS TAKEN
OUT IN THE FOREST RECOVERS THERE
SO WE HAVE CARBON.
ADDED ON THE LANDSCAPE.
UMP THE IMPORTANCE AS I WRAP UP.
CALIFORNIA'S LAGGING IN THIS IT
UNDERSCORES THE IMPORTANCE OF AB
[inaudible]
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN OR AGAIN.
PUT IN PLACE THE ICC THE
INTERNATIONAL CODE COUNCIL
STANDARDS IF THEY'RE GOING TO BE
VOTING ON THIS FALL.
THEY ALREADY PUT IN PLACE BEFORE
THAT VOTE TOOK PLACE WASHINGTON
BILL FIVE MASS TIMBER SKILL OUR
SCHOOLS.
RIGHT AWAY THEY'VE DECIDED TO DO
THAT ALABAMA MAIN ILLINOIS.
BROUGHT IN CROSS LAMINATED
TIMBER FACILITIES VERY RECENTLY.
WE CAN'T DO BETTER WE GOT THIS
MATERIAL WE HAD TO GET FROM
CANADA. FOR THE BUILDING THAT WE
CONSTRUCTED [inaudible]
SO LASTLY.
WHAT ELSE DO WE NEED TO DO?
I WANT TO MENTION ONE THING IS A
SOCIAL SCIENTIST WE TALK ABOUT
LANDSCAPE NEEDS.
AND THERE ARE MANY.
BUT TO BE EFFECTIVE DOING THE
WORK ON THE LANDSCAPE WE ALSO
HAVE TO HAVE PLACES TO BRING
THAT MATERIAL.
TO WE HAVE TO REBUILD SOME OF
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE
LOST OVER THE YEARS THAT'S A
CRITICAL DIMENSION.
OF THE PROBLEM WE FACE AS A
STATE SO AGAIN THE LANDSCAPE
ISSUES ARE ABSOLUTELY REAL WE
KNOW THEM FIRSTHAND BUT TO DEAL
WITH THAT.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE FACILITIES THAT WILL
UTILIZE THIS MATERIAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AND IF NEW CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
THE PERSON I'M NOT CATHOLIC
PHILIP SHAREDA PERSONAL MATTER
TO TEND --
TO BUT DANIEL AND I WAS FEELING
IT -- WILL
BE FILLING IN FOR HER --
AGAIN -- I'M
ANY MORENO --
WITH URKEL CALIFORNIA THAT WE
HAVE AN ACTIVE THAT CAMPAIGN TO
THWART EFFORTS BY THE BY MASS
INDUSTRY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
CLIMATE IMPACTS IN ORDER TO
JUSTIFY --
EXPAND THE POLLUTING INDUSTRY
AGAIN WITH ME IS DANA VARADA
LEAD ORGANIZER ON THE CAMPAIGN.
WILL NOW PROVIDE TESTIMONY ABOUT
WHY BY MASS INCINERATION IS NOT
A SOLUTION TO TREAT MORTALITY
WILDFIRES WERE ENERGY NEED.
PICK DOT ORG THANK GOD THANK YOU
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY.
I WANT TO BE BEGAN BY SAYING
THAT I FEEL DEEPLY FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO WERE EVACUATED
OR WORSE YOU HAVE LOST HOMES AND
NOT ONCE.
I GREW UP IN COLORADO AND WAS
EVACUATED FOR THE WHILE THOUGH
CANYON FIRE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT NOTHING
IS MORE HORRIFYING THAN DRIVING
AWAY FROM HER HOME.
NOT KNOWING WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IT AGAIN.
BUT A VISCERAL FEAR FIRE HOWEVER
JUSTIFIED CANNOT KEEP US FROM
HAVING A ROBUST INFORMED
DISCUSSION ABOUT FIRE FIRE
MANAGEMENT AND BIOMASS
UTILIZATION.
THERE ARE A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
MILLION DEAD TREES AND
CALIFORNIA'S FOREST.
HOWEVER NOT ALL A HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE MILLION TREES SHUT OR EVEN
CAN BE REMOVED WE HEARD FROM THE
CPUC.
ABOUT HOW.
VERY FEW OF THESE TREES ARE
ACTUALLY ACCESSIBLE.
MANY OF THESE TREES ARE IN
REMOTE AREAS AND ACCESSING THAT
WOULD BE PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE
AN ECOLOGICALLY DESTRUCTIVE.
ACCORDING TO A REVIEW OF THE
LITERATURE BY YOU SEE BY THE UC
EXTENSION TO THE MENDOCINO FIRE
SAFE COUNCIL IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN FIRE
PATHWAYS ARE NOT DRIVEN BY TREE
MORTALITY NOR IS TO IMMORTALITY
AT THE HEART OF FIRE ACTIVITY IN
THE WEST.
ALL THAT SAID THERE ARE DEAD
TREES THAT ARE IN DANGER FALLING
ON HOMES POWERLINES ROADS AND
OTHER IMPORTANT INFRASTRUCTURE
AS WELL AS TREES THAT NEED TO BE
REMOVED FOR DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
THESE TREES ARE TRULY HAZARDOUS
AND MUST BE REMOVED THE QUESTION
BECOMES WHAT DO WE DO WITH THESE
TREES AND ALSO WHAT SHOULD WE
NOT DO WITH THEM.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT USE HATTER
HAZARDOUS TREES TO PROP UP A
POLLUTING AND NON ECONOMIC
BIOMASS INCINERATION INDUSTRY.
ON AVERAGE BIOMASS AND SAID
FACILITIES AND IT. THREE TIMES
MORE CO TWO PER MEGAWATT THE
NATURAL GAS AND ONE AND A HALF
TIMES MORE THAN EVEN CALL.
BIOMASS INCINERATORS FOR LEASE
FINE PARTICULATES AND KNOCKS IN
HIGH CONCENTRATIONS.
BOTH OF WHICH ARE LINKED. TO
HEART AND LUNG CONDITIONS.
MANY OF THESE FACILITIES
INCLUDING ONE THAT IS CURRENTLY
DO BURNING DEAD FOREST TREES ON
AT BIO RAM CONTRACT.
ARE LOCATED IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
FROM SCHOOLS AND NEIGHBORHOODS
AND THESE FACILITIES ARE BURNING
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD THINK OF
BIOMASS UTILIZATION AS A
HIERARCHY OF THE HIGHEST AND
BEST USE FOR TREES.
WHEN POSSIBLE A TREE CAN REMAIN
A TREE EVEN SOME DEAD TREES
PROVIDE INNUMERABLE ECOLOGICAL
BENEFITS AND SEQUESTER CARBON?
THEN WE SHOULD PRIORITIZE
UTILIZATION THAT SEQUESTERS
CARBON.
BURNING TREES AND POWER PLANTS
NEXT TO SCHOOLS AND IN
NEIGHBORHOODS SHOULD NOT BE OUR
SHOULD BE OUR VERY LAST CHOICE
FOR BIOMASS UTILIZATION.
NOT THE FIRST.
WE MUST PRIORITIZE RESEARCH AND
WE CANNOT KEEP INCINERATORS
ONLINE AND SIMPLY SAYING THEY'RE
SAYING THERE'S TOO MUCH WASTE.
TO DEAL WITH.
WE NEED EXTENSIVE RESEARCH INTO
HOW MUCH WASTE THERE ACTUALLY IS
IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND THEN WHEN POSSIBLE AND
PERMITTING COMMUNITY SCALE.
BIOMASS UTILIZATION EFFORTS THAT
ARE GOING TO THAT SEQUESTER AS
MUCH CARBON AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU --
WILL.
I THINK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS ALL TURNED --
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
STIR CALLING.
SO I LIKE TO ASK YOU WHAT.
THE FROM SIERRA CLUB WHAT WHAT
WOULD YOU SUGGEST I TELL MY
CONSTITUENTS HER BREATHE IN
SMOKE EVERYDAY RIGHT NOW.
WHAT IS THE SOLUTION IF WE DON'T
WANNA?
THEN ARE WE DON'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING WHO'S OR WALK AWAY FROM
THE WHAT IS WHAT IS A AS I ONCE
WAS A TOWN JUST GET THIS IS THE
NEW NORMAN.
WE WE'VE SEQUESTERED FIRE FOR A
HUNDRED YEARS THAT'S NOT NORMAL.
FIRE NOW ACTUALLY BURNED EVERY
TEN TO TWELVE YEARS THE
SCIENTISTS IS SITTING IN THE
AUDIENCE WILL TELL YOU THAT.
I'M NOT A SCIENTIST I BELIEVE
THEIR RESEARCH BUT WE HAVE
HISTORY THAT TREE MARKINGS SAY.
FORCED BURNED EVERY TEN TO
TWELVE YEARS WE STOP THAT MAN
STOP THAT PROCESS.
KIM PIMLOTT SPENT.
THREE ALMOST THREE BILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR FIGHTING FIRES
TO STOP THAT PROCESS WHAT IS THE
SOLUTION.
FIRST OF ALL I ON ONE AT BEGAN
BY SAYING --
THAT.
IT IS IMPORTANT. TO TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES AND PROTECT TOWNS
AND THAT'S WHY WE WANT.
WOULD LIKE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PRIORITIZE DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND
PRIORITIZE HARDENING OF HOMES
[inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY.
I'M WHILE.
IT IS A JARRING TO SEE ALL THE
SMOKE AND I'M SURE IT'S STRONG
FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
WHERE THERE ARE SIX BIOMASS
FACILITIES CURRENTLY OPERATING.
THEY HAVE THAT KIND OF AIR
QUALITY EVERYDAY.
AND THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DAYS A YEAR.
AND IF WE CONTINUE [inaudible]
BURNING --
TAKING THE WASTE FROM THE
SIERRAS AND BURNING IT DOWN ON
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND I'M NOT
THINK THAT'S VERY FAIR TO THAT
ON CONSTITUENTS AND THE PEOPLE
LIVING IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
SO YOUR SUGGESTION WOULD BE THE
END OPEN BURN.
THAT'S ALSO AND CRACKED AND I DO
NOT THINK IT'S VERY FAIR TO
COMPARE THE EMISSIONS OF THE
BIOMASS INCINERATOR TO THAT.
ON OPEN BURNING OR FOREST FIRE
THAT'S THAT'S THESE UTILIZATION
CONVERSATIONS THAT I THINK ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AT THE
GOVERNOR ALLOCATED ON TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
TO THAT SET THE BAR EXTREMELY
LOW FOR THOSE UTILIZATION CON I
CONVERSATIONS IF WE JUST SAY.
WE SHOULD PRIORITIZE BIOMASS
UTILIZATION THAT IS CLEANER THAN
FOREST FIRES IN OPEN BURNING.
THAT CANNOT BE THE SOLUTION.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO AGAIN
PRIORITIZE RESEARCH PRIORITIZE
INNOVATION AND IF WE PROP UP
BIOMASS FACILITIES FOR THE END
UNFORESEEABLE FUTURE WE'LL NEVER
GET TO A REALITY.
WHERE WE HAVE CLEAN ALTERNATIVES
THAT TO BUY MASS INCINERATION?
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND I JUST WANNA SAY REALITY IS
[inaudible]
IT'S BURDEN.
AND IT'S GONNA OPEN BURN WHETHER
WE DO ANYTHING OR NOT AND HAD IT
IT'S LIKE. TO ME OBAMA'S PLANET.
IS A GIANT MOUSE ON A FORCE FIRE
YOU JUST TAKE IT OUT AND PUT IT
IN THERE AND YOU ACTUALLY DO
WHAT WE DO WITH.
COMBUSTIBLE ENGINES WE PUT
DIFFERENT KINDS OF TECHNOLOGY ON
A SO WE REDUCE.
THE EMISSIONS THAT COME OUT SO I
FIND IT REALLY FASCINATING THAT
TIME.
HERE WE CAN WE CAN SIT HERE AND
AND AND AND HAVE THIS DISCUSSION
WE TALK ABOUT STREAMLINING
PROCESS WE TALK ABOUT TRYING TO
ACTUALLY PROACTIVELY.
AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY OF COME TO
SOME SORT OF A SOLUTION TO
SOMETHING THAT MAN CREATED.
AND WE CREATED THIS SITUATION BY
EXTINGUISHING FIRE THAT NOW
ACTUALLY.
SEND OUT A LOT OF THIS BIOMASS
SO -- WOULD
BE GREAT TO HAVE A SOLUTION
OTHER THAN JUST GOING BACK TO
THE SAME THING WHEN I ASKED THE
QUESTION THAT WE CAN'T HAVE.
THIS BIOMASS PLANT IN THE
CENTRAL ALLEY WHETHER THERE ARE
MANY SHATTERED PLANTS ALL OVER
THE STATE THAT ARE.
NOT IN USE THAT WE COULD USE
THIS MATERIAL AND AS A SHORT
TERM AT LEAST PREVENTIVE
MAINTENANCE FOR THE SHORT TERM
UNTIL WE COME UP WITH WHATEVER
THAT SOLUTION IS THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO TELL ME THAT.
I HAVE HEARD A SOLUTION BUT I'D
LIKE TO HAVE A LEASE SOMETHING I
KNOW WORKS TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR DUCKS.
YEAH THANK YOU ARM I AM.
I THINK THE MESSAGE WAS THAT
THIS.
MAY NOT NECESSARILY BE THAT
ANSWER.
AND I TO SHARE CONCERNED THAT I
WANT AN ANSWER.
WE NEED ANSWERS BOB BIOMASS IS
SOMETHING THEY HAVE USED --
IN THE PAST IT'S PRESENTED AS AN
OPTION -- I
WAS SO CONCERNED ABOUT ITS COST
AND A LITTLE A CONCERNED AS WELL
ABOUT -- ITS
EMISSIONS.
IF IT EMITS MORE THAN NATURAL
GAS AND ONE AND A HALF TIMES --
MORE THAN --
COAL FOR ITS PRODUCTION.
THAT WORRIES ME BUT I THINK.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS SOME
ANSWERS ON HOW TO DEAL WITH
THESE PROBLEMS AND I WOULD LIKE
TO GO BACK?
IF I MAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO OTHER DISCUSSIONS WE HAD
EARLIER THERE ARE SOME ANSWERS --
WE DO NEED TO HARDEN OUR HOMES --
AND WE DO NEED TO BRING OUR BEST
AND OUR BRIGHTEST PEOPLE
TOGETHER. TO TAKE A LOOK AT ALL
THOSE OPTIONS AND PUT THEM INTO
PLACE.
AND I AGREE THAT FOR THE LAST
HUNDRED YEARS WE'VE HAD A
PHILOSOPHY IN THIS STATE THAT
SAYS THE BURNING IS NOT THE
ANSWER.
WE NOW FIND OURSELVES WITH FOR
MORE BURN A BULL COMBUSTIBLE
MATERIAL THAN WE HAD EXPECTED
AND A CLIMATE CHANGE WHERE.
THE AVERAGE HUMIDITY FOR THE
CURRENT FIRES HAS BEEN ADDED I'M
TOLD 5%.
THESE ARE EXTRAORDINARY NUMBERS
SO WE HAVE. ZERO THAT'S NEVER
BEEN SO DRY WE HAVE AIR THAT'S
NEVER BEEN SO DRY WE HAVE
HUNDRED MILE AN HOUR WINDS.
WE ARE EXPERIENCING SOMETHING
THAT I DON'T THINK WE
ANTICIPATED FIFTY YEARS AGO --
BUT WE HEAR.
AND I THINK I IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IF WE DID HAVE --
SOME DISCUSSION I KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RESEARCH AND WHAT
HAVE YOU AND WHILE THOSE ARE
HELPFUL AND HOPEFULLY THEIR NEW
TECHNOLOGIES COMING ABOUT EVERY
DAY THAT WILL --
HELP US MOVE FORWARD --
THE IDEA TO YOU TALK ABOUT
PRIORITIZING DEFENSIBLE SPACE
PRIORITIZING AND HARDENING ARE
HOMES AND I THINK THOSE ARE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS --
AND WE AND THOSE ARE PRIORITIES
TO THAT -- I
AM HOPEFUL.
THAT WE ARE NOW BRINGING
TOGETHER THE BEST AND BRIGHTEST
PEOPLE FROM A LOT OF THE
LEGISLATIVE --
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE COME FROM --
COLLEAGUES OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY AS WELL AS SOME THAT WE
HAVE PROPOSED IN THE SENATE --
WORKING WITH THE EXTRAORDINARY
COMPETENCY OF OUR CAL FIRE
PEOPLE NOT ONLY IN FIGHTING
FIRES BUT ALSO IN WORKING TO
PREVENT THEM SO.
I APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL HERE
I'M NOT SURE THAT THIS EXCITES
ME AS I'D HOPED.
GIVEN THE DOWNSIDES TO IT AND
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
INDEED A LOT OF THESE TREES WERE
NEVER GOING TO GET TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE MILLION TREES SOME
OF THEM IN OBSCURE AREAS.
I LOVE THE IDEA BOB PERHAPS
EXPANDING OUR CONSERVATION CORPS.
AND HAVING A LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE --
HELPING US I'M NOT SURE THOUGH --
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE
COULD LOOK IT UP BUT THAT
THERE'S NO ONE ANSWER TO THIS
PROBLEM AND I THINK WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IS.
CONSIDER ALL THE OPTIONS AND
THEN I WANT TO THANK A IN SPITE
OF THE FACT THERE ARE TWO NEW
WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN HERE AND I
THINK THAT THERE IS SOME SORT OF
STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT WHETHER IT'S IN OUR
FIRE AGENCIES OR OF TALK.
TO ACHIEVE PIMLOTT ABOUT THAT ON
MORE THAN ONE OCCASION I CAN
ASSURE YOU --
WE REALLY DO NEED TO BRING
TOGETHER THE GREAT IDEAS AT US
OTHER STATES HAVE DONE TAKE A
LOOK AT THEM IN THE CONTEXT OF
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO US IN
CALIFORNIA.
THEN TAKE THE SCIENCE IN THE
EXPERTISE AND MOVE THIS BALL
FORWARD OUTGOING FOR NOW I WOULD
LIKE -- THAT
THE OUR ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY
BE PART OF THAT DISCUSSION AND
SOLUTION AS WELL.
SO WITH THAT I I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THOSE
THOUGHTS.
NO DISRESPECT FOR ALYSSA
PROTECTS TAKES TO BEAUTY EQUAL
ONE CATHERINE PHILLIPS
[inaudible]
THROUGH ITS --
FIRST BY POACHERS I'D STEPPED
OUT SO IF THIS WAS ANSWERED MY
APOLOGIES BUT QUESTION ABOUT IS
HERE -- IS
THERE ANY DATA ABOUT THE LEVEL
OF ADMISSIONS FROM BIOMASS
VERSES OPEN BURNING I THINK.
MISS I THINK SOMEBODY MAY HAVE
ALLUDED TO THAT.
YEAH I'M GLAD YOU ASKED THE
QUESTION --
IT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED TIMES
DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF DIRECT
COMBUSTION THAT HAS EMISSIONS
CONTROL EQUIPMENT AND WHEN WE
START TALKING ABOUT.
GASIFICATION PROCESS SEE SOME OF
THOSE ARE EVEN CLEANER.
SO IT'S CRITICAL TO UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S THERE'S A HUNDRED
TIMES.
DIFFERENCE AND SO THE OTHER
THING IS THAT WE TALK OUGHT TO
BIOMASS OR NOT MASS I
HOPE WE DON'T LOSE SIGHT OF THE
WE ALSO ARE TALKING ABOUT.
OTHER PRODUCTS THAT CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE WHERE WE'RE TAKING
SMALL MATERIAL WE CAN MAKE POLLS
WE CAN MAKE OTHER MATERIALS AND
THEN WERE WERE ACTUALLY.
DEVELOPING VALUE ADDED PRODUCTS
WHICH CREATE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES CREATE WORK
OPPORTUNITIES ALL FOREST WASTE
IS NOT WASTE.
IT CAN BE USED IN DIFFERENT WAYS
CHIPS ARE JUST ONE WAY AND I'M
NOT SAYING THAT WE SHOULDN'T
HAVE SOME BIOMASS OPPORTUNITIES
A SERIOUS STUDENTS LOOKING AT
THAT.
AS ARE MANY OTHER --
OF OUR PARTNERS SO THERE ARE
DIFFERENT PROCESSES AND I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
WE ARE NOW ON TO THE NEXT
GENERATION OF BIOMASS FACILITIES.
TO ESPECIALLY AS WE LOOK AT THE
BY ON THAT PROCESS AND THE
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO PROJECTS THAT
ARE COMING ON SO.
BIOMASS BIOMASS BOILERS FAR FAR
CLEANER THAN JUST OPEN FILE
BERNIE.
THIS EPISODE REMEMBER WOULD GIVE
IT MIGHT --
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
PUTS IT SIMPLY THIS WAY.
BIOMASS ENERGY IS 98% LESS
POLLUTING THAN WILD FIRE OR
CONTROLLED BURNS.
IF I COULD.
QUALIFY TO THROUGH THINGS HERE
JUST TO NOTE SO ONE THING YOU
NOTED THERE WAS MUCH CLEANER IS
GASIFICATION --
BUT WE ARE RIGHT NOW TALKING
ABOUT GASIFICATION OF THE FUEL
WERE TALKING ABOUT TAKING THE
FUEL PUTTING IN A TRUCK IN
SHIPPING --
I I DO THINK A LOT OF ARE AND DO
YOU NEED TO BE DONE AROUND
GASIFICATION ON MOST OF THE COST
OF SHIPPING BIOMASS IS ACTUALLY
SHIPPING WATER THE WOOD HAS LOTS
OF WATER IN A THAT OBVIOUSLY IS
NOT.
COMBUSTION EVER BUT YOU HAVE TO
PAY FOR THE WEIGHT OF THAT THE
MORE WE CAN DO RESEARCH.
TO REDUCE THOSE COSTS --
THE MORE YOU'RE GONNA LOWER THE
OVERALL COST OF THE BIOMASS IN
POTENTIALLY THE OVERALL MISSION --
MOSTLY NOW SAYS INACTION NOT
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT --
A HEARTBEAT DID.
TOO ASSUMED FOR THE TRUCKING
BECAUSE THE ANALYSIS WE'VE DONE
ON GHG EMISSIONS --
LOOKING AT IT COMPARED TO OTHER
RENEWABLE OR OTHER ON ENERGY
RESOURCES --
WHICH IS DIFFERENT.
BUT ONCE YOU GET BEYOND TWENTY
TO THIRTY MILES OF SHIFTING THE
ADMISSIONS FROM THE TRUCKING GET
SO HIGH.
THAT THAT STARTS TO DRIVE IT OUT
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS IS
BIOMASS IS A SOLUTION FOR GHG WE
ALSO HAVE TO FOCUS ON BIOMASS
BEING CLOSE TO THE FUEL SOURCE
AND NOT LONG --
TRUCK.
BUT IF I APPRECIATE THAT I THINK
I THINK I THINK WE RECOGNIZE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT AS WELL BUT BUT
SHOULD WE NOT I MEAN LOOK I AM
NOT LOOKING AT BIOMASS AS THE
SAVIOR FOR THE ENERGY INDUSTRY
HERE OKAY.
I'M NOT NOT EVEN CLOSE TO THAT
BUT WE HAVE A DISPOSAL ISSUE FOR
GOING TO BE DOING MANAGEMENT.
SO IF WE DO NOT CREATE USE IT
FOR AT THROUGH THROUGH THE PILE
TO BIOMASS AS AN ENERGY SOURCE.
AND WE LEAVE IT IN THE FOREST
IT'S STILL RELEASES METHANE
WHICH IS A SHORT TERM POP
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS SO SO.
YOU KNOW AT SOME POINT HAD WE
YOU KNOW WE GOTTA FIGURE OUT ALL
THE NUMBERS HERE TO REALLY FIND
OUT FIGURE OUT WHAT'S WHAT'S
REALLY REALLY COST EFFICIENT --
IN YOU MENTIONED YOU MENTIONED
SOMETHING THAT YOU AND I
APOLOGIZE I WAS TRYING TO FOLLOW
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THE THREE MEGAWATTS A FIVE
MEGAWATT BIOMASS PLANTS AND AND
ST YOU TALK ABOUT STEVE'S ABOUT
STREAMLINING.
THINGS.
YEAH THERE'S THERE'S TWO THINGS
IN THEIR ONE AND I THINK IF
YOU'RE WELL AWARE --
THERE IS LEGISLATION --
FOR THE BIO MAT PROGRAM TO MOVE
THE SIZE OF THE PROGRAM'S FROM
THREE MEGAWATTS FROM THREE MEG
WHAT THE FIVE MEGAWATT.
ON THAT'S BEEN IMPLEMENTED ON
FOR BIO MAP FACILITIES --
YET THEY NOW CAN BE UP TO FIVE
MEGAWATTS INCISORS A RESTRICTION
ON HOW MUCH THEY CAN EXPORT TO
THE GRID.
ON BY STATUTE BUT THE FACILITY
ITSELF CAN BE FIVE MEGAWATTS
INSIDE THE OTHER STREAMLINING
ISSUE [inaudible]
I'M IS.
ONGOING AND LEAST AND IN MY
WORLD SEEMING ALMOST NEVER
ENDING IS THE STREAMLINING OF
THE INTERCONNECTION.
I MEAN THIS IS A TRUE JUST FOR
BIOMASS IT'S TRUE --
FOR ALL SMALLER DISTRIBUTED
GENERATION OUT THERE THAT THE
INTERCONNECTION PROCESS TO THE
GRADE -- IS
[inaudible] FOR SMALL
UNSOPHISTICATED DEVELOPERS
HAVEN'T BEEN IN THEENERGY --
INDUSTRY FOR A LONG TIME CAN BE
VERY COMPLICATED --
AND HAS A LOT OF STEPS TO IT IN
A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY IN SO THEY
CAN YOU SEE FOR MANY YEARS NOW
HAS BEEN TAKING.
YEAH STEPS THROUGH YOUR FIRST
TRYING TO FIND COMPROMISES AMONG
ALL THE PARTIES TO STREAMLINE IT
AND NOW MOVING MORE --
TO NO TOUGHER DECISIONS OUT
THERE WE'VE ALSO ADDED STAFF I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR
FOR GIVING US MORE STAFF WHO ARE
FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON
INTERCONNECTION INTERCONNECTION
DISPUTE RESOLUTION.
ON SO THAT WE CAN BETTER ON
NAVIGATE WHEN THERE ARE THIS
DISPUTE RESOLUTIONS BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY.
I THINK THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
THE SMALLER FACILITIES ARE GOING
TO FACE --
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE CLOSE TO THE
FUEL SOURCE ARE USUALLY NOT
CLOSE -- TO
ROBUST DISTRIBUTION SAYS.
IT'S IT'S A VERY EXPENSIVE
PROCESS TO INTERCONNECT AND
THAT'S IN THE YOU KNOW --
TWO TO THREE MILLION DOLLAR
RANGE FOR THE INTERCONNECTIONS
AND THAT CAN DRIVE.
THAT COULD BE THE DIFFERENCE OF
THESE PROJECTS BEEN PROFITABLE.
WHEN I GO BACK TO A COMMENT MADE
IN EARLY HEARING IN A WEEK WE
HAD A VERY SMALL BUILD TWEAK
PART OF THE SYSTEM?
FORCED WAITS ON STREAMLINING IS
IT WHILE IT WAS THE WAY TO YEARS
FOR THE RAGS ON THAT SO.
I'M LOOKING FOR THE MORE.
STREAMLINING.
QUITE FRANKLY YEAH ON ONE THING
I CAN SAY ON THAT IS THE THE
PIECE OF THE BILL THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING BACK ON IMPLEMENTED VERY
QUICKLY --
WE ALSO GOT CAUGHT IN A FEDERAL
LAWSUIT UNRELATED TO THE BIO MAT
PROGRAM --
AND THAT --
ON P. YOU SEE WHICH SUIT ON A
PROGRAM IT'S CALLED REMAPPED --
THAT THE FEDERAL COURT LOOKED AT
IN THIS TOOK MANY YEARS TO MOVE
THROUGH FOR IN THE FEDERAL
COURTS AND US AND VERY RECENTLY
LAST DECEMBER FEDERAL COURT AND
SAN FRANCISCO SAID.
STATES REMAPPED PROGRAM VIOLATES
FEDERAL LAW.
IN ISSUED AN ORDER AGAINST US TO
STOP ALL CONTRACTS UNDER THAT
PROGRAM.
THE CHALLENGE WE FACE IS THE BIO
MAT PROGRAM IN STATUTE
[inaudible]
IS 1100% BASED ON THE REMATCH.
SO THAT THEN CAUSED US TO HAVE
TO STOP AND GO SLOWLY AND MOVE
FORWARD VERY SLOWLY FOR A COUPLE
MONTHS TO AVOID FUTURE
LITIGATION.
ON THE BIO MAT PROGRAM NOW I
THINK WE'RE AT THE POINT NOW
WHERE WE CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE BY ON THAT PROGRAM WHICH
SEPARATED ENOUGH FROM THE WE MAP
OF RAM --
BUT IT DID CREATE --
A BIG BECAUSE IT THE COMMISSION
ON A NUMBER OF THINGS WE WERE
TRYING TO DO IN THE EARLY PART
OF THIS YEAR --
MY FINAL QUESTION JUST OF THIS
YEAR SIERRA CLUB FOLKS.
IS THE ENVIRONMENT OTHER IS
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY FLATLY
OPPOSED TO BIOMASS [inaudible]
BORIS.
UP I CANNOT SPEAK FOR THE ENTIRE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY.
UP THAT I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THERE IS ON LARGE SCALE
ESPECIALLY NATIONALLY --
LARGE SCALE OPPOSITION. TO OUT
BY A MASS INCINERATION AND AND
IN FACT THAT LIKE I MENTIONED
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AIR QUALITY
COALITION HAD A LOBBY DAY.
I JUST A WEEK AGO AND THIS IS
ONE OF THEIR KEY ISSUES THAT
THEY BROUGHT INTO --
TO LEGISLATOR SO IT'S DEFINITELY
A CONCERN [inaudible]
ARMONK.
VAST SWATHS OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY [inaudible]
OKAY -- OKAY
THANK YOU I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
TO MAYBE DRIVE NORTH AND SEE
WHAT IT'S LIKE TWENTY MILES FROM
HERE AND KEEP GOING.
SEE WHAT FORCE FIRES ARE DOING
AND THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISSOURI'S.
SO I LOOKED HER.
I JUST WISH THAT I I DO WANT TO
COMMENT THAT THE CHIEF --
PIMLOTT.
THE THINGS HE MENTIONED.
WAS THAT FIRE PREVENTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS OR BY
MAIL PROTECTIONS.
ARE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO REMEMBER
THAT OTHERS A LONG HISTORY OF
NOT JUST THIS YEAR CLUB BUT MANY
OF THE OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS THAT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
WHAT EVERYBODY ELSE'S BREATHING
WE ARE DEALING WITH SOMETHING
VERY DIFFERENT NOW AND WE DO
HAVE TO RE EVALUATE?
ALL OF THE DETAILS.
I THINK THAT WE ARE CHARGED WITH
MAKING DIFFICULT.
SOLUTIONS IT DIFFICULT PROPOSALS.
NOT PERFECT PROPOSALS.
AND I I I I KNOW THAT IF WE WERE
TO PUT TOGETHER PERFECT
PROPOSALS.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US WOULD BE
ON THIS ON THIS.
PART OF THIS GROUP SO I DO AGREE
WITH THE CENTER JACKSON THAT.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE TABLE SO THE
WE DISCUSS THESE ISSUES SO THAT.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS NOT?
IT IS SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THAT HAS TO BE DEALT WITH AYE IF
IT'S SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DONE.
IN THE FOREST RATHER THAN HAVING
TO TRANSPORT THE THE THE THE THE
BIOMASS --
IF IT'S DONE WITHIN IT WITHIN
THE AREA MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING
TO LOOK AT THERE ARE LOTS OF
LOTS OF POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS AND
AGAIN WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR
PERFECT SOLUTIONS.
BUT WE DO HAVE TO COME UP WITH
THE BEST SOLUTIONS TO TAKE CARE
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
AFFECTING US RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING SO
SERIOUS AND WE HAVE TO LOOK FOR
SOME SOLUTION [inaudible]
THIS MAYES.
I THINK HIS CHAIR OUT.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU GUYS ARE
HERE IT'S INTERESTING WE HAVE OF
ENVIRONMENT COMMITTEE WITH ALL
SCOTT FORCE YOU SAYS HE ASIAN.
AND THERE'S SOME TALK EARLIER OF
WHEN DOWN THAT CHIEF HIM UP THAT
WHAT WHAT WAS HERE AND I KNOW
THAT -- THAT --
SOME MEMBER DALY LEADER DALAI
AHEAD ASK SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
SOME BILLS THAT HE'S INTRODUCED
OVER THE YEARS.
AND WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
SCIENCE IS THERE.
IS THERE ANY DOUBT THAT WE HAVE
OVERGROWN FORESTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY.
DO DO YOU GUYS BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE OVERGROWN FORESTS IN IN
CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN -- I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE ENTIRE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY.
AND I AM MYSELF NOT A FOREST
ECOLOGIST [inaudible]
AND IT'S ALL THE OF THAT ANSWER
AT THAT.
BUT NO I I DON'T KNOW.
SO.
THE SIERRA CLUB DOESN'T TAKE A
POSITION AT ALL IN REGARDS TO
WHETHER WE HAVE OVERGROWN FOR
SOME OF THE SIERRA CLUB.
IS ONE OF THE MOST STORIED
ADVOCACY IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND SPECIFICALLY IN REGARDS TO
BOTH OUR PUBLIC LANDS ARE
PRIVATE LANDS ARE YOU SAYING
THAT THE SIERRA CLUB DOES NOT
TAKE A POSITION.
IN REGARDS TO WHETHER WE HAVE
OVERGROWN FORESTS.
AGAIN I'M NOT SAYING THAT --
I THINK THAT THERE IS SOME
DISAGREEMENT ON HOW WE SHOULD
MANAGE THOSE FORESTS AND
DEFINITELY WE NOW.
WE AGREE THAT THERE ARE THERE'S
BEEN YEARS AND YEARS OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION THE FORCE ARE OVER
GROUND I THINK SIERRA CLUB.
WE TAKE A DIFFERENT LOOK AT ON
FORCE MANAGEMENT FIRE MANAGEMENT
BUT I'M THE BIOMASS ORGANIZER
NOT A FORCE MANAGEMENT EXPERTS.
IT DIDN'T AND OF COURSE THE
REASON WHY I'M ASKING IS QUITE
WISH WE HAD SOMEBODY COME FROM
YOUR ORGANIZATIONALLY SOMEWHAT
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY THEN THAT BOMB. FOR
YEARS HAS BEEN ADVOCATING THAT
WE DON'T TOUCH NAM ARE ARE ARE
BOTH PUBLIC LANDS AND AND
PRIVATE LANDS.
WE HAVE PROBLEMS NOW BECAUSE
BECAUSE OF THAT.
YOU KNOW THE REALITY IS IN
REGARDS TO THIS PARTICULAR
PROBLEM AND WE TALK ABOUT --
INVERSE CONDEMNATION WHICH WE'VE
ALREADY HAD SOME DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT.
THE STATE TAKES SOME LIABILITY
AS WELL IT'S NOT JUST CLIMATE
CHANGE ALTHOUGH I DO THINK THAT
WE DO HAVE A DIFFERENT CLIMATE
TODAY AND I'VE I'M SOMEBODY AS A
REPUBLICAN WHO BELIEVES THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
I'M ISRAEL AND WE HAVE TO BEGIN
TO DEAL WITH --
WITH WITH DO WITH TO DEAL WITH
THAT.
AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE TO COME
TO GRIPS THE FACT THE STATE.
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS AND IT
COULD BE IT COULD BE THAT AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS WE HAVEN'T HAD
THE COURAGE TO BE ABLE TO STAND
UP TO SOME FOLKS TO SAY ENOUGH
IS ENOUGH.
SO THE QUESTION FOR ME IS ARE WE
GOING TO TODAY STAND UP BECAUSE
JUST LIKE DOCTOR WHAT TALKED
ABOUT IN HIS DISTRICT HE'S GOT
FOLKS.
THAT HAVE FEARED FOR THEIR LIVES
IF PEOPLE THAT HAVE DIED HERE IN
THE STATE BECAUSE OF THAT
BECAUSE OF OVERGROWN FORESTS AND
IT'S AMAZING TO ME THAT WE CAN'T
COME TO FACT.
WE CAN'T COME TO GRIPS WITH THE
SCIENCE AND THE SCIENCE SAYS
THAT WE HAVE OVERGROWN FORCE IT
WOULD BE GREAT.
IT WOULD BE GREAT.
IT WOULD BE GREAT AS A A AS A
COMMUNITY AND IT WOULD BE GREAT
IF THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMITTEE ALONG WITH OTHERS
WOULD LOOK AT THE SCIENCE AND
SAY.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH IT'S TIME TO
START GETTING SOME OF THOSE
FUELS OUT AND PART OF THE REASON
I WANT TO POINT THIS OUT IS THAT
WE HAVE A HUNDRED TWENTY YOU
SAID THIS A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
MILLION.
DEAD TREES IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
A LOT INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES IT WOULD TAKE TO BE
ABLE.
TO THE CLEAR TO CLEAR THOSE.
AND YET WE'RE GONNA HAVE MORE
DEAD AND DYING TREES BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T CLEARED ENOUGH WHAT DO
YOU DO WITH ALL OF THAT.
IT'S WASTE WHAT DO YOU DO WITH
ALL OF THAT FUEL WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING WITH ITS OF BIOMASS
ISN'T THE ANSWER.
THEIR WHAT IS THE ANSWER WHAT WE
EAT WHAT WE DO ABOUT THAT.
AND AND I LET ME JUST SAY I
THINK THAT.
THOSE ARE ALL FAIR QUESTIONS I
THINK THOUGH THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT OUR PANELS ARE PUT
TOGETHER WITH ADVOCATES FROM
VARIOUS POINTS OF VIEWS AND AND
SOME OF THEIR POSITIONS OR GOING
TO BE SORT OF BASED ON THEIR
THEIR PRISON AND HOW THEY SEE IT.
HOW WE ULTIMATELY GET?
S. WAYS TO MOVE FORWARD IS
REALLY FOR US TO TAKE THE
INFORMATION.
AND THEN YIELD TO WHERE WE THINK
IS THE BEST PATH.
A TO ADDRESS.
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN PRESENTED BUT I I'M
NOT.
IF YOU RAISE A GOOD POINT YEAH I
THINK I SHOULD TRY AND BY THE
WAY MY EX WASN'T DIRECTED
SPECIFICALLY AT ONE PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATION I'M TALKING ABOUT
US.
OF COLLECTIVELY AND AND AND I
THINK WE HAVE TO COME. TO THIS
POINT IN TIME WHERE IT'S IT'S
TIME FOR US TO STEP UP TO BE
ABLE TO TO GET REALLY TO THE THE
POINT AND RESOLVE THIS MATTER
AND IT'S GONNA TAKE SOME COURAGE
ON OUR SIDE. TO BE ABLE TO STAND
UP TO SOMEBODY STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS THAT DON'T HAVE A CHOICE
IN THE MATTER BUT TO CONTINUE ON
DOWN -- WITH
THE POSITIONS THAT THEY HAD IT
IT'S GONNA TAKE SOME COURAGE
THRUSTS HER FOR POINT --
SENATOR JACKSON'S JUST A VERY
QUICK VERY VERY SAID YESTERDAY
ARE FINE AND SENATOR DODD WILL I
HAVE A QUESTION CLOSE IT OUT AND
GO RIGHT.
TO THE PUBLIC COMES JUST LIKE TO
CLARIFY THIS YEAR CLUB HAS
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWELVE SIXTY SO THEY HAVE
RECOGNIZED THE NEED --
TO COME TO A DEAL WITH THESE
ISSUES AND THEY COME TO
RECOGNIZE.
THE NEED FOR THIS KIND OF FOR
TREATMENT THEY MAY BE OPPOSED TO
A SPECIFIC ISSUE AND I'M STILL
NOT CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
WHETHER IT'S A BLANKET
OPPOSITION OR BASED UPON
SUGGESTIONS AS TO HOW TO MOVE IT
FORWARD BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT.
AND I HAVE.
INTERVIEWED IN TALK TO VIRTUALLY
ALL OF THEM ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THAT EFFORT.
TO TO TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM AND
TO RECOGNIZE IT'S NOT A PERFECT
SOLUTION EVERYBODY'S GOING TO
HAVE TO GIVE A LITTLE SO I'D
LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT IF I MAY.
OKAY I I'VE GOT A QUESTION.
CENTER AYE I HAVEN'T HEARD THAT
TODAY SO --
I HOPE WE GET MORE COOPERATION
AND A MORE ARTICULATION OF WHAT
THAT COOPERATION WHAT THOSE
POTENTIAL PROGRAMS AND SOLUTIONS
ARE TO THESE PROBLEMS.
THE FACT THAT WE'VE GOT A
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION DEAD
AND DYING TREES OUT THERE I
DON'T CARE HOW DAMN REMOTE THESE
TREES ARE.
WHEN WE GET DOWN TO ABOUT THIRTY
MILLION MAYBE ALL BE --
PLUS WITH THE THE THOUGHT THAT
WE CAN'T POSSIBLY GET THE LAST
THIRTY MILLION.
BUT THAT TO DO NOTHING ON THIS.
AND USE THAT AS AN EXAMPLE OF
WHY WE SHOULDN'T DO THIS IS KIND
OF MIND BLOWING TO MAY.
AND THEN FINALLY I LIKE TO SEE
SOME STUDIES DONE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY'S AIR QUALITY SIXTY DAYS
IN A ROW WHAT IS THAT BEEN LIKE
DOWN THERE AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND WHAT IS THAT REALLY
ME.
WERE I IT'S A RHETORICAL
QUESTION BUT YOU KNOW THAT THE
REALITY WITH THIS NEW NORMAL
WHAT EVERYBODY'S BREATHING
PRACTICALLY IN THE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE GOT TO COME TO GRIPS WITH
A LOT OF THESE --
REALLY SERIOUS PROBLEMS
ENVIRONMENTALLY FOR SOCIAL DIED.
IT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES I GET THAT BUT NOW
IF IT APPLIES TO EVERYBODY NOT
JUST THOSE.
COMMUNITIES WERE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER AND THAT.
AND I THINK TO SENATOR JACKSON'S
EARLIER POINT THAT'S THE ONLY
WAY WE'RE GONNA GET OUT OF IT IS.
TO EVERYBODY TO COME TOGETHER SO
THAT I REALLY WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PANEL MEMBERS TODAY THANK
YOU FOR TAKING YOUR TIME.
IN BEING HERE AND SHARING YOUR
IDEAS WE'RE GONNA PUBLIC COMMENT.
I WE GO THROUGH A LITTLE RULE
MAKING ON PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
THOSE GUYS OBVIOUSLY NO ONE
LAUGHED AT MY INITIAL JOKE.
SO YOU WERE HERE FOR THE
PREVIOUS --
PUBLIC COMMENTS WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS A MINUTE EACH.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET OUT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO GIVE
EVERYBODY THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO TALK AND WE ALSO WANT RESPECT --
THE TIME FOR THAT FOR EVERYBODY
THAT'S IN THE ROOM IN THE PANEL
MEMBERS.
BUT IF SOMEBODY'S ALREADY SAID
WHAT YOU SAID COULD YOU PLEASE
SAY I ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS --
WITH THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER OR
FROM SOME GROUP SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
GO AHEAD SIR.
I THANK YOU PAUL MASON WITH YA
SORRY PALMETTO PACIFIC FOREST
IN JUST BECAUSE A GOOD LAUGH
DOESN'T MEAN WE WOULDN'T HEAR
YOU THE OTHER DAY BUT I JUST
BRIEFLY WANT TO HIT --
THREE KEY POINTS HERE WANTED AND
WE'RE AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RESTORING RESILIENCE THE
LANDSCAPE IN A PARTICULAR FOREST
CONTEXT WHERE WE WORK --
CERTAINLY REDUCING THE DENSELY
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH PRESCRIBED
FIRE MECHANICAL THING IS IN THE
MEDIA THING WE CAN DO IN THE
SHORT TERM.
WE ALSO NEED TO GET BACK TO
THOSE LONG TERM CONDITIONS WHERE
WE HAVE MORE OF THOSE LARGE FIRE
RESISTANT TREES ON THE LANDSCAPE
SO THERE'D BE THREE LONG TERM
THINKING WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE.
I ROLLED INTO MY SECOND POINT IS
THAT ANY.
REAL WAY OF ADDRESSING THIS BILL
REQUIRE ONGOING STABLE FUNDING
SO WE CAN ACTUALLY BUILD
PROGRAMS WHERE LANDOWNERS AND
BUSINESSES CAN COME TO THE TABLE
YOU CAN'T BUILD A WORK FORCE IF
YOU DON'T KNOW THAT ANY FUNDING
TO KEEP DOING THIS WORK IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS.
SO THAT STABILITY IN FUNDING IS
EVERY BIT AS IMPORTANT AS THE
AMOUNT OF THE FUNDING.
AND THE FINAL THOUGHT I WOULD
LEAVE YOU WITH THIS THERE'S BEEN
SOME TALK ABOUT TARGETS AND YOU
KNOW.
HALF MILLION ACRE YOUR TARGET
THE FOURTH CARBON PLAY IT'S ONE
THING TO HAVE TARGETS IT'S
ANOTHER TO HAVE SMART TARGETS
YOU KNOW.
THE TARGET THE FOURTH CARBON
PLANS FOR ANY MANAGEMENT BUT
THERE'S A VERY BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THOSE ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE YOU KNOW THINNING IN GETTING
US ON A TRAJECTORY TO A
RESILIENT FOR US IN THE FUTURE.
FIRST IS A CLEAR CUT THAT'S
GONNA PUT US BACK INTO A FIRE
PRONE PLANTATION IN TWENTY YEARS
AS WE TO DISTINGUISH THOSE AND
MAKE SURE WE'RE GOING WHERE WE
WANT TO BE DONE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
JULIA ELEVEN WITH A BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA I'M
FORMERLY THE DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
THE RESOURCES AGENCY.
SENATE JACKSON I HAVE TO TELL
YOU THAT I JUST HAVE TO URGE YOU
NOT ONLY TO HAVE MORE WOMEN ON
THE PANEL BUT MORE EXPERTS THE
SIERRA CLUB IS NOT THE EXPERT.
ON EMISSIONS IF YOU TALK TO THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD OF THE
PLASTER COUNTY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT.
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT ANY
OF THEIR DISTRICTS AROUND THE
STATE.
AGREE THAT.
BOB USING FORCE WAYS OR
AGRICULTURAL WASTE OR ANY OTHER
WOULD WAYS IN A CONTROLLED
BIOMASS FACILITIES NINETY EIGHT
OR 99% LESS POLLUTING.
THAT AN OPEN CONTROLLED BURNS
AND EVER TALKING ABOUT FOREST
MATERIAL OR SHRUBLAND AROUND
YOUR HOME OR A POWER LINE OR
COMMUNITY A CONTROLLED BURN IS
NOT AN OPTION THE ONLY OPTION.
IS MECHANICAL SENDING AND
REMOVING OF THAT MATERIAL.
AND THE ONLY THING YOU CAN DO
WITH IT BENEFICIALLY IS THEN
CONVERTED TO ENERGY WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANTLY CLEANER.
AS THE JONATHAN'S THE SIERRA
CLUB SAID HE'S NOT THE EXPERT
AND YET HE CITED A STUDY IN A
HEALTHY WET FOREST IN
SOUTHEASTERN UNITED STATES.
WERE WHOLE HEALTHY LOGS WERE
THEN SHIPPED TO ENGLAND IN AN
OLD COMBUSTION FACILITY THAT IS
ACTUALLY NOT THE SITUATION
CALIFORNIA AND ITS IS
DISINGENUOUS TO USE THOSE SORTS
OF NUMBERS ABOUT COMPARING TO
COAL AND NATURAL GAS.
A STUDY THAT IS UTTERLY
IRRELEVANT FOR THE SITUATION
HERE.
I HAVE MAPS OF THE AIR QUALITY
IN CALIFORNIA LAST WEEK IT WAS.
AT UNHEALTHY AND HOUSE ARTIST
LESER --
LEVELS ALL AROUND THE STATE
ESPECIALLY WHERE THE WILDFIRES
ARE BURNING WILDFIRE IS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUE AND
WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
I HAVE A LONG LIST OF SPECIFIC
POLICY PROPOSALS ARE GIVEN TO
SOME OF YOUR STAFF.
I WILL SEND AROUND ALL THE REST
YOUR STAFF I'M HAPPY TO LEAVE
MAPS FROM THE U. S. A. P. A..
NEXT TIME YOU HAVE A HEARING
LIKE THIS PLEASE WORD AND THE U.
S. EPA AND THE REAL EXPERTS ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH OUR AIR
QUALITY IN OUR FORESTS.
THANK YOU PLEASE A SUBMIT
WRITTEN COMMENTS ARE SPLIT I'D
IT AND IF I COULD JUST CORRECT
THE RECORD THAT INFORMATION CAME
FROM THE P. YOU SEE GENTLEMEN.
NOT FROM THE SIERRA CLUB ARE ON
THOSE STATISTICS NO IT WAS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT CLUB WHO
WAS LIVE AUDIENCE COMPARED TO
THAT SELECT.
ORGANIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CHRISTY SURE
I'M A RETIRED STATE PARK RANGER
AS ON THE STATE PARK PRESCRIBED
BURN TEAM FOR TEN YEARS AND I
WORK AS A WILDLIFE BIOLOGIST IN
POST FIRE AREAS.
I I THINK WE'RE DEALING WITH A
LOT OF GOOD NEWS HERE.
IN THAT I THINK THERE'S ACTUALLY
A LOT MORE AGREEMENT THAN WAS
ROTH WAS WAS REFLECTED TODAY IN
OUR DISCUSSION --
FOR ONE A WE VISITED EACH OF
YOUR OFFICES TODAY AND LEFT A
MAP SHOWING THAT MOST OF THE
ACRES BURNING IN CALIFORNIA ARE
NOT ACTUALLY BURNING IN FOREST
AT THIS TIME [inaudible]
NUMBER.
TWO THERE IS A ROBUST AMOUNT OF
SCIENCE AND A GREAT AMOUNT OF
AGREEMENT THAT SHOWS THAT SNAG
FORESTS OR DEAD TREES ACTUALLY
BURN.
AT LOWER INTENSITY TWO YEARS OUT
FROM FROM TREE MORTALITY SO
REALLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
USING OUR OUR RESOURCES IN
CALIFORNIA THE DEAD TREES IT'S
GOOD NEWS REALLY ARE NOT MUCH OF
A FACTOR.
IN IN OUR IN OUR QUEST TO TREAT
WILDFIRE [inaudible]
I'M SO.
WE HAVE SOLUTIONS HERE I I'VE
HEARD SOLUTIONS WE WE CAN HELP
PEOPLE HARDEN THEIR HOMES THAT
SOMETHING YOU CAN IMMEDIATELY
TAKE BACK YOUR CONSTITUENTS NOW.
THERE'S A WHOLE BREADTH OF
SCIENCE HEALTHCARE YOU IT'S NOT
JUST FOR FIGHTING MY INDEX
FINGER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMETS.
GOOD AFTERNOON STACEY HEAT WITH
THE ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
THIRTY FIVE RURAL COUNTIES
STATEWIDE IN OUR COUNTIES ARE
WHERE MOST OF THE FIRES ARE
BURNING RIGHT NOW.
AND WE APPRECIATE THIS HEARING
TODAY IN THE TOPICS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED AYE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IS ONE OF OUR TOP
PRIORITIES YOU'VE ALL BEEN GIVEN
A LETTER AND BEEN SENT A LETTER
FROM US THAT HAS MANY
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS TOPIC.
WE WISH THERE WAS ONE MAGIC
BULLET THAT WOULD FIX THIS BUT
WE KNOW THAT IT TAKES THE WHOLE
SUITE OF ACTIVITIES.
FROM MECHANICAL THINNING TO
PRESCRIBE BURNS TO YES BIOMASS
UTILIZATION AND INNOVATIVE WOOD
PRODUCTS TO ATTACK THIS THING
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR A LONG TIME AND WE'D LIKE TO
SEE SOME GOOD.
UP A GOOD PLAN OF ACTION COME
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
WELL I'M CHAD HANSEN ON MEDIA
FOREST AND FIRE ECOLOGISTS WITH
THE JOHN YOUR PROJECT
[inaudible]
ON I DO RESEARCH ON THESE ISSUES
AND A DOZEN KEY IT QUESTIONS
WERE BROUGHT UP AND I ENCOURAGE
ANYONE COMMITTEE WANTS TO LEARN
MORE TO REACH OUT TO ME AND HAVE
A CONVERSATION BUT TO THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER OUR FORESTS
ARE.
ARE UNNATURALLY DANCE --
THAT IS A REALLY SERIOUS
MISCONCEPTION.
WITH THAT THE SCIENCE TELLS US
THAT WE HAVE SLIGHTLY MORE SMALL
TREES.
OVERALL ON CALIFORNIA SOURCE WE
HAVE FEWER MEDIUM TO LARGE TREES
OVERALL WE HAVE LESS BIOMASS ARE
FORCED NOW THAT WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY.
AND A LOT OF THAT'S DUE TO
DECADES OF LOG.
THERE'S A KEY STUDY ON THIS BY
BY MCINTYRE ALL TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN I'VE DONE RESEARCH ON
THIS IS WELL.
IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND THAT THE SECOND THING
IS THAT --
OVERWHELMINGLY FIREBIRD NOT BY
FOREST'S DENSITY OR OVERALL --
THE BIOMASS DENSITY --
OFTENTIMES WHEN FORCE OR LOG
THEY TEND TO BURN MORE INTENSELY
WE DID THE BIGGEST STUDY EVER
DONE ON THAT CROSSING TIGHTLY
SEARCHLIGHT STATE THAT'S SIMILAR
CAN YOU TELL ME I DIDN'T GET.
YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU REPRESENT
YES I'M A DOCTOR CHAD HANSEN I'M
A FOREST IN FIRE ECOLOGIST WITH
THE JOHN IN YOUR PROJECT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT BEAKER.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRIS BURNS FROM THE
SIERRA BUSINESS COUNCIL AND WE
WORKED OUT THIS YEAR NEVADA --
ON THE ON ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL ISSUES I'M RUBBING
THAT THE OUTCOME OF THIS
COMMITTEE ACHIEVES AT LEAST
THREE THINGS.
ARE THE FIRST THAT IT PROTECTS
RURAL RATEPAYERS FROM BOTH FIRE
AND INCREASED --
REST ENERGY RATES --
THAT IT THAT THIS COMMITTEE
WORKS TO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
THE PACE AND SCALE OF FOREST
RESTORATION.
AND ALSO --
THIRD AYE CAPITALIZES ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL BENEFITS OF FUEL THINNING
IN BETTER FORCE MANAGEMENT.
HAD THREE THINGS LIKE BIO ENERGY
INNOVATIVE --
WOOD PRODUCTS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT PART OF THE REASON WHY
MCGUIRE MATERIALS ARE BEING SENT
TO BOMB US FACILITIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS BECAUSE MANY
OF THE RURAL ABOUT MASS
FACILITIES HAVE GONE OUT OF
BUSINESS AND ARE UNABLE TO TAKE
THOSE.
MATERIALS SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO
GET THOSE BACK UP AND RUNNING
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I REBEKAH AUGUST FROM THOSE
PARTIES FORCED WATCH --
STUDIES SHOW THAT THE MORE WE DO
TO MAKE REMOTE COMMERCIAL
PROJECTS.
WHICH TAKE THE LEAST FLAMMABLE
MATERIALS FROM THE FOREST OR
CONVERT NATIVE EDUCATE
VEGETATION TOMORROW FILE
MATERIALS THE MORE WE TEND TO
MAKE FIRES MORE INTENSE OR
SPREAD MORE QUICK FARMER QUICKLY.
THESE APPROACHES ONLY MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL SAFER AND AS SOON AS
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE HOMES
CONTINUE TO BURN.
ON THAT BENEFIT WILL BE GONE.
THE FACT IS THAT FIRES HERE LIKE
WE'VE ALL SAID AND SORT OF
LAYING CONCRETE FROM MEXICO TO
OREGON WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING TO
STOP IT.
WHAT IS NEEDED IS STRONG SUPPORT
OF WHAT'S PROVEN TO PROTECT LIFE
AND PROPERTY LIKE SOME OF WHAT
HAS BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE SET
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOANS BILL
AND OTHERS?
PREVENTION SAFETY ADDRESSING
EMISSIONS SUPPORTING GRANT
PROGRAMS LIKE SENATOR JACKSON'S
PAYS CONCEPT ANOTHER INCENTIVES
THAT HELP INCENTIVES THAT HELP
RESIDENTS MAKE THEIR HOMES FAR
SAFE.
AND MAINTAIN THAT WAY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE MARTINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
CONVERSATION TODAY.
THIS REALLY IS OUR PRIORITY IN
THIS IN THIS ISSUE SOLUTIONS
OFFERED TODAY CAN REALLY GO TO
MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES MORE SAFE
WE ARE COMMITTED PARTNER WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE TREE
MORTALITY TASK FORCE THE FORCE
RESILIENCY GROUP.
AND PRESCRIBE VERNE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT BIOMASS THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT WE CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OPPORTUNITY NOW
TO MAKE PROGRESS ON THANK YOU.
PATRICK WELCH FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
ARE WE HAVE LONG SUPPORTED AS
WE'VE ARTICULATED THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION
TO THIS AND TO THAT END FOR
SUPPORTING A NUMBER OF BILLS
INCLUDING SENATOR JACKSON'S BILL
ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD SPILL.
OUT WHEN IT COMES TO BIOMASS
WINTER STAND THAT THAT CAN BE A
BENEFICIAL AND USE FOR SOME OF
THESE TREES AND VEGETATION
THAT'S REMOVED.
FROM OUR FORESTS WE HAVE --
OPPOSE PREVIOUS EFFORTS TO
CREATE A MANDATE --
THAT GENERALLY INCREASE COSTS ON
OUR REPAIRS SO WE ASK THE A
COMMITTEE WHEN CONSIDERING THIS
ISSUE TO TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT.
I HEARD MENTIONED AT THE CONCEPT
OF A SUBSIDY TO LOWER THE COST
AND I THINK THAT'S AN
INTERESTING CONCEPT TO EXPLORE
IF THIS IS.
AT THE ROAD THAT THAT COMMITTEE
INTENDS --
TO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JUSTIN AUGUSTINE.
I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING IN
PARTICIPATING IN FORCE PROJECTS
FOR OVER TEN YEARS NOW.
AND ISSUE THAT.
HASN'T BEEN DISCUSSED IN DETAIL
HERE.
THAT PERMEATES THIS THOSE.
WHO WERE TALKING ABOUT FUELS
TREATMENTS AND THINNING PROJECTS?
MY EXPERIENCE IS THAT MORE OFTEN
THAN NOT.
WHAT ARE?
WHAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING UNDER
THAT TERMINOLOGY?
THE TARGETING OF LARGE TREES
PROJECTS I PARTICIPATE IN AND
AYE BATTLE AGAINST.
OUR BECAUSE THEY'RE TARGETING
THE LARGER TREES AND THAT'S
ACTUALLY COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO
MAKING ARE FORCED BY RESILIENT.
INSIDE ASK YOU TO BE VERY
CAREFUL WHEN YOU'RE USING THAT
TERMINOLOGY TO BE VERY FOCUSED.
ON WHAT WILL ACTUALLY HELP SOLVE
THE PROBLEM AS OPPOSED TO JUST.
THROWING THOSE WORDS AROUND AND
END UP CAUSING MORE PROBLEMS
THAN YOU ACTUALLY SOLVING THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF THE
NEVADA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I WANT TO ECHO AND
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THE RC RC
AND SHE SAX HAD. ONE JUST AS
UGLY AGAIN CAUGHT THE NEVADA
COUNTY VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
ORDINANCE AS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF A
COUNTIES COULD BE DOING SHOULD
BE DOING TO GET ON TOP OF THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ISSUE.
BUT IT REQUIRES RESOURCES AND
THEN THOSE NEED TO BE ONGOING
RESOURCES I THINK MISTER KORDA
COULD SPEAK TO THE AGGRESSIVE
NATURE OF HE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ORDINANCE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD EVENING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE TO
COME BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL CALIFORNIA COTTON GIN
NURSING GROWERS ASSOCIATION.
AMERICAN PISTACHIO GROWERS IN
WESTERN ON PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING TODAY I
THINK THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS PACKAGE
IF ANYTHING COMES OUT OF THIS
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE IT NEEDS TO
BE HOW WE PREVENT THESE HUGE
FOREST FIRES.
A LOT OF THIS DISCUSSION HAS
BEEN ON COSTS AND THAT IS
BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING.
BIGGER FIRES BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT
TAKING CARE OF OUR FORESTS --
WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF BIOMASS
FOR AGAN FOREST RIGHT WASTE WE
AGREE THAT THIS SHOULDN'T BE A
MANDATE THOUGH BECAUSE THAT
WOULD JUST FURTHER INCREASE
COSTS SO LOOKING AT SOME OTHER
OPTIONS.
ALSO IF --
DAY COMMITTEE MEMBERS OR ANY OF
THE STAFF ARE INTERESTED IN
SEEING SOME OF THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY COMING OUT OF BIOMASS
RIGHT HERE IN WOODLAND WE HAVE
WEST BIOFUELS --
THAT WESTERN ART PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION AND UC DAVIS WORKS
WITH AND WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
SET UP A TOUR FOR YOU SO.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED PLEASE LET
US KNOW IT'S JUST A QUICK TRIP
FROM THE CAPITOL THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LIZ FORCED
BURKE I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY.
CALIFORNIA MUST BE PREPARED TO
FACE THE NEW NORMAL OF YOUR
AROUND WILDFIRES SCIENCE SHOWS
THAT ECOLOGICAL THINNING AND
PRESCRIBED BURNING TOGETHER CAN
EFFECTIVELY CHANGE BONFIRE
BEHAVIOR.
THEY TO CONSERVANCY SUPPORTS
POLICIES AND FUNDING THAT
INCREASES THE PAY SCALE FOR
THESE ACTIVITIES TO REDUCE
WILDFIRE THREAT.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THANKS --
SO MY NAME IS WILL ABRAMS I'M
HERE REPRESENTING MY FAMILY MY
COMMUNITY I'M FROM SANTA ROSA --
WE ARE GOT ALERTED TO THE FIRES
IN THAT AREA ON OCTOBER EIGHTH --
AS OUR HOME WAS BURNING AND
URGES BURNING IN MY KIDS WERE
SCREAMING THEY WERE GONNA DIE SO
THAT'S THE PERSPECTIVE THAT I'M
COMING FROM --
AND USUALLY AFTER SORT OF THE
INITIAL SHOCK OF THAT --
MADE --
BECAUSE OF MY BACKGROUND I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
WAS AN EARLY ALERT SYSTEM I
CALLED PGM NEED TO GET SOME
BASIC INFORMATION ABOUT THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT COULD BE PUT ON
POLLS FOR THAT --
I GOT ZERO ANSWERS ON THAT
SUBJECT LATER ON WHEN THE
REPORTS CAME OUT THAT SIXTEEN OF
THE FIRES WERE DEFINITELY CAUSED
BY PEACHY NEED EQUIPMENT AGAIN
CALLED PJ NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES IN MY?
COMMUNITY AGAIN I GOT ZERO
INFORMATION FROM THEM IN TERMS
OF INFORMATION THAT I COULD USE
A PROCESS THAT.
THEY ARE NOT RESPONSIVE --
IN THAT REGARD IN THE ONLY THING
THAT WILL MAKE THEM RESPONSIVE
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO MAKE
SURE THAT OCCURS.
THANK THANK YOU SIR.
CATHERINE PART OF AN AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION I JUST
WANT TO ASSOCIATE WITH MYSELF
WITH ALL THE COMMENTS THAT YOU.
HAVE MENTIONED TODAY I THINK
THIS IS BEEN AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PANEL DISCUSSION AND
ALL THE DIFFERENT PANELS AND WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
ADDRESSING THIS.
FIRE PREVENTION AND MITIGATION
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN WHITE HERE
WE HAVE THE TELEPHONE LICENSE
FORCES SOCIALIZATION AND THE
FORCE ANNALS OF CALIFORNIA OF
THE LICENSE FORCES SOCIALIZATION
ARE THE STATE'S REGISTERED
PROFESSIONAL FORESTERS.
SO THEY REALLY ARE THE EXPERTS
ON IMPROVING ON THE FORCE
MANAGEMENT THEY PROVE ALL THE TO
HARVEST PLANS AND THEY ALSO MAKE
SURE THAT THE THE WHAT'S ACTION
MANAGE.
WOULD ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH A
GORDON AND HIS COMMENTS A LOT OF
THINGS THAT HE WAS TALK ABOUT WE
WE WOULD AGREE WITH.
OF THE FOR SALE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL BE DIFFERENT THEIR SMALL
MOM AND POP.
THE LANDOWNERS THERE WHAT WILL
BE CONSIDER WE DON'T HAVE A
RESOURCE TO GO OUT AND DO A LOT
OF THE THE CLEARING THE BRUSH
MANAGEMENT SO WE REALLY HAVE AN
ECONOMIC ISSUE HERE.
BEST ESTIMATES OF ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF OF MAN'S LAND
OUT THERE BUT ONLY.
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND ACRES AT TO
BE MANAGED FOR A LOT OF REASONS
WE HAVE ABSENTEE LANDOWNERS WE
HAVE PEOPLE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCE TO GET IT DONE.
WE DO THINK THAT OPPORTUNITIES
SUCH AS BIOMASS WHICH COULD BE
PARTNER SOLUTION.
MAYBE MAYBE PART OF THAT BUT IT
REALLY IS AN ECONOMIC ISSUE I
MEAN WE HAVE TO GET.
FINALLY TO GET THE RESOURCES
SUBSIDY ISSUE I THINK WAS
MENTIONED MAY WE USED CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS TO SUPPLY SOME THE
COST OF THE TRANSPORTATION THAT
MIGHT BE ONE AVENUE.
PRESCRIBED BURNING ALSO IS A IS
A POTENTIAL ISSUE BUT THERE'S A
LIABILITY ISSUE WE LIKE TO HAVE
THAT ADDRESSES WILL [inaudible]
YOUR COMMENTS.
HELLO AMERICORPS OLSON A
REPRESENT --
LICENSE TIMBER OPERATORS AND
TRUCK DRIVERS AND OTHERS TO
BASICALLY DO THE WORK AND
BASICALLY TREES DON'T THAN
THEMSELVES MATERIAL DOESN'T COME
OF THE FORCE FLOOR.
AND DRIVE ITSELF THE BIOMASS
FACILITIES IN THEIR CONSERVATIVE
FEW OF OUR PEOPLE IN THIS
INDUSTRY THAN THERE USED TO BE.
I MIGHT ADD MOST OF THEM ARE IN
THE AGE PRACTICE THE FIFTIES AND
SIXTIES SO WE NEED TO REPLENISH
THIS WITH THE YOUNGER GENERATION
HOW USED TO BE DONE.
IS A SMALL BUSINESS FAMILY OWNED
COMPANIES GRANDPARENTS AND PASS
IT ON TO THE SONS AND DAUGHTERS
OF PASS IT ON TO THE GRAND
DAUGHTERS GRANDSONS BUT THEY'RE
NOT NECESSARILY SO INTERESTED IN
IF THEY CAN EARN A LIVING AT IT.
GET MARRIED RAISE A FAMILY AND
HAVE A LONG TERM SENSIBILITY
ABOUT.
SO DON'T FORGET US NOW WE'VE
SENATE ANY --
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION ABOUT
POLICIES WE SUPPORT WE'RE
CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION OR SEEKING
A THREE COMMUNITY COLLEGES RIGHT
NOW IN ALL SEGMENTS OF THE
NORTHERN PART OF CALIFORNIA BUT
I THINK PEOPLE SOMETIMES ASSUME
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO DO THIS WORK
ASSEMBLY THERE.
AND ACTUALLY DWINDLING THEIR
AGING AND WE SHOULD BE A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION AND WE ARE PART OF
THE FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE
AND I AM OF BILLS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MARIA GARCIA ON BEHALF
OF THIS AND ON THE LAND TRUST
I'M HERE TODAY A VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE CONVERSATION N ON FOREST.
FLORA ACTION VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AYE WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON DOING JUST THAT IN
THIS NUMBER VALLEY WORKING WITH
COUNTY AND STATE AGENCIES AND SO
WERE PARTICULARLY APPRECIATIVE.
OF THE CONVERSATION FOR I'M
ONGOING SUSTAINABLE FUNDING ON
THESE PROJECTS THAT THEY DON'T
AT NO PUN INTENDED SIMMER DOWN
IN THE FUTURE AND THAT THIS IS
AN INVESTMENT FOR THE STATE TO
DO ONGOING MEDICATION AND FIRE
PREVENTION THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOY DEAFENED BY AND
I'M A VOLUNTEER HERE AT THE
CAPITOL FOR A A RP.
THAT A A RP WERE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT FRAGILE POPULATIONS --
AND SO AS YOU CONSIDER
PREVENTION OPPORTUNITIES ALERT
SYSTEMS MANY OTHER THINGS THAT I
I KNOW YOU'RE CONSIDERING.
WE WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
TAKE IN CONSIDERATION
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE ARE
LARGE CONCENTRATIONS OF LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MOBILITY ISSUES
MAYBE MEMORY CARE FACILITIES
ASSISTED LIVING THOSE ARE.
ALL CONCERNS TO US --
AS A PERSONAL MATTER.
I HAVE THREE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN EVACUATED IN THE FIRE SINCE
LAST YEAR.
IN MY FAMILY TO WERE LUCKY AND
THEIR HOMES DID NOT BURN MY
YOUNGER SISTER HOWEVER LOST HER
HOME TO THE TYPES FIRE IN SANTA
ROSA [inaudible]
AND THEY RECEIVE NO ALERTS --
BUT THERE WAS NO RESPONSE FROM
THE FIRE DISTRICT.
AND THEY'RE NOW LIVING IN THE
COMMUNITY NORTH OF SANTA ROSA
[inaudible]
WHERE?
THE TREES HAVE SMOTHERED THE
OVERHEAD POWERLINES SO ANYTHING
YOU COULD DO. TO HELP BRING
ACCOUNTABILITY TOOK THAT ISSUE
IT WOULD BE GREATLY APPRECIATED
THANK YOU.
EVENING MEMBERS ISSUES MAY
ROBERT SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN --
WE'VE ALREADY SUBMITTED WERE
WRITTEN COMMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE PER YOUR REQUEST
SOLELY MAKE THIS VERY BRIEF SO
WE CAN LEAVE HERE THIS EVENING
ARE WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF ANY
EFFORT BY THIS COMMITTEE. TO
INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE OF
FORCE MANAGEMENT OPERATIONS AND
IN THIS STATE INCLUDING ANY
EXPANSION OF BIOMASS --
WE SOULFUL SUPPORT OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
SUBMITTED TO THIS COMMITTEE BY
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM RC RC.
UP THAT'S TRUE CALIFORNIA DOES
FACE AN UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL OF
WILDFIRE RISK AND WE CONTINUE TO
HEAR THE CONCERNS FROM OUR LOCAL
FARM BUREAUS AND MEMBERS
SPECIALLY MENDOCINO COUNTY.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON PROVIDING
SOLUTIONS TO OUR MEETING FULL
FORCE MANAGEMENT IN THE STATE AT
WILL HELP PREVENT THE LOSS OF
LIVES TO DESTRUCTION OF PROPERTY.
AND REDUCTION IN GHG EMISSIONS
THANK YOU AND THAT CONCLUDES THE
PUBLIC COMMENT I'D LIKE TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES.
THIS BILL LONG HEARING FOR
HANGING OUT HERE TODAY ALSO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR SPEAKERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS MEETINGS
ADJOURNED